COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING IT'D HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY HOWEVER I WILL NOTE
THAT WE HAVE NO MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. MEMBERS
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE
COMMITTEE ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONE TO COMPUTERS JUST REALLY
EIGHT ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. EVERY TIME YOU WANT TO
BE RECOGNIZED USED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND. I RECOGNIZE YOU. AND THEN
YOU GO BACK ON MUTE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE BEEN
ADMITTED WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE. INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED. ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. THE ROOM IS MUTED. I
APOLOGIZE FOR BREAKING IN BUT WE
ARE GETTING NOTHING HERE IT'S-
IT'S I THINK IT'S ON MUTE. I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR. OKAY. I LIKE
READING. HOW BOUT NOW PERFECT
SORRY FOR INTERRUPTING THAT'S
OKAY MOST THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE THREE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON RESPONSE THE COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY HAD TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO ROUTE OR
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TODAY WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. ALL MEMBERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING TODAY ARE HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY ARE DOING
THAT REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
AID IN ELIMINATING ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
BE RECOGNISED JUST USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE AND I WILL
CALL UPON YOU. AND THEN YOU
WOULD PLACE BACK ON ME TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTINCT
ALLOWS AND WILL ALSO BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING PROVIDE. PUBLIC COMMENT
THE PARTICIPATORY FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THAT
NUMBER FOR TODAY. IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO.
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS. PLEASE
REFER REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO PLEASE WAIT
THIS CAN ONLY BE A SHORT TIME
OFTEN AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONE TO RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE A MUTED
AND YOU ARE NOW. READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
BE THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE- HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
AND- ANY INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNCTIONS. AB
MUTED. IN TODAY'S HEARING WILL
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES. THE CAL
WORKS THE CALFRESH AND HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH A GROUP WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. NUMBER FOUR WE BEGAN I
WOULD ASK THE CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN VERIFY
WHO WHO WAS HERE. EGGMAN HERE
WHENEVER PAN YEAH GREAT NOTED-
CENTER PENDING EVERYTHING OPEN
COMMENT YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
BEFORE WE GET STARTED OKAY
HOMELESS BEGIN WITH AN OVERVIEW
PRESENTATION BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT FROM THEIR DIRECTOR
DAVID SCRIVNER. GOOD AFTERNOON
DIRECTOR. GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER
EGGMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M DAVID SCRIBNER
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT OR SEE A STATE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AN OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET IT'S B. C.
P. FOR THE COMING YEAR AND TO
PROVIDE UPDATES ON THE STATUS OF
THOSE NEW PROGRAMS. CSK WAS
CHARGED WITH IMPLEMENTING A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND JUST
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDE UPDATES ON
BOTH THE CALIFORNIA REGION
PAYMENT PROGRAM. AND THE FEDERAL
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
SYSTEMS PROGRAM. THE PRIMARY
FOCUS OF CSP'S THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DEVELOPMENT
OF PROGRAMS THE SERVANT UP LEFT
THE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS. LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED A DISPROPORTION
FINANCIAL IMPACT DURING THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THROUGHOUT
THIS PAST YEAR TUESDAY'S BEEN
FOCUSING ON SUPPORTING THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
OPERATE THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROGRAMS AS THEY HAVE ADAPTED TO
THE CHANGES BROUGHT ON BY THE
PANDEMIC. THESE LOCAL LEVEL
ADAPTIONS ADAPTATIONS INCLUDE
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
AGENCIES THE SUPPORT FOOD BANKS
THAT PIVOTED TO FOOD DROP OFFS
AND HOME DELIVERY. AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THE FARMERS
. LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AGENCIES
CREATED NEW WAYS TO DEVELOP IN
HOME EMERGENCY AND WEATHER IS
ATION SERVER. YEAH I'M PROUD OF
HOW CSP AND ITS NETWORK IS
ADAPTED TO MEET THESE CHALLENGES
. THESE DAYS ALMOST 1100%
FEDERALLY FUNDED FUNDING COMES
PRIMARILY FROM THREE FEDERAL
GRANTS. TO COMMUNITY SERVICE
BLOCK GRANT OR CDBG. THE LOW
INCOME HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR LIGHT HEAT. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY'S WEATHER
IS THE WEATHER IS ATION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. CURRENTLY
THE LARGER C. S. B. G. UNLIKE IT
GRANTS ARE BEING FUNDED UNDER
FEDERAL CONTINUING RESOLUTION.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED SIXTY SIX MILLION FOR
C. S. B. G. ONE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE MILLION FOR LIKE EIGHT.
EIGHT MILLION FOR THE DEAL WE
WEATHER RESISTANT WEATHER
STATION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM UNDER
THE REGULAR ANNUAL GRANTS
DISTRIBUTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BOB CST WON'T HAVE
FINAL WORDS UNTIL THE FEDERAL
BUDGET PROCESS HAS CONCLUDED.
FUNDING FOR THE REGULAR ANNUAL
GRANTS HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
STABLE OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
THAT'S SAD OVER THE COURSE OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN BENJAMIN CST
IS SEEN A SIGNIFICANT INFLUX OF
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING AS FEDERAL
GOLF DOLLARS OF AUGMENTED
REGULAR FUNDING LEVELS. UNDER
BOTH THE CONSOLIDATED
APPROPRIATIONS. I WOULD KNOW FOR
THE PUBLIC THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFERENCE DIFFICULTIES. HOLD ON
ONE SECOND DIRECTOR. WE DIDN'T
HEAR THAT LAST PART HOW HOW IS
YOUR CONNECTION WHERE YOU ARE.
MINE SEEMS GOOD. KERN HOLD ON
ONE SECOND. OKAY YOU SEEM TO BE
BACK ON. LET'S GO. OKAY IN A
POOL OF MY- WHO IS OVER AGAIN.
THE POLICY WITH- TWENTY TWENTY
YEARS ACCESSIBLE MIDDLE FUNDING
CST RECEIVED ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
NINE MILLION FOR C. S. B. G. AND
FORTY NINE MILLION FOR LIFE HE-
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE RESULT IN
AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
THREE MILLION OF FOR LIKE YOU.
THE TWENTY TWENTY CURES ACT
FUNDS HAVE BEEN PRIORITIZED TO
ASSIST LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
THAT HAVE BEEN ECONOMICALLY
ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. INCLUDING HOUSEHOLDS
WHO EXPERIENCE THEM I'M APPOINT
AN IMPACT. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE STATE BUDGET THE
SUPPLEMENTAL ARE POLITE KEEP
FUNDS ARE BEING PRIORITISED
TOWARDS FINANCIAL SYSTEMS TO
REDUCE ENERGY BILL REAR JUST.
ADDITIONALLY INSIST IS CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERING SEVERAL STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS. I'M GETTING
PAID I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL-
WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD CST
IS ADMINISTERING FIFTEEN MILLION
IN CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
GRANTS AWARDED TO COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFITS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THESE GRANTS
AWARENESS OF COUNTY IDC AND
OTHER TAX CREDIT BENEFITS AS
WELL AS FIND FREE TAX
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE. THIS
YEAR FUNDING HAS SUPPORTING
THIRTEEN GRANTEES STATEWIDE. CST
IS A MASTER THIS GRANT SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN. THIS IS LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM OR
LIE WHAT IS CURRENTLY FUNDED
WITH A MIX OF CAP AND TRADE
AUCTION PROCEEDS IN GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS. WHY WOULD AS A CALVARY
CLIMB INVESTOR PROGRAM THAT IS
PRICED AT THAT AS THE PRIMARY
GOAL OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IS THE ONLY PROGRAM OF
ITS KIND IN CALIFORNIA FOCUSING
EXCLUSIVELY ON SERVING LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. WITH NO COST
SOLAR PEAVEY SYSTEMS AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES. TWO
COMPONENTS OF WHY WHAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN OPERATION. THE FARM
WORKER HOUSING COMPONENT WHICH
SERVES LOW INCOME FARMWORKER
HOUSING AND THE MULTI FAMILY
COMPONENT WHICH SERVICES MULTI
FAMILY AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CEST RECEIVED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FROM FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
FARMWORKER HOUSING COMPONENT
WITH FIFTEEN MILLION
APPROPRIATED FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND. TO SUPPORT
THE MULTI FAMILY COMPONENT.
TUESDAY WILL BE UNDERTAKING NEW
PROCUREMENTS FOR LIFE FOR
LANGUAGE PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS
IN THE COMING MONTHS TO SUPPORT
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING. IN
ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE IN THE
PROPOSED 202-320-2220 UNSC HIS
MAIN IN THE PROPOSED TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET.
INCLUDES AN INVESTMENT OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR LANGUAGE TO
SUPPORT THE ACCELERATED
DEPLOYMENT OF AIR CONDITIONING
HEAT PUMPS. AND LOW GLOBAL
WARMING REFRIGERANTS IN
COMMUNITIES VULNERABLE TO THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT. FINALLY
THIS IS IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING A NEW THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM FOR GRANTS TO
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH FARMWORKER
RESOURCE CENTERS. SHE IS THE
ONLY HAS ONE B. C. B. THIS YEAR
AND THE BASIC YOUR QUEST THE
SHIFT OF SEVEN FULL TIME
POSITIONS FROM THE DEPARTMENT'S
TEMPORARY HELP LIKE IT. DIDN'T
APARTMENTS PERMANENT POSITION OF
AUTHORITY. REQUEST PROVIDED TRUE
OF THE POSITION OF FORTY TO
REFLECT POSITION USAGE MORE
ACCURATELY WITHIN DEPARTMENT
BASED ON MY JAVADI TENURE AND
WORKLOAD. THERE IS NO FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS REQUEST
BECAUSE IT'S A SHIFT THE
POSITION. OF AUTHORITY WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING
BUDGET. IT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CEST WAS ALSO GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPLEMENT TWO
MAJOR NEW PROGRAMS. FIRST THE
CALIFORNIA RIDGE PAYMENT PROGRAM
OR CAP. WHICH IS MEANT TO
ADDRESS THE HISTORIC LEVELS OF
ENERGY BILL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ACCRUED DURING THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. SECOND THE FEDERAL LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER SYSTEMS
PROGRAM WERE LIGHT WALK WHICH
WILL PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO REDUCE WATER AND
WASTE WATER DEBT. ACCRUED AS A
RESULT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ASCAP AND MY
ONE OR SUBJECT OF THE NEXT TWO
ISSUES ON THE AGENDA. I'LL PAUSE
HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE CST OVERVIEW I JUST PROVIDED
. BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANYTHING
FROM YOU. HI THIS DEBATE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
CONCERNS FOR MASTER HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A-
THE L. A- ANYTHING FROM YOU.
HELLO ARE YOU ON I YES SORRY I'M
I BELIEVE YOU CUT OUT FOR A
MOMENT- ANGELA SHORT WITH THE L.
A. L. JUST SAY AS DESCRIBED BY
CST THERE ARE NO NEWSIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATIONS PROPOSED- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND YOU TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET YEAR
ALTHOUGH THE DEPARTMENT WILL BE
CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT ITS
ONGOING PROGRAMS INCLUDING THOSE
WHICH RECEIVED A LARGE ONE TIME
FUNDING AUGMENTATIONS THE
CURRENT YEAR- AND REGARDING
CSG'S AT CSCS ONE B. C. P. WE
REVIEW THE PROPOSAL AND HAVE NO
CONCERNS- AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA AND DESCRIBED BY DIRECTOR
SCRIBNER THIS IS AS ZERO COST
PROPOSAL. THAT WOULD SHIFT
EXISTING POSITIONS- TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERMANENT POSITION
FORTY THANK YOU. AND HAPPY TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MUCH ARE GRANT ANYTHING ON
THE- NO I THINK WE'RE OKAY WERE
LOOKING FOR TO GETTING INTO ON
THE UP PROGRAMS. OKAY LET US
MOVE ON NOW TO THE SECOND AGENDA
ITEM IS AN OVERVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA. THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
ARE YOU READY TO BEGIN.
ABSOLUTELY. THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
ONE STATE BUDGET DIRECTED ONE
BILLION IN FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN AT FUNDING FOR THE
NEWLY CREATED CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH PAYMENT PROGRAM TO
REDUCE PASSED BILL BILL BILL
BALANCES INCURRED BY ENERGY
UTILITY CUSTOMERS DURING THE
KATKO THAT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS
IN THE UTILITY BILLS THAT WERE
SIXTY DAYS OR MORE PAST DUE FOR
ENERGY USE DURING THE PANDEMIC
RELIEF BILL PERIOD BETWEEN MARCH
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY. THREE JUNE
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE A CAP
BENEFIT. THE NEW CAP GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION NINE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION AND
FIGHT IN FUNDING WAS TO BE
EXPENDED BY PRIORITY GROUP. AND
THEREFORE PRAY RECORDS. FIRST
OUR ACTIVE RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS
AT RISK OF DISCONNECTION SECOND
ALL ACTIVE RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS
WITH PAST DUE BALANCES. THIRD
ALL INACTIVE RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS WITH PAST DUE BALANCES
ENFORCED. ALL COMMERCIAL
CUSTOMERS WITH PAST DUE
BALANCES. C. AS HE WAS REQUIRED
TO DISTRIBUTE ALL CAP FUNDING TO
ENERGY UTILITIES BY JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
ONE TIME SURVEY RESULTS FROM
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ESTIMATED TOTAL TOTAL STATE
WHITE ENERGY UTILITY REAR JUST
TO BE NEAR NEARLY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. IN THE ONE BILLION
CAP FUNDING WILL ADDRESS ROUGHLY
HALF OF ALL STATEWIDE ENERGY A
RELIGIOUS ACCRUED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. BILL RELIEF PERIOD. TO
GAIN A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CURRENT STATUS OF PAST YOU
BOUNCES AFTER ALL CAP BENEFITS
ARE APPLIED TO CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS. GST WILL BE SERVING
ALL UTILITIES ARE RECEIVING
CAPITAL CATION. THIS SURVEY WILL
CAPTURE REAR JUST FROM NOT ONLY
THE PANDEMIC BILL RELIEF PERIOD.
OF MARCH TWENTIETH TO JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT ALSO
INCLUDES THE PERIOD BEFORE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THE PERIOD
FOLLOWING JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. ZERO DE AND- COMPLETING
THIS REAR SIR. IN THE SPRING.
WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF RECEIVING A
CAPITAL OCCASION AND ENERGY
UTILITIES REQUIRED TO REPORT ON
CAP OUTCOMES FOLLOWING THE
DELIVERY BENEFITS THESE OUTCOMES
INCLUDE AMONG OTHER DATA POINTS.
THEY DON'T TOTAL FUNDS
DISTRIBUTED NUMBER OF CUSTOMER
SERVICE AN AVERAGE BENEFIT AND
SEE IF YOU MUST POST A STAT ON
ITS PUBLIC WEBSITE WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF RECEIPT AFTER ALL ENERGY
UTILITIES SUBMIT THE REPORTS TO
THE DEPARTMENT. FOR THE PUBLIC
WE'VE HAD ANOTHER LITTLE FREEZE.
EXPERIMENTATION I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY STATING HOW PROUD I AM
OF OUR SMALL DEPARTMENTS ABILITY
TO SUCCESSFULLY ADMINISTERED THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR CAP PROGRAM
UNDER SUCH A COMPRESSED TIME FOR
IT CST HIT THE GROUND RUNNING IN
JULY AND USE IT EXISTING STAFF
RESOURCES TO SUCCESSFULLY
DISTRIBUTE FUNDING THAT WILL
SUPPORT OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIA ENERGY
CUSTOMERS TO PAY DOWN THEIR
UTILITY DEBT. WHILE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAP STREAM
CSP'S CAPACITY IT WAS THROUGH
THE DEDICATIONOF THE DEPARTMENT
STAFF. CLOSE COORDINATION WITH
ENERGY UTILITIES AND OUR MEMBER
ASSOCIATIONS AS WELL AS THE CAB
AS WELL AS TO SEE IF YOU SEE. I
CAN FOR THE PUBLIC OR HAVING
SOME IN AND OUT. DIRECTLY BACK
IN A SECOND. CURRENTLY
REESTABLISHING CONNECTIONS.
GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF RECESS WE
TRY TO REESTABLISH OUR
CONNECTION. IF YOU CAN HEAR ME.
TO GO
BACK TO MISTER SCRIBNER AND YOU
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
SIXTY DAYS THE UTILITIES HAD
THÀNH TO NOTIFY. OKAY. LET'S SEE
SO THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO
DEPARTMENTS RESPOND TO DO TO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON CAP. THE
FIRST WHICH REQUESTED SHE IS DUE
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF UPDATE ON THE
ROLLOUT AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
CAP AND HIGHLIGHT THE
SIGNIFICANT SUCCESSES OR
CHALLENGES OF APARTMENTS FASTER
IMPLEMENTATION. I'D LIKE TO
START BY STATING HOW PROUD I AM
OF OUR SMALL DEPARTMENTS ABILITY
TO SUCCESSFULLY ADMINISTER THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR CAP PROGRAM
UNDER SUCH A COMPRESSED TIME
FRAME. CST HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING IN JULY AND YOU. TO PAY
DOWN THEIR UTILITY THAT. WELL
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CAP
STRANGE YES THESE CAPACITY IT
WAS THROUGH THE DEDICATION OF
THE DEPARTMENT STAFF CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH ENERGY
UTILITIES AND THEIR MEMBER
ASSOCIATIONS AS WELL TO SEE IF
YOU SEE THIS IS THE SUCCESSFULLY
DISTRIBUTED ALL CALIFORNIA TO
ENERGY UTILITIES BY THE JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DEADLINE. FURTHERMORE SINCE SHE
IS THE APPROVED CAP APPLICATIONS
ON A FLOW BASIS. QUALIFIED
CUSTOMERS HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
CAPITAL CREDITS SINCE DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. CAPITA
FUTURE BE APPLIED TO CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS ARE ONLY BASIS BANERJEE
CHILES INSISTED EXPECTS ALL GOT
FUNDS WILL BE CREDITED TO
QUALIFIED ACCOUNTS NO LATER THAN
EARLY APRIL OF THIS YEAR. THE
MOST NOTABLE CHALLENGES YOU
FACED WITH CAPITAL LIMITATION
WAS NAVIGATING THE COMPLEXITIES
OF SHARED UTILITY BILLING
SYSTEMS. AND ENSURING ALL
ELIGIBLE UTILITIES RECEIVE THEIR
SHARE OF CAP FUNDS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH PROGRAM RULES. JUST USE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE THOSE ISSUES
ALONG WITH CHALLENGES THAT
INEVITABLY ARISE WITH
IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM OF THIS
SCALE BY COORDINATING CLOSELY
WITH THE UTILITIES IN THEIR
MEMBER ASSOCIATIONS TO QUICKLY
AND COLLABORATIVELY ADDRESS
ISSUES AS THEY AROSE. ENSURE THE
CAPTAIN OF HIS RICH CUSTOMERS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THE SECOND
QUESTION A SUBCOMMITTEE YES YES
YOU DO DRESS WAS WHETHER
DEPARTMENT COORDINATED PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION WITH OTHER
SOURCES OF ENERGY UTILITY
RESEARCH ASSISTANTS AND IF SO.
DESCRIBE THE DETAILS OF THIS
COORDINATION. THE START IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY GETTING KERR
DURING THE KEPT THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC PREDATE THE
CAP PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE AFTER
THIS FUNDING IS DISBURSED. SEE
IF YOU SEE AN ENERGY UTILITIES
AND TAKEN A NUMBER OF STEPS TO
OFFER ASSISTANCE TO CUSTOMERS
ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. IT WOULD STRUGGLE WITH
UTILITY PAYMENTS AS A RESULT.
THIS INCLUDES DISCONTENT
DISCONNECT MORE TORRANCE PAYMENT
PLANS TO RAISE CUSTOMER DEBTS.
AND DISCOUNT PROGRAMS TO LOWER
ONGOING ENERGY CALLS. DURING
CAPS IMPLEMENTATION CSTS CLEVER
COLLABORATED CLOSELY WITH THE
CQC ENERGY UTILITIES COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS AND STATE
ASSOCIATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. AS WELL AS
PREVIOUSLY THIS CORONATION WAS
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESSFUL AND
TIMELY ROLL OUT OF CAPITALIST
UTILITIES A QUALIFIED CUSTOMERS
. OUTSIDE OF THE PROTECTIONS
OFFERED UNDER CAP. THIS IS
PROVIDED ENERGY UTILITIES AND
CUSTOMERS WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
OTHER SOURCES OF ASSISTANCE FOR
CUSTOMERS STRUGGLING TO PAY
THEIR UTILITY BILLS INCLUDING
CSP'S LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIANS CODE NINETEEN BRETT
RELIEF PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR RENT
AND UTILITIES TO INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIA RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS. HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE COVER NINETEEN PENDENNIS.
CSP'S LIE HE PROGRAM IS ALSO
PRIORITIZING TWO HUNDRED THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING FROM THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN ACT. TOWARDS FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS TO REDUCE ENERGY BILL
REAR JUST FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THE CAP PROGRAM AT
THIS TIME. WELL FIRST I'D I'D
LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I YES IS JULIA BAKER WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
SUMMARY OF THE CAP PROGRAM THANK
YOU WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH L.
A. L. THANK YOU ANGELES SHORT
WITH THE L. A. O. WE WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
CAP- MARCH QUITE A SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATION TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
BUDGET. AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS
MANAGED TO CONDUCT A STATEWIDE
ENERGY UTILITY A RESEARCH SURVEY
FIELD APPLICATIONS AND ALLOCATE
FUNDS ALL IN A TIMELY MANNER- WE
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THESE
EFFORTS AND ALSO KNOWLEDGE THAT
THE DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION
CST HAS ENSURING ON THEIR
WEBSITE. AB HELPED FACILITATE
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT OF
THE PROGRAM- WE'RE CONTINUING TO
MONITOR THE PROGRESS OF CAP.
PARTICULARLY AS THE PROGRAM NOW
ENTERS INTO THE RECORDING PHASE
AND WILL BE SHORTER REYES ANY
FUTURE ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE.
THANK YOU MAKE SURE YOU FOR YOU
WE FROZE FOR A MINUTE BUT I
THINK WE GOT WE GOT ALL OF IT.
AND DIRECTOR SCRIBNER'S NOT
OFTEN YOU GET A SHOUT OUT FROM
THE L. A- SO CONGRATULATIONS ON
THAT- I JUST HAD A FEW
QUESTIONS. JUST KIND OF FOR THE
PUBLIC TO SO THE PAYMENTS GO TO
THE UTILITIES CORRECT IT'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE CONSUMER. BUT
THERE WILL BE CREATED ON TO A
CONSUMER BUILT ON TO THE
CONSUMERS BILLS SO THE PAYMENT
DID GO FROM THE DEPARTMENT
DIRECTLY TO THE UTILITY. AND
THEN THERE WILL BE A CREDIT
OUGHT THAT WILL SHOW UP ON. EACH
ELIGIBLE A CUSTOMER'S BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN MY
SECOND QUESTION AROUND THAT IS.
WE SAID WE ARE PAYING IT DOWN SO
WE ARE WE ARE WE JUST. ARE WE
SPREADING IT OUT AND PAYING
PEOPLE'S. HOW MUCH THEY OWE DOWN
ARE WE PAYING IT OFF. FOR EVERY
INDIVIDUAL- OF A FAMILY AND THEN
GOING TO THE NEXT. THE NEXT
PERSON. IT WILL- IT DEPENDS BY
UTILITY- THE ALLOCATION- IN IN
SOME INSTANCES WOULD REPRESENT A
PERCENTAGE OF IT THE TOTAL OWED
BY A PARTICULAR CUSTOMER IT JUST
DEPENDS ON HOW LARGE THE AVERAGE
BALANCES. AND IN OTHER INSTANCES
IT WOULD BE ABLE TO- HAVE PAID
OFF ONE PARTICULAR. PRAYER
GROUPS- AMOUNT OWED. AND THEN
PUSH DOWN FURTHER. WHAT WE CALL
THE WATERFALL THROUGH THE FOR
PRIORITY GROUPS. AND PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF CUSTOMERS AS IT WENT
THROUGH. BUT AGAIN I DID GO TO-
PRIMARILY TO HOW MUCH WAS OWED
BY EACH PRIORITY GROUP- AND BY
UTILITY. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DIRECTOR. AT THIRTY PAN
QUESTIONS. Q. AND THE END OF I
MISSED THIS BUT YOU YOU
MENTIONED SO WE HAVE THE FOR
PRIORITY GROUPS- AND YOU
MENTIONED THAT ROUGHLY ESTIMATED
TWO BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
REAR SO- SO HOW FAR. DOWN THESE
PRIORITY GROUPS ARE WE GOING TO
YET- SO. IT SO WHEN YOU'RE
DISTURBING THE MONEY TO THE
UTILITIES. IS A ARE YOU GETTING
EVERYTHING I MEAN CUTTING
INFORMATION FROM THEM. IS IT
THAT YOU'RE EXAMPLE EVERYONE OF
COURSE YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY
THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY COVERED ONE
IN THE FIRST PRIORITY GROUPS AND
THEN WERE MIDWAY THROUGH THE
SECOND OR THIRD SO HOW HOW HOW
EXACTLY DOES THAT DOES THAT WORK
IN TERMS OF. GOING THROUGH
PRIORITY GROUPS IS THAT. IT'S
NOT LIKE DO YOU ALLOCATE AMOUNT
TO EACH UTILITY AND THEN THEY
SEE HOW FAR THEY CAN GO DOWN. OR
YOU SERVE SAYING OKAY WE'RE
PULLING ALL THIS DATA TOGETHER
AND THEN WERE. THEN EVERYONE IS
THE FIRST PARTY GROUP NO MATTER
WHAT UTILITY AND THEN WE GO TO
THE SECOND GROUP AT CETERA SO
HOW'S THAT WORK. YEAH YOU DID
GREAT QUESTION AND IT IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A COULD A COMPLEX-
KIND OF MATH PROBLEM AT. THAT IT
DID THE BASE IS ALWAYS COMES
FROM THE ARREARS THAT'S REPORTED
BY A PARTICULAR UTILITY. AND
OBVIOUSLY WE DID THE INTENT WAS
ALWAYS TO ADDRESS- 1100% A BILL
RICH FROM PRAIRIE GROUP ONE AND
ANYTHING THAT REMAINED WHAT WE
CALL WAS WATERFALL DOWN TO EACH
PRIORITY GROUP. AS THEY COULD BE
PAID OFF IN FULL. SO THAT THERE
WAS ALWAYS- THE FIRST BY THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF PRAYER YOU PAID
FOR- WITH THESE DOLLARS. NOW THE
COMPLEXITY COMES FROM THE FACT
THAT DIFFERENT UTILITIES WOULD
HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF A REAR
AGES AND A DIFFERENT ALLOCATION.
WHICH THEIR ALLOCATION IS BASED
ON A POLL PERCENT. OF THE-
REARRANGE. A STATEWIDE. SO SOME
UTILITIES AGAIN LIKE I HAD
STATED WOULD BE ABLE TO PAY OFF
1100% OF PRAIRIE GROUP ONE.
MOVING A PRAYER GROUP DETENTION
MOVE INTO THREE AND FOUR. THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AS AN
EXAMPLE. I DID NOT REPORT ANY
PRAYER GROUP ONE UTILITIES
BECAUSE AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
BECAUSE OF THE MORE MORATORIUMS
THE DISTRICT YOU SEE. NO
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMER WAS FACING
IMMINENT JUST CONNECTION AT THE
TIME THAT SURVEY WAS IMPLEMENTED
AND THAT APPLICATION. ALL FUNDS
THEN FOR THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES WOULD GO DIRECTLY TO
PRIMARY GROUP TO CUSTOMERS. BUT
THE L. U. ARREARS DATA WAS SO
HIGH. IT WAS ONLY ABLE TO
ADDRESS A PERCENTAGE OF EACH
CUSTOMER'S BILL AND EACH
CUSTOMER WOULD RECEIVE THE EXACT
SAME AMOUNT WHICH WOULD MEAN. IF
THE ALLOCATION. TO FOR EXAMPLE
P. GINNY WOULD ONLY HIT. JUST
LIKE THAT. BRAD I AND THAT AGAIN
THAT BENEFIT VARIES BY UTILITY
AND BY ALLOCATION ACROSS THE
BOARD ALL OF THAT INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE ON THE CSU WEBSITE WE
DO HAVE- A OF KIND OF A
SCORECARD- THAT EVERYONE COULD
LOOK AT AND SEE NOT ONLY WITH
THE ARREARS WAS THE ALLOCATION
AND THEN THE PERCENTAGE PAID TO
EACH OF THE FOUR PRIMARY GROUPS
OKAY SO THAT'S ALL AVAILABLE ON
YOUR WEBSITE. YES IT IS PER
UTILITY OKAY YES IT IS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S
MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE AND I WOULD JUST SAY. FOR
A DAILYO AND THEN- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I'M GONNA CALL ON YOU
EVERY TIME JUST BECAUSE- WE'RE
HAVING A LITTLE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND I DON'T HAVE IT
UP ON MY SCREEN SO I CANNOT SEE.
YOUR RAISE HAND ON MY ON MY-
LAPTOP SO MANY COLONY EVERY TIME
YOU DON'T HAVE TO JUST TELL ME
NOTHING IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING OKAY. ISSUE NUMBER
THREE DIRECTOR. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THIS IS ALSO
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW FEDERAL LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR MY WALK.
UNDERLIE WHAT CALIFORNIA WAS
ALLOCATED ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS FOR THE
RESIDENTIAL WATER UTILITY COSTS-
FEDERAL GUIDANCE I WALKED AS
MODELED ON EXISTING LOW INCOME
HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
PROCESS. THESE PROCEDURES AND
POLICIES. CONSISTENT WITH THE
GOVERNMENT FELT THE PROGRAM WILL
FOCUS ON ADDRESSING WATER AND
WASTEWATER RELIGIOUS FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT JUST TO RESPOND TO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON MY WALL
THE FIRST OF WHICH REQUESTED CST
TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF LAW I WANT. TO
HIGHLIGHT ANY SIGNIFICANT
SUCCESSES OR CHALLENGES THE
DEPARTMENT SPACE DURING PROGRAM
ROLL OUT. IN AUGUST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CEST FINALIZED THE
LIE WACHTER HALF STATE PLAN
AFTER STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS AND THE
DRAFT STATE PLANS RELEASED FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE RECEIVED
FINAL STATE PLAN APPROVAL FROM
FEDERAL OFFICIALS IN NOVEMBER.
CST CONTINUES TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I FEDERAL EXPECTATIONS
FOR PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION. CST
IS ALSO BEEN. MY WALK. IN COSTS
WITH AGENCIES THAT WILL PROVIDE
OUTRAGE INTAKE AN ELIGIBILITY
SERVICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
DEPARTMENT PLANS ON RELEASING
THOSE PROGRAM GUIDELINES FOR
FINAL PUBLIC COMMENT LATER ON
THIS WEEK. THROUGHOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF WHY WHAT CST IS
BEEN IN REGULAR CONSULTATION
WITH THE CPUC AND THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AS
THE BOARD IMPLEMENTS ITS ONE
BILLION DOLLAR WATER AND
WASTEWATER RESEARCH PROGRAM. THE
STATE WATER BOARD IS REPORTED
THAT THROUGH THEIR WATER
RESEARCH PROGRAM PAYMENTS
TOTALING APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ISSUE TO PARTICIPATING TOO MANY
WATER SYSTEMS. TO ADDRESS 1100%
OF QUALIFY DRINKING WATER DEBT.
WASTE REARS DATA HAS NOT BEEN
SURVEYED THE STATE WATER BOARD.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PANDEMIC RELIEF BILL PERIOD.
WELL I WANT TO PLAY A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN CLOSING THIS
GAP BY OFFERING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS CONTINUING TO
EXPERIENCE DIFFICULTY MAKING
PAYMENTS FOR WATER AND
WASTEWATER SERVICES. I WANT
SERVICE DELIVERY SCHEDULED TO
COMMENCE IN MAY. SINCE CSP AND
ITS SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE NOT
ADMINISTERED WATER BENEFITS IN
THE PAST THE DEPARTMENT IS
INVESTING SIGNIFICANT UP FRONT
TIME AND RESOURCES TO DEVELOP Y.
WHAT GUIDELINES ENGAGE WITH
WATER PROVIDERS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION AND SERVICE
DELIVERY FOR CUSTOMERS ACROSS
THE STATE AT PROGRAM LAUNCH. CST
CONTINUES TO RECEIVE UPDATED
GUIDANCE FROM FEDERAL OFFICIALS
ON EXPECTATIONS FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION. AND THAT
FACTORED ND THE REALITY THAT WE
ARE DEPENDENT ON WATER UTILITIES
OPTING IN TO PARTICIPATE THE
PROGRAM THROUGH DIRECT PAY
AGREEMENTS. DOES CREATE SOME
UNKNOWNS THAT ARE OUTSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT'S CONTROL. WITH THAT
BEING SAID WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
WE'RE LAYING THE GROUNDWORK FOR
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM LAUNCH. EIGHT
COMING IN MAY. THE SECOND
QUESTION THE SEVERITY THE SUB
COMMITTEE WISHED CST DO
ADDRESSED WITH WINDOWS THE PART
EXPECT TO RELEASE PROGRAM
GUIDELINES FOR THE FOUR LINE
WHAT. AS STATED PREVIOUSLY CST
WILL BE RELEASING FINAL FINAL
WHY WHAT PROGRAM GUIDELINES FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT THIS WEEK. IN THE
DEPARTMENT WILL ALSO BE HOLDING
PUBLIC MEETINGS ARE A PUBLIC
MEETING TO REVIEW THE GUIDELINES
FOLLOWING PROGRAM GUIDELINES
RELEASE. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE OR COMMENTS
FROM FINANCE RALLY- AT THIS TIME
ONLINE WHAT. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. ELIA.
YES ANGELES SHORT WITH YELLOW AS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA OF THE
FUNDING FOR A LIE WHAT IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL. THE STATE
WATER BOARD OF FOR US SIMILAR
PURPOSE OF ADDRESSING WATER AND
WASTEWATER RIDGES THEREFORE WE
VIEW COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
TWO ADMINISTERING ENTITIES AS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTING THE TWO
PROGRAMS- YOU JUST HEARD
DIRECTOR SCRIBNER SPEAK A BIT TO
THIS COLLABORATION SO WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME-
BUT WILL BE CONTINUING TO
MONITOR IMPLEMENTATION PROGRESS
OF THE PROGRAM AND WILL
CERTAINLY RAISE ANY FUTURE
ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DR GRANT. THANKS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION
NOTING THAT THEIR APPROXIMATELY
THREE THOUSAND WATER AND
WASEWATER SYSTEMS I DON'T KNOW
IF EACH ONE OF THEM HAVE A
SEPARATE YOU KNOW. BILLING AND
IT'S CETERA- I GUESS IN THE
TERMS OF. IT'S A TRIED TO BUY
YOU TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF THE ROLL
OUT OF YOU. SO HOW. DO YOU HAVE
SUFFICIENT DATA TO BE ABLE TO BE
SURE WE'RE TARGETING THE FUNDS
SOME OF WHICH ARE YOU KNOW SAID
THAT. IT'S ON SMALLER SCALE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTEEN MILLION. I MEAN
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY BUT STILL
IT'S A MUCH SMALLER SCALE IN
TERMS BEACH OVER TARGETING THE
RIGHT HOUSEHOLDS WITH THIS I
MEAN GIVEN THE FACTORS UNLIKE
UTILITIES WHICH WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT. YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
MORE WATER SYSTEMS. SO IN TERMS
OF- BEING ABLE TO PRIORITIZE
THAT WHILE NOT DRIVING UP THE
OVERHEAD- I'M ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM. YES THEY THE PROGRAM IS
SINCE IT'S MODELED AFTER SHE IS
THESE LIE HE PROGRAM IT IS
ADMINISTERED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHICH MEANS IT IS A ONE CUSTOMER
ONE APPLICATION APPROACH. AND SO
ELIGIBLE CUSTOMERS WILL BE
COMING INTO THEIR LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS. AND SUBMITTING BILLS-
SEEKING THESE- THESE FUNDS SO-
THE DEPARTMENT IS WORKING WITH A
THIRD PARTY IMPLEMENTOR. WHO
WILL BE HANDLING THE DIRECT PAY
AGREEMENTS. ARE BETWEEN THE
FUNDING SOURCE THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE WATER AND WASTEWATER
UTILITY. AS LAW DOES NOT PERMIT
THE DEPARTMENT TO ISSUE ANY
BENEFITS DIRECTLY TO CUSTOMERS
IT MUST GO TO THE UTILITY
ITSELF. BUT CENTER HANDED THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WILL BE
TARGETED SPECIFICALLY TO LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS WITHIN THE
AREAS THAT ARE AGENCIES COVER
STATEWIDE. OKAY AND- YOUR
ALLOCATION TO THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES IS THAT BASED ON. THE
ESTIMATED PERCENTAGE OF LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS ARE. AS SONYA
YET I'M JUST I'VE GOT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PART AT THE BACK
AND SO. I MEAN I KNOW YOU TO USE
YOUR BEST EFFORTS TO GET THE
MONEY TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE. AND
THEN ARE WE GONNA HAVE THE KIND
OF INFORMATION GOING BACK SAYING
WELL THIS IS WHO THE MONEY
ACTUALLY ENDED UP GOING TO AND-
THE AND SO FORTH OF WE CAN AVAIL
- THIS- THIS PROGRAM AND AREAS
FOR IMPROVEMENT. THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS TO THE
LOCAL AGENCIES IS GOING TO BE
BASED ON A SIMILAR OF MULTI
FACTOR OF FORMULA THAT WE USE
FOR OUR LIGHT HEAT FUNDS AND SO
THAT THE DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS
WHAT WILL BE BASED. A LOT ON IT
TO THOSE THAT POINTS A NUMBER OF
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS THE AREA
AS WELL AS- THE DOLLARS NEEDED
BY THE AGENCIES SO IT IS A AGAIN
IT A LITTLE BIT OF A MATH ISSUE
BUT THE IN AND SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE THAT SURVEY DATA WERE THAT.
THAT THE OVERALL CONNECTION WITH
THE WATER UTILITIES- WE WILL BE
GETTING REPORTING BACK FROM OUR
AGENCIES ON THE LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS THAT HAVE BEEN SERVED
UNTIL I WALK PROGRAM. I GUESS
ONE OTHER QUESTION IS THAT IT IS
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT THREE
THOUSAND DIFFERENT THAT'S A SITE
THAT THE WATER AGENCIES COME IN
ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT SIZES I
KNOW JUST FOR MY OWN DISTRICT
UNITY OF LARGE ONES SAY OF
SMALLER ONES. AND TO BE FRANK
WE'VE DEALT WITH THIS BEFORE-
WATER ISSUES YOU KNOW SOME OF
THEM ARE MUCH MORE CAPABLE
ADMINISTRATIVELY THAN OTHERS
OTHERS HAVE RUN INTO SOME
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO. BUY THEIR SUPPLY
WATER ARE YOU KNOW IN MINISTER
THINGS SO IS THAT IS THAT
PROVING TO BE A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE I OFTENTIMES ACTUALLY
SOME OF THE SMALLER ONES. WHICH
MAY HAVE LESS CAPACITY- FOR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S IN JAIL FOR
MANAGING THEIR WATER SYSTEMS.
ALSO TEND THIS ALSO SERVES THE
LOWEST INCOME. NEIGHBORHOODS SO
I JUST WONDER AS FAR AS YOUR-
EXPERIENCE OUR MEDIA
INTERMEDIARY THAT AGENTS DON'T
PERSON CONTRACTING WITH- HOW.
HOW YOU'RE DEALING WITH THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE- IT'S- YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE GIVING MONEY DIRECTLY
TO THE AGENCIES- NOW SOME
AGENCIES A SAID HOUSE LESS
CAPACITY FOR HANDLING. THINGS
THAN OTHERS. YEAH THIS THE FUNDS
ARE GOING TO BE- IDENTIFIED BY
AGENCY BUT YET THEY WILL BE PAID
DIRECTLY TO THE WATER UTILITIES
THROUGH OUR OUR THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR AND IT IS A
CHALLENGE THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
ESTABLISH DIRECT PAY AGREEMENTS.
WITH THREE THOUSAND WATER.
UTILITIES BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE OUR THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR HAS EXPERIENCE
DOING- THEY WE FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET THIS PROGRAM UP AND
RUNNING AND START. THIS PROCESS
FROM DAY ONE- BUT AGAIN IT IS TO
YOUR POINT CENTER AND IT IS UP
TO YOU THOSE PARTICULAR- WATER
UTILITIES TO BEND YOU DON'T
PARTICIPATE WITH BUT THE
DEPARTMENT AND OUR THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR- TO ESTABLISH THAT
AGREEMENT SO THAT FUNDS CAN FLOW
ONCE APPLICATIONS ARE BEING
RECEIVED BY OUR AGENCIES FOR
THEIR PARTICULAR CUSTOMERS OKAY.
WELL I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT CHALLENGES I
THINK THE IMPORTANT THING IS
FIRST AND ON THE BACK AND THAT'S
WAS ASKING OF THE BACK AND
EVALUATION SO THAT WE SEE GAPS-
YOU KNOW THERE'S CERTAIN WATER
AGENCIES FOR HOOVER SAID
SUMMARIES ARE NOT EITHER DON'T
PARTICIPATE ARE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN A WAY. YET THEY
HAD THEIR SERVING COMMUNITIES
THERE- PARTICULARLY
DISADVANTAGED- WE WILL FIGURE
OUT THEN WHAT OTHER APPROACHES
WE MIGHT TAKE TO BE SURE THAT
THOSE CUSTOMERS ARE HEALTH SO
AGAIN I KNOW IT'S A YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRYING TO STAND A PROGRAM
VERY QUICKLY. AND WITH A
SOMEWHAT COMPLEX WATER SYSTEM
THE L. DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM- IN
TERMS OF NOT JUST
ORGANIZATIONALLY NOT JUST
MECHANICALLY- SO BUT OF THE VERY
INTERESTED IN SEEING WHAT THE
ANYTHING THE VALUATION RESULT AT
THE BACK AND ESPECIALLY. WE FEEL
THAT MORE FUNDS MIGHT MIGHT MAKE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS WILL BE SURE
TO USE DEFECTIVE WE KNOW WE'RE
LEARNING. LESSONS FROM FROM THIS
EXPERIENCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO PAN AM ANA THAT.
GOOD BOTH ON ON THE WATER AS
WELL AS ON UTILITIES. FORGIVE ME
FOR NOT KNOWING ALL THE BUCKETS
BY HEART BUT DO WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. PLACES LIKE I REPRESENT
UP AND DOWN IN THE VALLEY WHERE
WE HAVE. JUST INCREDIBLY HIGH-
LACK OF WATER AND VERY HIGH
HEATS WHERE PEOPLE. HAVE NO
OTHER CHOICE BUT TO ROUTE RUNNER
UTILITIES ALMOST AROUND THE
CLOCK. WHAT WENT ON WHEN
OFTENTIMES YOU KNOW THEY THEY
HAVE THE LEAST ENERGY EFFICIENT
ONES. IS THE IS OUR REGION TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT AS WELL OR JUST
LEVELS OF POVERTY. BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS. WELL FOR THE FOR CAP-
THE IT WAS JUST BASICALLY THAT
THE TOTAL REAR RIDGE BY
UTILITIES SO KNOW THAT THOSE
ISSUES WERE TAKEN- CAL BUT I
THINK THAT THEY WOULD JUST
NATURALLY BE PART OF THE MATH
THAT WOULD COME INTO IT THE
HIGHER ARREARS DOLLARS WOULD BE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THOSE THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE USING- THEIR
UTILITIES MORE- IN HIGH HEAT-
SCENARIOS. AS FAR AS LIKE WHAT
THE FACTORS IN DETERMINING THE
NUMBERS GOING TO THE AGENCIES
WILLINCLUDE THE INCOME
POPULATION AND THEN THE WATER
COST SO- THOSE INS DOES AREAS
THAT MAY HAVE HIGHER INSTANCES
OF- THE COST JUST TO GET WATER
MAIN NECESSARILY- RECEIVED A- A
LARGER ALLOCATION AND AT THE
ABILITY TO HAVE A POTENTIALLY
MORE CUSTOMERS- AFFECTED IN AND
IMPACTED. BY THE LAYOFFS OF
FUNDING. OKAY I THINK YOU HAVE
TO GET SOME OF BERMAN A LOOK
INTO MORE IN THE FUTURE LIKE
THIS. REGIONAL ISSUES WITH ALL
THIS MONEY WE'RE HAVING FOR
UTILITIES- THEM OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON. THE DEPARTMENT OF. CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES. WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR THEM FROM DIRECTOR DAVID
KILGOUR. AND WE THANK YOU
DIRECTOR SCRIBNER FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. AFTERNOON SENATORS
OF YOUR SECOND DAVID US ABOUT
THIS. AFTERNOON THAT THEY. YES
SAID DID YOUR DAD DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORT
SERVICES I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU SHARING THREE MAJOR
INITIATIVES THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSALS FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND THE FIRST
I WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT IS THE FULL PASS THROUGH
AND CURRENCY FOR ON FORMER CHILD
SUPPORT CASES THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF SEVERAL YEARS OF
EFFORTS ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
BEHALF GM. IMPLEMENT WHAT WE CAN
IN IN THE FIGHT AGAINST POVERTY
PREVENTION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE FIRST OF THOSE CHANGES WAS
ARE CHANGED TO THE DEFICIT D. R.
A. DEFICIT DEFICIT REDUCTION ACT
AND DISTRIBUTION MODEL FOR CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES WHICH INCLUDES
ALL PAYMENTS FROM ALL SOURCES.
GOING TO PAY OFF FAMILIES FIRST
BEFORE GOVERNMENT THE SECOND
THOSE CHANGES STARTED IN
NEGOTIATIONS IN NINETEEN TWENTY
WITH THE MINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE ABOUT CURRENT
SUPPORT PASTOR AND HOW MUCH WE
PASSED THROUGH ON ON THOSE OF
MONEY IN THE CAMANCHE
NEGOTIATION THERE WAS TO GO TO
THE FEDERAL MAXIMUM AND I'LL
TALK ABOUT THAT A BIT MORE OF
THE TERM ACTION IS ONE OR TWO
HUNDRED. IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE FARMERS SOCIAL SERVICES AND
WITH CHILD SUPPORT AND WE WERE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE TECHNICAL
CHANGES LAST YEAR TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT THAT EFFECTIVE JANUARY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR STOCKS
INCREASED IN PAST DUE TO
FAMILIES WENT FROM FIFTY DOLLARS
TO ONE HUNDRED AND TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS. THIS THIRD PIECE HERE
THAT YOU'RE SEEING FOR YOU TODAY
IS A CONTINUATION OF THAT
UTILIZING THE FEDERAL ALLOWABLE
OPPORTUNITIES BEFORE US TO PASS
TO TAKE TO EXERCISE THE OPTION
TO PASS THROUGH ALL OF THE
CLASSES THAT WE RECEIVED ON OUR
FORMALLY ASSISTED FAMILIES
THROUGH THE FAMILIES INSTEAD OF
RETAINING THAT THE GOVERNMENT.
AND THAT WOULD AMOUNTS TO IN
IMPACTS THE STATE'S BUDGET OF
ABOUT NINE THREE MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR BUT IT ALLOWS US TO DO
STUPID ALMOST DOUBLE THAT
FAMILIES CLOSING ON TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY MOVING
FORWARD AT FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE.
THERE ARE ASERIES OF QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAD ON THIS PARTICULAR
PIECE- WHAT IS ONE OCCURRENCE OF
COURT- WHEN I PASSED THROUGH ALL
OF. TRANSIT ON FOR FIRST THE
SYSTEM FAMILY. NO THREE MAY
REASON WHY THAT THAT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING THE FIRST IS- WE HAD
A MOVED WITH THE- FOR. TO GO TO
ONE HUNDRED HUNDRED DOLLAR. AND
THE START OF YEAR. AND JUST
PIECE IS WE DO NOT HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY TO GO ABOUT THAT SO IF
WE WERE TO MAKE THE DECISION TO
PASS THROUGH. AND THE ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CURRENTLY ASSISTED FAMILIES
WE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOLES FOR
THEIR 50% OF THE SHARES
RECOLLECTION SO. THERE'S AN
ADDED IMPACTS TO THE STATE'S
BUDGET. AND TO MAKE THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT HOLE THERE IS A
DISCUSSION FEDERAL LEVEL ABOUT
WHETHER THAT'S GOING TO BE
CHANGED ON THE ROAD BUT THEY'RE
NOT QUITE THERE YET. AND THEN
THE THIRD PIECE- ON THIS.
CONCEPT ABOUT. MOVING TO CURRENT
PASSED THROUGH ALL TRANSPORT
REALLY HAS TO DO WITH OUR
SYSTEMS ITSELF WE JUST
IMPLEMENTED ONE AND TWO HUNDRED
WE REALLY WANT TO SEE THE
IMPACTS OF THAT AND THE FACT IT
HAS ON THE FAMILY WE- TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO GO INTO FRTHER
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
WE JUST REGARD WHEN IT COMES TO
OTHER TYPES OF SERVICES ON THE
PARCEL SERVICES SIGN. AND THEN
JUST FRONT TECHNOLOGICAL
PERSPECTIVE WHICH PARCEL SERVICE
IS GOING TO THEIR MAJOR OVERHAUL
AND SYSTEMS WE DON'T FEEL WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET TO THIS AND
TELL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
YEAR AT THE EARLIEST SO WE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT TIME I THINK TO
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS IN THE SASS
WERE WRAPPED WITH THIS INCREASE
FASTER THAN WE CAN MAKE SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT. FOR THE PAST
DOING. CURRENT SUPPORT AS YOU
MOVE DOWN THE ROAD. I WANTED TO.
IT OVER TO NAY. SECULAR ABOUT
THEM TO. BUDGET AND THE LOCAL
TRANSPORT. AGENCIES. HI HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- CENTERED EGGMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE-
MUNNINGS MANSION- I WANTED TO GO
OVER QUICKLY THE- COVERS BUDGET
FOR DEPARTMENT TRANSPORT
SERVICES ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET POSES ONE POINT ONE SIX
BILLION DOLLARS THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR NINE GENERAL FUND FOR
THE DEPARTMENT JOHNSON SERVICES
INCREASE OF SIXTY SIX NINE
DOLLARS FROM THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO PROJECT ON ONE OF OUR
MAJOR CHANGES IS FIFTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS OR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY
ADMINISTRATION. THIS IS THE
CONSTANT CONTINUATION OF A MOTOR
YOUR WRAP UP TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT INEQUITABLE FUNDING
UNDER FUNDED ALL CSAS AND BRING
THEM INTO PARITY WITH THE US YES
THE FUNDING METHODOLOGY THAT WAS
ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY- THE BY. ALSO INCLUDE THE
TRUMP WHICH PASSED THROUGH WHICH
DAVID DISCUSSED- EARLIER. AND
TROUBLING WHICH FOR SOME FINAL
WHICH CHRIS WILL TALK ABOUT
LATER ON- AS FAR AS COLLECTIONS
IS CONCERNED DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
IN TOTAL DISTRIBUTOR COLLECTIONS
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THIS IS A ECREASE
OF ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS COMPARED TO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BY JACK.
THIS DECLINE IS- IS THE
CONTINUING DOWNWARD TREND DUE TO
BE COPING RELATED STIMULUS
MEASURES ROLLING OFF. SUCH AS
ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
AND DECLINING TAX ANCEPS WELL
THE LABOR MARKET IS SLOWLY
RECOVERING. AS THE AMBIENCE ASK
FOR THE IMBALANCE BETWEEN THE
DECLINES IN ASSISTANCE QUESTION
VERSUS NOT ASSISTANCE QUESTIONS
THIS IS ATTRIBUTED TO A NET ZERO
SHIFT OF ASSISTANCE QUESTIONS TO
NON ASSISTANCE QUESTIONS. DUE TO
THE DEPARTMENTS FOR PASSED THE
PROPOSAL WHICH REFLECTS THESE
DOLLARS GOING FROM FOUND GOING.
TO FAMILIES AND SET OF
GOVERNMENT WORK- HAVE YOU TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. SINCE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I YES AND
NO CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME MESOPOTAMIANS ANYTHING. LOL
THIS IS JACKIE BRISTOW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE-
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
FINALIZING OUR ANALYSIS OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT BUDGET BUT I CAN
PROVIDER INITIAL HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS FOR EACH PROPOSAL- WITH
REGARDS TO THE PAST THROUGH
PROPOSAL. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL REFLECTS ONE PASTOR
OPTION WHERE THE STATE DOES WAS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED WOULD
MAXIMIZE THE FEDERAL FLEXIBILITY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PASTOR
AMOUNT FOR FORMER CAL WORKS%
FAMILIES OR FAMILIES THAT
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED CAL WORKS-
COULD TEND TO BE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES I'M ALTERNATIVE POP
THROUGH OPTIONS INCLUDE
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS FOR CURRENT CAL
WORKS FAMILIES THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING- CAL WORKS
CASH EIGHT ALTERNATELY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PASSED THROUGH
FRAMEWORK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOCKS SHOULD REALLY REFLECT ITS
OWN GOALS. I'M FOR EXAMPLE IF
THE LEGISLATURE WANTED TO
MINIMIZE THE PAST THEIR
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN CURRENT AND
FORMER CAL WORKS FAMILIES WELL
AT THE SAME TIME MAXIMIZE THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES THAT RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS IT COULD
INCREASE PASSED THROUGH LEVELS
FOR BOTH FORMER. AND CURRENT CAL
WORKS FAMILIES. OF SOMETHING
THAT THE- WE NEED TO CONSIDER
WHAT THAT POLICY OPTION WOULD BE
HOW QUICKLY THE PASTOR CHANGES
COULD BE IMPLEMENTED AS WAS
MENTIONED ANY PASTOR CHANGES FOR
CRYING CAL WORKS FAMILIES. COULD
NOT BE IMPLEMENTED UNTIL
SOMETIME IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE JUST DUE TO LIMITATIONS ON
IT SYSTEMS RIGHT NOW HOWEVER
THAT COULD GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
TIME SOME TIME TO CONSIDER. I'M
SOME OF THESE OTHER PROGRAMMATIC
IMPLICATIONS- SUCH AS WHAT. AN
INCREASING CURRENT PASSED
THROUGH- FOR POWER EXPAND THESE
WOULD MEAN FOR THEIR CHARACTER
ELIGIBILITY OR ELIGIBILITY AND
OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY OF COURSE THE
LEGISLATURE- WE NEED TO CONSIDER
IT BE INCREASE AN ESTIMATED
GENERAL FUND IMPACT. AND OVERALL
WE ARE STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
ASSESSING THE COST ESTIMATES FOR
EACH OF THE COSTS ARE EACH OF
THE PAST THROUGH OPTIONS
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET
PROPOSAL I'M JUST SOMETHING THAT
WE WOULD FLAG IS BECAUSE WE
CAN'T NECESSARILY GO OFF THE-
PASTOR CURRENT COST LEVELS ARE
COLLECTION LEVELS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT- DOES TEND TO INCREASE
OR DECREASE WITH CAL WORKS
CASELOAD LEVELS- WHICH WE- WERE
ESTIMATING. ARE JUST GOING TO
INCREASE IN THE FUTURE. I'M
MOVING ON TO THE- PROPOSAL FOR
THE INCREASED FUNDING ALLOCATION
TO LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING LEVELS WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FUNDING
METHODOLOGY. AND THAT IT DOES
NOT FULLY INCENTIVIZE THE
ADOPTION OF PROGRAM EFFICIENCIES
THAT COULD ALSO HAVE THE EFFECT
OF REDUCING COST PRESSURES AND
FREE UP EXISTING BONDS. MORE
OVER WE HAVE A CONCERN THAT THE
FUNDING METHODOLOGY I MAY NOT
REFLECT ACTUAL FUNDING NEEDS.
I'M GIVEN THAT PROGRAM UP FOR
OPERATIONS HAVE ANY CONTINUED TO
MOVE FURTHER AWAY FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OPERATION
LEVELS. WHICH SERVE AS THE
BENCHMARK WHEN CALCULATING
OVERALL LCSC FUNDING NEEDS
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FUNDING METHODOLOGY. THUS I'M
EVEN IF THE FUNDING METHODOLOGY
WAS DEEMED APPROPRIATE AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY- THERE'S
NO CERTAINTY THAT IT CONTINUES
TO ACCURATELY MEASURE CURRENT
AND FUTURE LCSC ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING NEEDS. WITH THAT SAID
AND WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NOT PROVIDE ANY
FUTURE ON TUESDAY FUNDING
INCREASES UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION REVISES ITS
FUNDING METHODOLOGY TO ADDRESS
THESE IDENTIFIED SHORTCOMINGS.
SOME CHANGES THAT ARE PRETTY
STRAIGHT FORWARD THAT COULD BE
ADDED TO THE FUNDING METHODOLOGY
RELATIVELY QUICKLY INCLUDE
LIMITING THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS ADJUSTMENTS ON THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY TO A FIXED RATE AS A
WAY TO CONTROL THE STATE SHARE
COST- FOR COUNTY CONTROLLED
SALARY AND BENEFIT INCREASES
AND- SUCH CONTROLS. AND THE
STATE SHARE COST ARE COMMON IN
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. ADDITIONALLY ANOTHER
POSSIBLE CHANGE- COULD BE TO ADD
ON A ONGOING PROCESS AND WHICH
BUDGETS ARE UNDERFUNDED- OF
OVERFUNDED LCCS MEETING LCCS
THAT HAVE ACCESS FUNDS ABOVE
THEIR CALCULATED FUNDING NEEDS
CERTAIN TIME PERIOD AND THEN
THOSE EXCESS FUNDS ARE
REDISTRIBUTED TO UNDERFUNDED
ALSEA. SA- I'M HAPPY TO GO TO DO
. I'M MORE DE ABOUT THE SUPER
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT- KRISTIN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES WAS ALSO GONNA
PRESENT. ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND OUR INITIAL HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS ON THAT WAS WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING IT WAS JUST
RELEASED ON FRIDAY BUT TWO
THINGS WOULD FLAG FOR THE
LEGISLATURE NOW IS- REQUESTING A
SUMMARY OF THIS STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK THAT WAS COLLECTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES- AND JUST REQUESTING
INFORMATION ON HOW THOSE- ON HOW
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE DOES OR
DOES NOT. ADDRESS THOSE
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK THAT CAME
UP- BUT ALSO ONE THING THAT WE
WILL BE LOOKING FOR IN THE
LANGUAGE IS IDENTIFYING WHETHER
THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS WHERE IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADOPT MORE DETAILED LANGUAGE.
AROUND THE NEW CRITERIA THAT CAN
BE CONSIDERED WHEN ESTABLISHING
A CHILD SUPPORT ORDER AND THIS
IS MORE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ENSURING STANDARDISED APPROACH-
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
CRITERIA FOR ALL FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- TRUE DON'T STEP
BACK BUDGET JUST TO SEE WITH YOU
EARLIER- THE WOMAN TARA FOR THE
PASSED THROUGH. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THERE ARE BASICALLY TWO
TWO PARTS OF FAMILIES ON CAL
WORKS A POST CAL WORKS. ON
EITHER LEVEL OF THOSE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMPLICATIONS OF TRYING TO GIVE
IT TO PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ON CAL WORKS BUT ARE WE LOOKING
AT LEVEL OF NEED FOR THE AMOUNT
OF THAT PASSED THROUGH OR OR
THEY'RE PRIORITIZING. PEOPLE
WITH HIGHER LEVEL OF NEEDS OR IS
THERE JUST NOT THE DATA TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT LEVEL OF.
CRITERIA. MY UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THE- PROPOSAL FOR A BI
INCREASING PASTOR FOR FORMER CAL
WORKS FAMILIES. IS IT WE HAVE TO
TREAT ALL FAMILIES WELL IT'S
KIND OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THEIR CONDITION IS IF YOU'RE
GOING TO. INCREASE THE PASSED
THROUGH YOU HAVE TO DO IT
EQUALLY- SO IF YOU'RE IF IT WILL
WILL BE WILLING TO FORGIVE OUR
SHARE OF THAT PAYMENT IF THE
STATE DOES THE SAME AND THEY
PASSED THROUGH THE EXACT SAME
AMOUNT TO FAMILIES- HOWEVER IN
YOUR CONVERSATIONS ABOUT MAYBE
HOW DO CURRENT. CAL WORKS
FAMILIES COMPARED TO FORMER CAL
WORKS FAMILIES. BOTH ARE LOW
INCOME. HOWEVER BASED OFF OF.
INCOME DATA THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM THAT- DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES A FEW YEARS AGO
IT DOES SEEM LIKE. CURRENT CAO
WORKS FAMILIES TEND TO BE ANY
WORSE ECONOMIC POSITION-
RELATIVE TO FORMER CAL WORKS
FAMILIES- AND IN IN THE IN THE
CASE OF FORMER CAL WORKS
FAMILIES. OF THE OF THE CARE OF
THE FAMILIES THAT WOULD BENEFIT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND MANY OF THEM NO LONGER HAVE
AN ACTIVE CHILD SUPPORT ORDER IN
PLACE AND THAT COULD BE A SIGN
THAT. THE CHILD HAS ALREADY
REACHED ADULTHOOD. AND THAT
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE THE TYPES OF
PAYMENTS THAT WOULD GO TO
FAMILIES TYPICALLY ARE THE LAST.
PAYMENTS THE LAST BUCKET BUT
GETS PAID IN ALL CASES. I'M SO
THE CHILD POSSIBLY HAS ALREADY
REACHED ADULTHOOD BY THE TIME.
THOSE PAYMENTS ARE BEING MADE-
VERSES WITH THE CURRENT COVERAGE
FAMILY WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
CHILD IN THAT HOUSEHOLD TODAY.
I'M SO DEPENDING ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S CALLS YOU CAN
STRUCTURE IN A WAY WHERE PERHAPS
YOU ARE. PRIORITIZING ARE
BENEFITING FAMILIES THAT YOU
DEEM ARE EITHER IN A MORE NEED
RELATIVE I BASED OFF OF THEIR
RELATIVE ECONOMIC SITUATION OR
RELATIVE TO THE FAMILY THE
HOUSEHOLD COMPOSITION AS THEIR
CHILD- IN THE HOUSEHOLD X.
SENTARA. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THAT VERY HELP- DIRECTOR
DAVID ON THE L. CSA FUNDING- ARE
YOU LOOKING AT DIFFERENT SORTS
OF OBJECTIVES TO BE ABLE TO.
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS. YES THEY
ARE OUR FIRST INITIATIVE- WHAT
THEY OUGHT TO STAY FUNDING WAS
TO BRING PARITY TO ALL THE LOCAL
CHANNELS FOR AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE SO THERE ARE SOME VERY
WELL FUNDED COUNTIES THERE
CELESTE FUNDING COUNTIES THE
FUNDING CALCULATOR BRINGS
EVERYBODY TO THE MIDDLE TO
JACQUI SECOND POINT IS THAT THE
RIGHT AMOUNT OF MONEY SUPPOSING
EVERYBODY WAS AT THE MIDDLE IS
THAT THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO ADEQUATELY FUND THE SOUTHEAST
ASIA NOT. THAT'S I THINK WHERE
FURTHER ANALYSIS NEEDS TO COME
INTO PLAY AND WE HAVE A WAY TO
STARTED TO RAMP UP FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT A CONTRACT TO DO A LEVEL
OR EFFORT STUDY- ON THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM AT THAT POINT IN
TIME RIGHT NOW IT REALLY DOESN'T
MATTER THE LEVEL OF EFFORT IS
ACCURATE OR NOT BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN INTO AN EQUAL
PLAYING FIELD ACROSS ALL THE
LOCAL CHANNELS FOR AGENCIES. SO
THAT'S OUR FIRST GOAL WITH THIS
IS TO BRING ACROSS THE STATE AND
THEN WE WILL ASSESS AND ANALYZE
WHETHER WE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO ADEQUATELY SUPPORT THE
ACTIVITIES THE CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAM OR IF THERE'S LESS FUNDS
AND ALSO TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE
COUNTRIES THAT ARE OVER THE
FUNDING TACULAR BRINGING THEM
INTO LINE WITH THE FUNDING CHECK
LATER AS STANCE TODAY. SO
THERE'S CERTAINLY NOTHING IN THE
CONVERSATION BUT IT IS THE NEXT
STEP THAT WE NEED TO BRING SOME
PERISHABLE. TRANSPORTATION JUST
CROSS THE STATE. OKAY BUT WE
WILL NOT NOT ALL THINGS ARE
EQUAL SO TO AND CHECK HIS POINT
ABOUT- THERE ARE SOME THAT. YOU
KNOW HAVE. OF FUNDING AND THEN
OTHERS WITHOUT ENOUGH. DOES IT
MAKE SENSE TO BE GIVING THOSE
WITH PLENTY OF FUNDING MORE
FUNDING. THIS FUNDING THAT ALSO
THIS EDITION OF. MONEY THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING IS ONLY GOING TO
BE UNDERFUNDED COUNTIES NOT
PLEASE COUNTIES THAT ARE OVER
FUNDED SO YOU JUST BRING THE
BOTTOM UP TO ALIGN IT WITH THE
FUNDING CALCULATOR. AND WHEN WE
HAD- A YEAR AND A HALF AGO WITH
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE- OF THE
PANDEMIC WE HAD TO REMOVE
FUNDING FROM THE CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAM. WE TOOK A LARGER
PORTION OF THAT FUNDING FROM THE
LARGER FROM THE MORE WEALTH THAN
THE CUNTIES THAT A LOWER
FUNDING. AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO
BRING THE BOTTOM UP SO WE ARE
NOT PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO ANY. COUNTY THAT IS OVER THE
FUNDING METHODOLOGY OKAY AND
THEN GOING FORWARD THEY'LL-
WE'RE GONNA TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
HOW DO WE KEEP THOSE OVER FRIEND
THOSE COUNTIES THAT DO VERY
WELL- I KEEP OUR EYE ON THAT AND
JUST TO MAKE SURE THE BOTTOM.
THE BOTTOM KEEPS UP WITH THE
TOP. THAT IS CORRECT AS WE BRING
THE PRODUCT TO HAVE PARITY WE
ARE EXPECTING THOSE. COUNTIES
WITH THE HIGHER FUNDING TO COME
INTO LINE WITH THE FUNDING
FORMULA. THAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING WITH THE DECLINING
CASELOAD AND INCREASING COSTS
FOR SALARIES AND EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS. AND WE'RE NOT SEEN
THAT THEY'RE MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARDS THAT THAT'S. WHEN WE
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS WITH
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY. THANK YOU DR
. THANK YOU VERY AND FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND
THANK THE PHARMACY CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR THE WORK DONE ON
THE LCS A FUNDING METHODOLOGY
SELF- I APPRECIATE THE L. A. AS
COMMENTS I ALSO WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT- DOES NOT THAT
MANY YEARS AGO- THAT- WE HAD
THIS TREMENDOUS FUNDING
DISPARITY BETWEEN COUNTIES THAT
CAME OUT OF A FORMULA OR AN
EQUATION. THAT WAS ACTUALLY IN
EXISTENCE FOR SEVERAL DECADES IN
FACT I THINK IT WAS FULLY AND
CHILD SUPPORT WAS I THINK IN THE
THIRTY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND NOT
IN SOCIAL SERVICES AND SO FORTH
IN FACT WE HAD A VERY
DYSFUNCTIONAL- FUNDING MECHANISM
FOR CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
DIDN'T THAT DIDN'T RECOGNIZE THE
ACTUAL NEED. AND IN FACT-
DEPARTMENTS CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES WORKING WITH COUNTY
WITH THE LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES WORKED HARD TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT THAT LED TO MORE
FAIRNESS BETWEEN THE COUNTIES-
THAT THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THIS
FUNDING MECHANISM I CAN
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR PUTTING
IN THE FUNDS- TO CAN TO BE SURE
WE- WORK OUT THAT ENTIRE
AGREEMENT BECAUSE OVER SEVERAL
YEARS WILL BRING THE BOTTOM UP
AS MENTIONED. AND. AND SO THAT.
EACH COUNTY AND EACH LOCALITY
WOULD HAVE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO ATTICA TO PROPERLY
ADMINISTER TO CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICE AND IN FACT. BECAUSE OF
THAT- I BELIEVE- THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY. HAVING MORE EFFECTIVE
COLLECTIONS OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES ULTIMATELY IN THE END
IT'S NOT ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY
THE- COUNTY THAT THE STATE
SPENDING AND HOW MUCH COUNTIES
ARE GETTING. AS MUCH AS HOW MUCH
OF THE FAMILY'S GETTING RIGHT IN
BEING SURE THAT WE DO WHAT WE
CAN SUPPORT THE FAMILY SO. I
CERTAINLY. CONCUR WITH THE L. A.
L. O. THAT DOES WORK WITH MOVING
FORWARD YOU KNOW WE WANT TO LOOK
AT WHAT SORT OF GUARD RAILS YOU
PUT IN PLACE. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT AND I
WANNA THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
PUTTING THE FUNDING SO WE FULLY
WORK OUT FUND THE AGREEMENT THAT
WAS COME TO SEVERAL YEARS AGO
THAT PROVIDE MORE EQUITABLE
FUNDING BETWEEN COUNTIES. THAT
WAS AS A RESULT OF A
NEGOTIATION. BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE COUNTIES THAT. ACTUALLY
THAT ACTUALLY- FINALLY FIXED A
PROBLEM THAT GONE ON FOR DECADES
CLEARLY DECADES OR A
ESSENTIALLY- WHERE WE'VE IT IS
FRANKLY HAD A VERY DYSFUNCTIONAL
WAY OF DISTURBING THE FUNDS
BETWEEN COUNTY FOR SOME GOT WAIT
NOW GOT A LOT MORE AND OTHERS
GOT. WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
TREMENDOUSLY UNDERFUNDED
COUNTIES ARE UNDER FUNDED TO BE
ABLE TO ADMINISTER CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES. SO WHAT. SO I GUESS I
WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT- I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR PUTTING
IN THE MONEY NOW WE HAD A LITTLE
PIES WHEN THE COVETED WE WERE
AFRAID WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER BUDGET DOWN FALL. BUT
THAT WE ACTUALLY GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE AGREED TO. AND
THEN OF COURSE MOVING FORTY ONE
ENSURE WE CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN
BALANCE AND APPROPRIATE LEVELS
OF FUNDING FOR THE COUNTIES. SO
I DO APPRECIATE WHAT'S HERE IN
THE LTSA FUNDING METHODOLOGY.
THE FULL PASS THROUGH I THINK
AGAIN IS. APPRECIATED- ENTER
WE'RE HOPING THAT WITH THE FOR
PASSED PEOPLE TO BE MORE WILLING
THE PPO TO GET. THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE A COLLECT MORE MONEY BE. THE
PEOPLE FAILURE TO CHILD SUPPORT
WILL KNOW THAT THE MONEY IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO THEIR CHILD
AND NOT JUST TO ADMINISTRATION.
I GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE AND
I THINK IF WE TOUCH A LITTLE BIT
ON IT IS THAT. AND ACTUALLY I DO
I MAKE A COMMENT THAT. I'M
ACTUALLY KIND OF HARD TO HEAR
THAT THE PEOPLE ARE POST CAL
WORKS ARE DOING BETTER BECAUSE
THAT MEANS AT LEAST BECAUSE WE
GET LIKE YOUR IN CAR WORKS WE DO
ALL THAT WE DO JOB TRAINING WE
DO A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
EDUCATION ETCETERA. SO I'M GLAD
TO KNOW THOSE FAMILIES ARE
ACTUALLY. DOING SLIDERS ARE
BETTER OFF THAN THE ONES ARE
CURRENTLY AND THAT MEANS. AT
LEAST THAT INTERVENTION DURING
THE TIME THEY WEREN'T CAL WORKS
OR HELPING THEM OUT. IN AB
PUTTING THEM ON A BETTER FOOTING
I HOPE- BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS THAT- FOR THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY ON CAL WORKS WHAT
IS DO DO WE HAVE THE ESTIMATE
FOR WHAT THE COST WOULD BE IF WE
DID A PASS THROUGH FOR THOSE
FAMILIES AS IT. IS A COST
PROHIBITIVE I UNDERSTAND OR SOME
CHALLENGES YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
IT OTHER THINGS TO DO THAT BUT-
A IS THAT IT IS THERE A COST
ISSUE THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
OR IS IT MORE. OF A YOU KNOW
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUE. THANK YOU
CENTER AND THAT COST FOR PASSING
. ON- ALL CURRENT. EXTREMELY
SISTER CASES BE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DOLLARS. AND
A ONE FOR ONE BENEFIT TO THOSE
FAMILIES. AND TO FULLY PASSED
THAT THROUGH BECAUSE NOT ONLY DO
THEY HAVE TO GET THE MONEY WE
HAVE TO MAKE THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT HOLE FOR THEIR
PORTION OF IT. THE BENEFIT WE
HAVE ON THE- THE FORMALLY
SUGGESTED SITE IS THAT FOR
EVERY. DOLLAR WE'RE LOSING IN
RECRUITMENT TWO DOLLARS IS GOING
OUT TO THE FAMILIES OF THOSE
FOREIGN RELEASED AS A CASES. WE
HAVE A STATUTORY AUTHORITY
THROUGH THE DEFICIT. REDUCTION
ACT TO IMPLEMENT THIS WITHOUT
ANY ISSUES FROM THE PRO
GOVERNMENT. NEWS OR EXERCISING
THEN. AND HAS BEEN OFFICIAL.
THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS WITH
COLORADO. WHO IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT IS CURRENTLY DOING PASSED
THE RUN CURRENT SUPPORT CASES.
THEY DID NOT ELECT TO DO JUST.
THAT THE DISTRIBUTION ON THE
FORMALLY SYSTEM CASES SO. IF THE
PERSON PAYS IN THE MONTH OF THE
OBLIGATIONS DO. BECAUSE AFTER
THE FAMILY IF THEY DON'T PAY IT
GOES INTO ARREARS. AND THAT
ARREARS IS SELECTED. IN THE
RETAIN AFTER THE GOVERNMENT.
COLORADO IN OUR CONVERSATION HE-
SAID HAPPY TO DO IT OVER AGAIN.
THEY WOULD HAVE STARTED WITH
YOURS AND THEN. THANKS FOR ITS
SUPPORT. AS FOR CURRENT SUPPORT
ITSELF AND- AND THAT'S I THINK
IS A IS A TOUGH FOR NEGOTIATION
WHETHER WE CAN DO POLLS OR NOT.
BUT WE ALREADY HAVE THE STATE
STREET THIRTY G. D. FORMALLY
ASSISTED CASES NOW. OKAY AND ARE
YOU SENATE BUT HE THAT ARE YOU
SAYING YOU DON'T THE STATURE
THOUGHT YET THE I MEAN I'VE-
FOR. PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY ON
OUR- WELL WE DO IT IT'S JUST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL NOT
WAIVE THEIR PORTIONS SO IN
ADDITION TO PASSING THE GRANT
THE MONEY THROUGH THE FAMILY WE
WILL HAVE TO MAKE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. OTHER OKAY NO I
UNDERSTAND IT'S PART OF THE
EXPENSE OKAY BECAUSE HE'S A
STATUTORY AUTHORITY OVER THE
CLEARANCE TILTED TO BACK TO
WHETHER TO ATTACH IT TO THE
BARRIERS WELL OKAY. WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO-
ISSUE UMBER FIVE CHILD SUPPORT
BUDGET INVESTMENTS. RIGHT S.
SENATOR WE DID TRY TO SAVE A
LITTLE BIT ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE I'M HAPPY TO GO BACK TO
THAT AND HAVE CHRISTIAN TALK
ABOUT THAT TOGETHER WE CAN NO
ARSENAL TALK ABOUT THAT PLEASE.
OKAY KRISTEN GRANT THANK YOU
SATURDAY WHEN THE SUBCOMMITTEE-
THE INTERNET ITSELF DOES A GREAT
JOB OF DESCRIBING THE FINAL RULE
WHICH IS THE FLEXIBILITY
EFFICIENCY AND MODERNIZATION
CHILD SUPPORT ANIMAL THIS WAS
FINAL IN DECEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND HAS A NUMBER OF REQUIREMENTS
FOR CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
ACROSS THE NATION. WITH REGARD
TO CALIFORNIA WE HAD A FEW BAD
REQUIREMENTS BUILT YOU NEEDS ARE
DEADLINE FOR THOSE IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY WHEN YOU DUE TO THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC AND THERE WERE
SOME FEDERAL FLEXIBILITY IS
GRANTED TO ASK AND ARE DEADLINE
WAS EXTENDED TO SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND INTENDS TO MEET ITS
REQUIREMENTS WHICH WILL PREVENT
US FROM BEING SANCTIONED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR FAILING
ME THESE REQUIREMENTS AND.
GETTING OUR STATE TRANSACTION. I
SORRY NEED IT'S BROKEN DOWN BY.
CATEGORIES THE MAIN IN. IS YOUR
ABILITY HI. THAT ARE STATUTES.
RAREFIED AND ALL THIS ORDER MY
BE A ON. WHAT HE IN CHILD
SUPPORT AND FAMILY LIFE
GENERALLY KNOW ABOUT A PARENT'S
ABILITY HEY. IN TERMS OF THE
GENERAL RULE THERE ARE ALREADY
CASE LAW AND STATUTES IN PLACE.
HOW MIGHT THAT OR THE GENERAL
FAMILY LAW CASES. IN TERMS OF
OUR CHILD SUPPORT IS THE
LEADING. WE DO HAVE A CONCEPT
THAT REQUIRES OUR AGENCIES GIVE
RESALE. EARN FULL TIME MINIMUM
WAGE IF WE ARE NOT SURE OF THEIR
INCOME. OF THEIR INCOME IS
ANNOUNCED YOU ASK- AND BE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ADVISE.
CHANGES THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
TAKE. INTO ACCOUNT WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT. AND APPLY NOW. WHICH
GIVES ON. HE'S ON THINGS IS
BASED ON- ECONOMIC RESEARCH INTO
IMPACTS. HE ARE PARENTS ABILITY
EARN BUT JUST HIS GAME. OR
RESIDING IN A COUNTY WHERE THERE
IS A HIGHER THAN AVERAGE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. THAT IS WOULD
CONTINUE THAT ROLE WE HAVE IN
PLACE THAT WAS BASED ON A WORK
FORCE- I AM WORKERS CAME
TOGETHER AND CREATED A TOXIC
WORK PROGRAM AS WE KNOW IT TODAY
THAT BALANCES- I THINK SHE SEES
AND YOUR PROCESS WHERE THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY A PLACE HOLDER ORDER
AND IF WE LATER FIND ACTUAL
INCOME FOR THE PARENTS OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE THEN REQUIRED TO
TAKE THAT CASE TO WORK AND HAVE
IT RESET BASED ON THE- ACTUAL
AND- OPERATES AS A PLACEHOLDER.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT MEETS US
FINAL WORLD FIREMEN'S WHILE
STILL PRESERVING THE
EFFICIENCIES AND THE DUE.
PROCESS RIGHTS OF OUR PARENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THEY ARE SOME
CHANGES WITH REGARDS
PERSPIRATION. THEY MAYOR CHANGES
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE IN A
JOINT REPORTS THAT WENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BROWN CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES AND THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. AND THAT WAS RELATED TO
FAMILY TRANSACTION FOUR THOUSAND
SEVEN POINT FIVE. WHICH PROVIDES
FOR AN AUTOMATIC SUSPENSION OF
SUPPORT MY PARENTS FIRST THREE-
PROVIDING THAT A FIRST VERSION
DOES NOT CONSTITUTE VOLUNTARY
UNEMPLOYMENT IS A KEY COMPONENT
OF THAT FINAL FULL. SO WE'RE
LOOKING PERSON INFORMING CHANGES
THEIR- YOU COME INTO. MY FINAL.
LASTLY WE WERE HERE LAST YEAR WE
REALLY TO GET SOME CHANGE THE
HOME AND I JUST. AS WE THAT IN
THE- OUR PARENTS FULL TIME WAGE
NO LONGER ANY SORT OF
ADJUSTMENTS ARE LOW INCOME
ADJUSTMENTS- DUE TO THAT RUSSELL
. IN THE STATUTE B. R. JUDICIAL
COUNCIL RECENTLY RELEASED THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ADELINE REVIEW
REPORTS- WHICH YOU ASKED YOUR
REVIEW AND COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHENEVER
RECOMMENDATIONS THERE. THAT
REPORT DOES NOT A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH REGARDS TO
LOW INCOME ADJUSTMENT AND SO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SEEKS. TO
IMPLEMENT ONE OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. I'M ONE OF THE
YOU FOR A WHAT- HOW WE ENGAGE
THE STATE. PARENTS TRAILER BILL
. AND WE DID IN DECEMBER ISSUE A
REQUEST FOR COMMENT STILL VERY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING OUR LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THEMSELVES AND
STAFFERS FOR LEGISLATIVE BODIES
AS WELL AS A SERIES OF ACTS. AND
WITH THAT REQUEST FOR COMMENT WE
INCLUDED IN INVITATION TO- ONE
OF THREE MEETINGS THAT WERE
IDENTICAL OR WE COULD WALK THE
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGH THAT
CHANGES IN THE FINAL RULE. I
COMPARED TO OUR CURRENT STATUTES
THE CASE LAW AND THEN THE PRIOR
PROPOSAL FROM TWENTY TWENTY THAT
HAVE BEEN HELD IN MAY SHORTLY
AFTER THAT AND- WE REQUESTED
COMMENTS IN WRITING LATER IN
JANUARY. DID RECEIVE THIS YEAR
THE PROMISED AS ALEJO REQUESTED
WE HAVE WORKS TO PREPARE- I
MATRIX THAT SHOWS THE GENERAL
TENOR OF THOSE STAKEHOLDER
COMMENTS. AND HOW WE MODIFY OUR
PROPOSAL AND THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE STATE OF. WE ALSO
INTERVIEWED. GET AT LEAST ONE
HUNDRED THE CAL SINCE THE
RELEASE OF THE EXACT LANGUAGE
AND WE WILL WORK WITH THEM AS
WELL TO ADDRESS THERE SIR. I
SYMBOL RELEASED TO YOU BUT WE IT
WAS A GREAT PROCESS FOR RIVER
ABLE TO HEAR FROM OUR
STAKEHOLDERS- AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WATCH. THAT BOASTS
LANGUAGE AS IS AFTER THOSE
CHANGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. S. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS OF THE TRAILER BIL
LANGUAGE PROPOSALS AS DESCRIBED
THANK YOU. LOL NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. OKAY THANK YOU I THINK
WILL WORK WE ARE ALL EAGER TO
SEE MORE AND AS A LA OBRA
POINTED OUT PREVIOUSLY A TO BE
ABLE TO SEE- THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMENTS AND LEVEL OF
PARTICIPATION AND THEN YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THE FEEDBACK THAT
CAME BACK AFTERWARDS TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT- ANYWAY WE'LL
HAVE MORE WILL HAVE MORE TIME TO
LOOK AT THIS DR GRANT DENTIST ON
THE THANK YOU AND THAT JUST
RECOGNIZING THAT- WE WE'VE ONLY
VERY RECENTLY RECEIVED JUST
LANGUAGE SO- VERY INTERESTED
HAVING OPPORTUNITY WE LOOK AT
IT. THANK YOU YES AND WE
APPRECIATE THE STAFF WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY TO GET US AT LEAST
WHAT WHAT WE HAVE ALREADY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING MORE
THANK YOU OKAY. MOVING ON TO
ISSUE THEN NUMBER. I LOST MY BY. S. MANSION ACCOUNT OF AN
UPDATE ON- LAST YEAR'S
ACTIVITIES. HE DAVID- SO LAST
YEAR OUR SCENIC TWENTY TIME
PROJECT ON THE BUDGET INCLUDED
I'M FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS OR
NINETY NINE DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING TELL CSAS
THIS FUNDING RESTORE STATE WHITE
HOUSE YOU SEE FUNDING LEVELS
WERE REDUCED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR AS A
RESULT OF COMING NINETY AS
DIRECTOR HERE WERE MENTIONED THE
HIGHER PROPORTION OF THE
REDUCTIONS WERE TAKEN FROM US
YES HE'S ABOVE THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY WHEREAS THE
RESTORATION. ON MORE ONLY
ALLOCATED TO UNDERFUNDED
COUNTIES WHICH COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED ON USING THE NEW
FUNDING TO HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF
AND BRING UP THEIR CASE THE
STAFF OPERATIONS IN THE FIRST
HALF OF THE FISCAL YEAR HOUSE
YES HE'S RAMPED UP THEIR HIRING
IMPLEMENTED EFFORTS TO REACH AS
MANY FOLKS AS POSSIBLE AND
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS DAY POSTED
ON LINKED IN ANOTHER ON
APPROVING WEBSITES AND SERVICES
SOME COUNTY'S AGAIN SURGERY
EITHER SIRENS CONCERNING OPTIONS
TO MAKE THEIR POSITIONS MORE
ATTRACTIVE AND COMPETITIVE.
DURING THIS TIME ASSISI'S
EXPERIENCE HIGH LEVELS OF
STAFFING ATTRITION AS A AS A
RESULT OF RETIREMENTS AND
EMPLOYEES LEAVING FOR OTHER JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BETTER PAY AND
BENEFITS IN LINE WITH THE NINTH
NATIONAL TREND OF A TIGHT LABOR
MARKET HOWEVER WE ARE BEGINNING
TO SEE THE COUNTIES OVERCOME
THESE INITIAL CHALLENGES AS MORE
POSITIONS ARE BEING HELD JEFF
ATTRITION HAS MODERATED IN
OVERALL NET POSITIONS AT THE US
UC'S ARE BEGINNING TO INCREASE
DECSS WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
AND REPORT THIS INFORMATION IN
ITS QUARTERLY SR PORT WE ARE
HOPEFUL AND BELIEVE THAT THE
COUNCIL MAKE SIGNIFICANT.
PROGRESS IN THE SECOND HALF OF
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU. PARTY
FINANCING. YES NO CONCERNS WITH
THE DESCRIBED IMPLEMENTATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LMAO YES AS
THE DEPARTMENT MENTIONED- SOME
L. C. ESSAYS SINCE THE
RESTORATION OF THESE BONDS ON
THEIR FUNDING LEVELS HAVE
ACTUALLY DECREASED- THIS SEEMS
TO BE DUE TO- ED TOUGH LABOR
MARKET SAID NOT AS MANY PEOPLE
FLYING FOR OUR FOR POSITIONS BUT
THEN ALSO AS WAS HIGHLIGHTED AND
THE SRO REPORT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT SUBMITTED BACK IN
DECEMBER. I'M SOME PEOPLE
ACTUALLY- REJECTING THE JOB
OFFERS- AND A HIGH LEVEL A HIGH
NUMBER OF RETIREMENTS AS WELL-
SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
STOPPING TRENDS- IN PARTICULAR
AS IT PERTAINS TO UNDERFUNDED
ALL CSAS AND TO THEIR ABILITY TO
SPEND SHOULD THE PRIOR RESTORED
FUNDING- AS IT MADE THAT HAVE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THEIR- LEVEL OF
READINESS FOR AN ADDITIONAL
INFLUX OF RESOURCES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE DO
KEEP TRACK OF I'M SURE YOU KEEP
TRACK OF BUT AGAIN REGIONS THAT
ARE. HAVING MORE DIFFICULTY THAN
OTHERS AND IF SO IS THERE A
TRIGGER AT WHICH POINT THE STATE
WOULD HAVE TO COME IN AND HELP
IF PEOPLE WEREN'T ABLE TO. TO DO
THE BASIC FUNCTIONS OF GETTING
THE CHILD SUPPORT. OUT SO AT
THIS TIME THAT THE BASIC
FUNCTIONS OF THE TRUCKS WERE
PROGRAM ARE STRAIGHT AWAY
THEY'RE USED TO- DELIVERING THE
SERVICES THEY'RE JUST NOT.
CAPABLE OF DELIVERING THE SAME
QUALITY AS THEIR HIGHER FROM THE
COUNTIES MIGHT OTHERWISE BE ABLE
TO DO. SO AS THEY'RE RAMPING UP
IT JUST GIVES THEM. A REDUCED
CASELOAD- CASE WORKER- RATIO
WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO BE MORE
ENGAGING MORE SUPPORT OF THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT THEY START.
BUT ALSO TO THE POINT OF AS MORE
FUNDING COMES IN. THE STRUGGLE
MORE TO GET THAT THAT FUNDING
OUT- SO WE'RE JUST MAKING SURE
WE KEEP AN EYE ON THE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE MORE DIFFICULTY THAN
SOME OF THE MORE WELL FUNDED
COUNTIES. YOU KNOW STRUGGLE
GETTING THE FINDING OUT REAL
ESTATE WHY DISBURSING UNIT- THAT
COVERS THE ENTIRE STATE AND
THAT'S A CONTRACT THAT WE HOST
ALL THE MONEY COMES IN THE STATE
RIGHT SPACE MEAN AND THEY JUST
GIVE IT OUT SO. THE IMPACT ON
THE LC STAYS IS WORKING WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL ON CASE BY CASE BASIS
TO ADDRESS ANY. ISSUES OR
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE HAVING
IN PAYING THEIR CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES SO- PAYING CHILD
SUPPORT SO IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE
HANDS ON SUPPORT THE LC STAYS
AGO ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE. ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. THEIR
STRUGGLE IS REALLY JUST BRINGING
ON THE ADDITIONAL BODIES AND
TRAINING THEM UP IT'S A PRETTY
INTENSIVE ONE YEAR PROCESS TO
REALLY GET CHANGE WORKER FULLY
UP TO SPEED ON CHILD. SUPPORT
AND A LOT OF TIMES THEY'RE
LOSING. RICHER SHOULD EVEN
THROUGH TRAINING. A CERTAIN OF
THOSE. THAT THEY INVESTED TIME
ENERGY SILICON OVERCOME THAT.
THAT LOSS OF STAFF FROM RICH.
STAND FROM DROPPING OUT OF THE
TREE PROCESS IS TO GET THE
PULLED UP TO SPEED AND-
SUCCESSFUL CASE WORKER. YEAH
THANK YOU AND DR PANDA CERTAIN
WAY WELL. IN THIS THAN I AM.
WITH THE LONG BEEN A LONG TIME
BUDGET SHARE ON THIS BUT I AM
BUT I CAN TO SAY. TO SOMEONE
WHO'S JUST BEEN UP A MEMBER AND
THIS IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING YOU
HEAR A LOT ABOUT IN YOUR IN YOUR
DISTRICTS IN YOUR COMMUNITIES.
ON THE ISSUE AROUND A CHILD
SUPPORT SO. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS DOCTRINE
. NO OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
FIRST ASSUME WE CAN GET TO THE
COLLECTABILITY NEXT. OKAY YES
IT'S NOT A LITTLE PART MENACE-
I'M VERY EXCITED TO SHARE THE
WORK WE'RE DOING ON OUR
FLEXIBILITY STUDY WE'VE
DEVELOPED THE STATEMENT WORKERS
SO WE CAN LOOK AT THE FACTORS
THE LEGISLATURE HIGHLIGHTED FOR
US LAST YEAR IN EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE INSPECTORS ARE
REQUIRED TO CONSIDER- WE ALSO
ENGAGE YOUR STAKEHOLDERS ARE
RESCUED YOU HAD HERE- SUCH AS
OUR LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
THANK YOU DISTRICT COUNCIL OR
PROGRAM AS WELL AS AND THANKS
FOR LISTENING ADVOCATES KNOWN AS
TRUTH AND JUSTICE JOHN- LISTEN
THAT WE ASK THEM IF THERE ARE
OTHER FACTORS. IMPORTANCE DO YOU
CONSIDER BODY I'M INSTEAD
LANGUAGE ALLOW US TO LOOK OTHER
AS THEY WERE YOU CLASS ASENATH
ARE RIGHT NOW WE ARE GOING TO
WITH REDIFF CALIFORNIA YOU.
THING IF THEY DID STUDY FOR AND
BACKING THAT ALLEY I AND MY LAST
WEEK WE HAVE INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS
THANKS CAME THEIR PROPOSALS AS
TO HOW THEY WOULD BE THE STUDY
THAT WORK WORK VERY HARD THAT
OUR ABILITY THE MONEY AND A
POLICY. OKAY THANK AND THE PORT
OF FINANCE ANYTHING ON THIS THE
COLLECTIVE. NO NOT ON THIS THANK
YOU CALIO ANYTHING ON. NOTHING
OKAY THE DEFENSE JUST REMIND ME
WHAT I KNOW YOU'RE PROCESS TRY
THE ACTUAL RESEARCHERS BUT- WHEN
DO WE EXPECT THE RESULTS FROM
THE STUDY. THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE IS A JAN FIRST OF
TWENTY THREE. THERE IS A
DESPERATE FACT FOR RE YEAR. WHAT
THE PRESSURE SHOULD BE AND THEN
US MANDATORY. THAT IF THAT CASE
MEETS THAT CRITERIA AND THEN WE
WITH ANY. BLACKS OKAY BUT- RIGHT
NOW THE GOAL IS TO HAVE RESULTS
BY THE JERRY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE CORRECT EXACTLY YES THE
LANGUAGE PERMITS US TO IMPLEMENT
A POLICY LETTER TO BE FOLLOWED
UP REGULATIONS AS WELL. ALL
RIGHT WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO
WELL I WILL BE HERE BUT I LOOK
FORWARD AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN TO
SEE RESULTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WILL MISS YOUR DOCTOR PAN.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. I THINK. DIRECTOR
JOHNSON ARE YOU COMING. YEAH
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED BY
SENATOR CAN CAN JOHNSON DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES A LOT AT TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT THIS AFTERNOON IN
TERMS OF OUR CASH IN SUPPORT OF
SERVICES AND CAL WORKS IN THE
CHANGES THAT WE'VE BEEN MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS TO STRENGTHEN THAT
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS OUR FOOD
ASSISTANCE AND OUR HOUSING SO I
WILL START WITH TURNING IT OVER
TO OUR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
CHEN CHIU CHOI. WELCOME DEPUTY.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
IT'S WONDERFUL TO BE HERE WITH
YOU THIS AFTERNOON I'M THE FIRST
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED OF US
AND WITH RESPECT TO THE COW
WORKS ITEMS IS TO JUST PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THEIR PROPOSED
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
CAO WORKS BUDGET AND TO OFFER A
DESCRIPTION OF THE SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATIONS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I AS YOU KNOW
WELL THE COW WORKS PROGRAM IS
THE CORNERSTONE OF THE STATE
SAFETY NET FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN.
PROVIDING CASH ASSISTANCE AND
EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATION RELATED
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS INCLUDING
CHILD CARE. A TOTAL PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THE PROGRAM. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
INCLUDES SIX POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN A MIX OF THE FEDERAL
AND STATE FUNDS. THE MOST RECENT
ACTUAL DATA REFLECTS THAT THE
PROGRAM WAS SERVING AROUND THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FAMILIES. AS
WE'LL TALK ABOUT MORE WITH THE
NEXT QUESTION- WE ARE PROJECTING
FOR THE PROGRAM TO GROW BY OVER
12% IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. WITH RESPECT TO CASH
ASSISTANCE WE ARE PROJECTING AN
INCREASE OF A SEVEN POINT 1% TO
THE MAXIMUM GRANTS. THIS WOULD
BRING THE MAXIMUM GRANT FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE AND A HIGH COST
COUNTY TWO NINE HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE DOLLARS A MONTH. IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AS
WE LOOK AT THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
INCLUDED A NUMBER OF CHANGES AND
SIGNIFICANT AUGMENTATIONS
RELATIVE TO THE COW WORKS
PROGRAM. THAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING THIS YEAR AND IN
SOME INSTANCES THAT DON'T BEGIN
UNTIL THE BUDGET YEAR IN TERMS
OF THEIR EFFECTIVE TIMING. A
COUPLE OF KEY EXAMPLES THERE
INCLUDE THE EXTENSION OF TIME
LIMIT FROM FORTY EIGHT TO SIXTY
MONTHS. WHICH WILL BE EFFECTIVE
MAY OF THIS YEAR I INCREASES TO
THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD
PREGNANCY RELATED BENEFITS. AND
ASSISTANCE TO FAMILIES TRYING TO
REUNIFY WITH THEIR CHILDREN
THROUGH THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
FOR COUNTY CAO WORKS STAFF. AND
BENEFITS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
AFGHAN MILITARY AND PAROLEES. SO
WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
IMPLEMENT ALL OF THESE RECENT
CHANGES AND INVESTMENTS WHILE
ALSO LOOKING AHEAD TO THE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET- WITHOUT
I WILL PAUSE AND SEE IF YOUR-
QUESTIONS ON THIS HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW AND THEN FROM THERE.
CRISTINA MESSA WHO IS THE CHIEF
OF OUR CAO WORKS AND FAMILY
RESILIENCE BRANCH IS PREPARED TO
ANSWER THE NEXT QUESTIONS FOR
THIS ITEM. I THINK WE'LL MOVE ON
YEAH OKAY THE QUESTIONS PLEASE.
OKAY THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
THE SOFA THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATORS THINK INTENDED
AFTERNOON. I'M AND TO THE NEXT
QUESTION IS SPECIFIC TO THAT HOW
WORKS HE SPOKE. AYE WELL CAO
WORKS CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE A
DECLINE IN OERALL QUISO
THROUGHOUT THE FIRST HALF OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALENDAR YEAR-
THE COLORS PROGRAM DID
EXPERIENCE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN APPLICATION VOLUME
DURING THE LATE SUMMER. AND FALL
MONTHS OF LOS CALENDAR YEAR.
AROUND THE SAME TIME THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE A LOSS
OF SIGNIFICANT UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. THE DEPARTMENT WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE FOLKS OVER AT
TV TO ENSURE. THAT PARTICIPANTS
THAT WORK THE THING THAT BENEFIT
CLASS HAD ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION NEEDED
I HAD TO APPLY FOR SAFETY NET
BENEFITS WHICH OF COURSE IS
INCLUSIVE. OF BOTH CALFRESH IN
COLOR. WE ARE STILL AT THIS TIME
WAITING ON FINAL DATA TO
DEMONSTRATE WHETHER OR NOT- THAT
INCREASE THAT WERE EXPERIENCING
AN APPLICATION VOLUME
CONTRIBUTED TO AN INCREASE IN
CASELOAD. BUT WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WE WILL SEE AN INCREASE ONCE
THAT DATA IS AVAILABLE ON. WE
ALSO KNOW NOW THAT DENIALS CROSS
CAL WORKS FOR APPLICATIONS THAT
WERE PROCESSED. DURING THE
PANDEMIC WERE HEAVILY DENIED DUE
TO BEING OVER INCOME. HOWEVER WE
ONLY HAVE DATA AVAILABLE THROUGH
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO
WERE UNABLE TO SPEAK. AT LEAST
AT THIS TIME IF THAT TREND-
REMAINS DURING THAT BENEFIT
QUITE YET. CURRENTLY OUR
CASELOAD IS REPRESENTATIVE OF
JUST ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES AS A GINGER
SHARED- BUT AGAIN WE'RE WAITING
ON MORE OF THAT ACCURATELY THAT-
A FORMER COUNTY TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT HE SAID INCREASES THAT WERE
ANTICIPATING. OUT WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO EXIT
RATE. AS THE KING SAUD HELD A
FAIRLY STEADY THROUGHOUT THIS
PAST YEAR. MEDIA LAST COMPONENT
OF COLOR HE SAID THAT WE WANTED
TO SHARE- WE WERE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT GOOD CAUSE DURING THE
PANDEMIC FOR MANY OF OUR WELFARE
TO WORK PARTICIPANTS- AND SO WE
EXPERIENCE. IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE DECLINE IN
SANCTIONED HE'S LOADED- WHICH
NOW MAKES UP JUST ABOUT 3% OF
OUR TOTAL KEYSTONE ARTWORK.
BECAUSE THERE IS BUSY MAKING
SIDE QUESTIONS AS KICK OFF.
PERFECT THANK YOU I THE NEXT
QUESTION IS DIRECTLY PERTAINING
TO FUNDING FOR HOW WORKS IN THE
FUNDING CHANGES AS TO THE
FUNDING FOR HOW WORKS
ELIGIBILITY ADMINISTRATION- IS
DETERMINED BY A NEW METHODOLOGY
THAT WAS DEVELOPED IN
COORDINATION. WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR AT
THE VERY HIGH CASELOAD OF
FORECASTS DURING THE PANDEMIC I
DID NOT MATERIALIZE AND CAL
WORKS ALTHOUGH A FUNDING
AGREEMENTS FOR COUNTIES WERE
MAINTAINED ARE PROVIDED IN BOTH
THE- NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEARS. AGO THE CASELOAD IS
PROJECTED TO INCREASE IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IT IS NOT
INCREASING AND KNOCKED ME CLEAN
ALL OF THOSE INCREMENTS
INCREASES THAT WERE PROVIDED IN
THE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. AT LEAST
ON THE UPPER METHOD- THE
CASELOAD WOULD NEED TO BE
FORECASTED. TO INCREASE TO ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
CAL WORKS FAMILIES AT TWO
NINETEEN THE FUNDING LEVEL THAT
WAS PROVIDED IN THAT. AT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. AS A CALL YET TO
THAT POINT I THIS IS NOT
INCLUSIVE OF THE ON GOING TO
INCREASE AND BE SPENDING-
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
COUNCILS. I THINK HOW WORK
SINGLE ALLOCATION FUNDS
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES ARE THE
ELIGIBILITY ADMINISTRATION ALEC
HOW LEARN INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT- OF THE TOTAL SINGLE
ALLOCATION FUNDING FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. 63% TWENTY
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. 36% FOR
THAT ELIGIBILITY ADMINISTRATION
AND THEN THE REMAINING 1% WERE
DISTRIBUTED TO COUNTY. WE ALSO
WANTED TO NOTE THAT- WHILE THIS
IS DESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF
FUNDING FOR THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION BUT NOT FUNDED
THROUGH SINGLE ALLOCATION BUT
FUNDED SEPARATELY ARE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
SERVICES FAR HOW WORKS FAMILIES
AS WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SERVICES FOR-
PROVIDED THEIR INDIAN HEALTH
CLINIC. IT'S ALSO NOT INCLUSIVE
OF THE EXPANDED SUBSIDIZE
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS- THE
PROGRAM IN WHICH WERE ABLE TO
PAY THE WAGES OF PARTICIPANTS
FOR ENGAGE IN WORK EXPERIENCE
OPPORTUNITIES THE WELFARE TO
WORK. IT ALSO DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE FAMILY STABILIZATION- A
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE OUR CAL
WORKS FAMILIES BY DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM PROGRAM. OR THE HOME
VISITING PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
AND CAL WORKS IN FOR HOME
VISITING PROGRAM IT SEPARATELY
BY THEY FOR BOTH THE HOME VISITS
THEMSELVES AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. PORTION AT A
VISITING. BUT THAT OPPOSE THIS.
AT THERE'S QUESTIONS ON THE
FUNDING ITEMS. DOES THAT
COMPLETE CAL WORKS PRESENTATION
. IT DOES YES OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. NO COMMENTS AT THIS
TIMEBUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS DELEO. GOOD AFTERNOON
RYAN ANDERSON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
JUST LIKE TO. ELABORATE ON ONE
POINT THAT THE DEPARTMENT MADE
ABOUT RECENT CASE LAW DYNAMICS
POST PANDEMIC I KNOW THIS IS
BEEN A BIG FOCUS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAS ALSO BEEN A BIG
FOCUS FOCUS OF OUR OFFICE. JUST
TO REVIEW WE ALL EXPECTED AT THE
OUTSET OF THE PANDEMIC THAT HAS
UNEMPLOYMENT INCREASED CASE LOAD
WOULD INCREASE IN SOME
PROPORTION TO THAT THAT THAT'S
HISTORICALLY WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
AND INSTEAD OF GETTING AN
INCREASE WE'D GUIDE HISTORIC
DECREASE- FROM THE SUMMER OF TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY THROUGH
NEARLY THE MOST RECENT DATA-
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
INVESTIGATING. WELL WHAT IS THE
CAUSE OF THIS DECREASE IN PART
BECAUSE WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHETHER POLICY MEASURES WE COULD
TAKE TO ENSURE THAT ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES WHO ARE NOT. REACHING
THE PROGRAM COULD BE REACHED IN
PART BECAUSE IT'S A- FORECASTING
A DILEMMA RIGHT- WE HAD THIS
QUESTION OF AT WHAT POINT WITH
THE DATA TO CATCH UP WITH
HISTORIC NORMS IN THE CASE OF
START GROWING AGAIN. WE KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO CONDUCTED
THEIR OWN INVESTIGATION OF THOSE
QUESTIONS INDEPENDENTLY WE BOTH
I. THINK THROUGH A PROCESS OF
ELIMINATION. I CAME UP WITH A
BEST GUESS B. AND THEN THIS WILL
SOMEHOW TO THE EXTRA- FINANCE.
AND ECONOMIC SUPPORT OFFERED BY
THE STATE AND ESPECIALLY BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOUSE
PANDEMIC. ESPECIALLY THE
EXPIRATION OF ENHANCED
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND THIS
IS BOTH THE SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR A
WEEK- ARE I BENEFIT AND THE
STAFF WAS MEANT OF THE CANON.
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
WHICH ALLOWED FOR THE FIRST TIME
SELF EMPLOYED WORKERS TO RECEIVE
YOU AYE BENEFITS THOSE WITH
EXPIRED IN SEPTEMBER. IN BOTH
OUR OFFICE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. ARE PROJECTING
THAT WITH THAT EXPIRATION WE
WOULD SEE SOME RETURN TO THIS
HISTORICAL NORMS A- RESUMPTION
OF GROWTH IN THE PROGRAM. AS A
RESULT DESPITE THE FACT THAT
RECENTLY OUR TWO OFFICES HAVE
HAD WILDLY DIVERGING PROJECTIONS
FOR THIS CASE THOUGH. I
CURRENTLY WE'RE RIGHT ON THE
SAME PAGE OF COURSE THE BIG
QUESTION IS WELL. ARE WE BOTH
RIGHT- THE INITIAL DATA. IT'S
NOT REALLY CLEAR IT IS TRUE THAT
IN THE MOST RECENT DATA IN
SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER OF LAST
YEAR- CASELOAD STARTED GROWING
AGAIN AND THAT'S THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE SEEN IT BROWN. AGAIN SINCE
THE FIRST MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT THE GROWTH WAS RELATIVELY
MODEST ABOUT TWO THOUSAND CASES
A YEAR BOTH OUR OFFICES WERE
EXPECTING SOMETHING CLOSER TO
TEN THOUSAND CASE IT TEN
THOUSAND CASES A MONTH. HI WE'RE
STILL WAITING ON MORE RECENT
DATA SO THIS UNTESTED AS
ASSUMPTION REMAINS TO BE PROVEN
BUT- INITIAL DATA SOMEONE
ENCOURAGING BUT THAT'S THE ONLY
POINT I NEED TO MAKE RIGHT NOW.
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU YES WE ALL
ON THAT FOR ESPECIALLY IF YOU
TIME. AT FOOD OR TALKING TO OUR
- FOODBANK PROVIDERS. THERE WAS
A MISDEMEANOR HUGE NEED AROUND
BASIC RESOURCES AND SO IT IT IT
REMAINS. VERY CURIOUS TO A TO
ALL OF US IN YOUR RIGHT IT
REALLY IT HAMPERS PROJECTIONS-
IF YOU'RE NOT QUITE SURE IF IT'S
GOING TO COME BACK OR NOT- SO I
GUESS I GUESS. SO ARE YOU
COMFORTABLE WITH THE WITH THE
CURRENT. TWELVE POINT SIX
INCREASE THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROJECTING. YES OUR OFFICE.
INDEPENDENTLY PROJECTED A VERY
SIMILAR CASELOAD INCREASE SO. WE
HAVE NO PROBLEMS WITH THE-ADMINISTRATION'S PROJECTIONS AT
THIS TIME OF COURSE. FOR ALL
REVISIT THIS AGAIN IN MAY WHEN
WILL HAVE MORE RECENT DATA.
FFESTINIOG PRINT. THANK YOU IF
YOU QUESTIONS SO ONE IS THAT-
YOU KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT OF
COURSE UNEMPLOYMENT- TO THESE
ENDING IN SEPTEMBER ALSO- THE
CHILD TAX CREDIT ENDED- JUST
ENDED SO TO WHAT DEGREE DO YOU
THINK IT IS THAT SORT FACT I'M
SURE YOU FACTORED IN BUT- HOW
MUCH OF IMPACT YOU THINK THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE ON CAL WORKS AND
ROMAN WHICH- WHICH OFTEN.
INVOLVES FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
. EIGHT IN THEORY I COULD HAVE
TREMENDOUS IMPACT I'D BE IN
INTERIOR NEARLY EVERY CAL WORKS
FAMILY IF NOT EVERY- EXCEPTING
MAYBE THOSE THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
IT SOME IMMIGRATION- EXCLUSIONS
SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
EXPANDED- CHILD TAX CREDIT THAT
WE SAW. THROUGHOUT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YEAR- THAT WAS THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH THAT
COMPARES VERY FAVORABLY AT THE
PER CHILD TO ATTACK COMPARES
VERY FAVORABLY TO THE ASSISTANCE
THAT'S OFFERED BY CAL WORKS
ITSELF SO. POTENTIALLY A VERY
ATTRACTIVE ALTERNATIVE TO BEING
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM- IT
CERTAINLY A GOOD HYPOTHESIS THAT
WITH THAT EXPIRATION IN DECEMBER
WE WOULD SEE SOME ADDITIONAL
IMPACT ON CASELOAD. I THINK THE
COMPLICATING FACTOR THERE MIGHT
BE- THE ONE PAPER MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES WERE ELIGIBLE DID IN
FACT RECEIVE IT AND ALL A LOT OF
TIMES THAT DEPENDS ON WELL DID
THEY FILE TAXES IN THE PRIOR
YEAR A LOT OF CAL WORKS FAMILIES
REPORTED ZERO EARNED INCOME. AND
A LOT OF THOSE FAMILIES DON'T
FILE TAX RETURNS AND THUS WHEN
AND IF IT FOR ME BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THE AMOUNT OF
PAPERWORK TO FILE TAXES HOW'S
THAT WAY AGAINST ABOUT PEOPLE
WORK IT TAKES ABOUT THE CALYX
RIGHT. HOW MUCH EFFORT IT TAKES
ALL RIGHT IT'S A GOOD QUESTION
YEAH. THE OTHER THE OTHER-
ACTUALLY QUESTION I ASK IS THAT-
AND AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECORD THAT SO-
WE DID. SO MANY ISSUES THAT CAME
BACK AS THEY CAME UP SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WAS- AFTER WE GET
THROUGH THE GREAT RECESSION WAS. THE SINGLE ALLOCATION FORMULA
ISSUE. THAT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS
. COUNTIES IN WITH DURING GOOD
TIMES WOULD BE TREMENDOUSLY
UNDERFUNDED FOR THEIR STAFF AND
THEN WHEN THE RECESSION HIT
SUDDENLY HAVE TO YOU KNOW UP. UP
FUND AND THEN DON'T HIRE PEOPLE
AT CETERA. I KNOW IN THIS CASE
HERE BASED ON THAT TESTIMONY
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION YELLED
THAT. REDUCTION OF FIFTY FIVE
MILLION IS DUE TO I GUESS. THE
INTENSIFICATION THE DIDN'T WAY
OUT FORTUNATELY ACTUALLY- THAT
WE WOULD CERTAINLY HAVE A LOT
MORE PEOPLE AND ROLLED- WHEN
KOBE HEAD- BUT I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS THAT. THE OF THE
REFORMS THAT WE MAY TWO. I USED
TO COUNTY ADMINISTRATION AND IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE FIND FOR YOU
KNOW SINGLE ALLOCATION AND BE
SURE TO BE ADEQUATE FUND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR- THE COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AND OTHER
WORKERS WO ADMINISTER CAL WORKS
IS THAT WORKING APPROPRIATELY
ARE WE HAVING LARGE AND THAT
THIS IS AN 8% REDUCTION FROM I
UNDERSTAND FROM THIS BUDGET. IT
ARE WE HAVING ENOUGH STABILITY
IN THE LEVEL FUNDING WE'RE
PROVIDING TO COUNTIES TO
MAINTAIN THEIR- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY SO THAT
WE CAN CONSISTENTLY ADMINISTERS
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY ELDERLY
UPSWINGS IN THE ECONOMY THINGS
GET BETTER AND THEN THERE'S LESS
FUNDING YEAH SO I JUST WANTED TO
TOUCH ON THAT- SINCE WE DID MAKE
THOSE REFORMS MANY YEARS AGO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO THE CYCLE WITH
COKE. I GUESS THAT'S THE
QUESTION PERHAPS FOR BOTH
ADMINISTRATION L. A. L. THEY
WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT. THANK
YOU ADEGOKE THE- FACT ADDS THAT
JUSTIN FREITAS WANTS TO JUMP AND
GO AHEAD. AND ANNOUNCE FILE. YES
RAISED FOR YOU DIRECTOR- JOHNSON
I THINK YOU'RE RECORDS AND JUST
A KIND OF ANSWERING THE BIT
ACROSS IS. IT IS NOT NECESSARILY
FOLDER. IN THE FUNDING THAT-
THAT METHODOLOGY YOU MAY WAS A
GREETED. BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE MID. TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THEN
IN THE TWENTY ONE BY ACT. THERE
WERE- TO DIFFERENT ON. TO THIS
YOUNG CATION FUNDING ONE WAY
THAT- A ONE TIME AUGMENTATION.
OF AROUND TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
AND THEN THERE IS A SECOND
AUGMENTATION IT WAS AN ONGOING
AUGMENTATIONS THE BASE. SO WHAT
YOU'RE REALLY SEEING HERE IS-
IS- AND- A COMMITMENT AND AN END
TO WHAT THE CURRENT METHODOLOGY
IS. TEN YEARS SEEN A DIFFERENCE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR PROJECTION
JUST BECAUSE THERE WAS AN
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME. INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET ACTS. SO BASED ON THE
WEIGHT SHE SERVE HIS BEEN
TRAINING AND WORKING IN THAT
THIS THIS METHODOLOGY FOR THE
ADMIN FUNDING IS. IS APPEARING
TO BE IN LINE. WITH WHAT I
COUNTY NEEDS TO BE AND THEN
AGAIN DIRECTOR JOHNSON IF
THERE'S ANYTHING. THAT YOU WANT
TO ADD ON THE- I THINK I THINK
YOU. OKAY AND OUT OF ANY KIND AT
ANY COME FROM A. L. YEAH.
SENATOR PANDUIT WE THINK YOU'RE
ASKING THE CRUCIAL CRUCIAL
QUESTION HERE THAT'S IT THERE'S
TWO CATEGORIES- ONE IS WHETHER
THE SPECIFIC ADJUSTMENT THAT.
WAS MADE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WAS APPROPRIATE JUST BY
THE BOOK RIGHT AND WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY ALL THE MOVING PIECES
THERE BUT IT DOES LOOK LIKE.
DESPITE HOW AUDIT APPEARS THEY
IT WAS APPROPRIATE UNDER THE
LETTER OF THE LAW FOR THAT
DROPPED TO OCCUR. PERCENT DOES
LEAVE OPEN THE FUN TO QUESTION
WHICH IS- IS THE FORMULA
OPERATING AS INTENDED BUT
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE INTENSE OF
THE FORMULA AS WE UNDERSTAND IT
WAS TO ENSURE THAT CHANGES TO.
THIS FUNDING AMOUNT WERE IN LINE
BOTH WITH COUNTIES ABILITY TO
CHANGE THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
CAPACITY AND ALSO THE CHANGING
NEEDS OF THE PROGRAM AND- THAT
SECOND POINT DOESN'T APPEAR TO
BE ADDRESS WHENEVER YOU HAVE A
SITUATION. WHERE FUNDING IS
DECREASING AT A TIME WHEN NEED
IS INCREASING- THERE'S ALSO JUST
YOU KNOW UNDERLYING QUESTIONS
ABOUT- WHETHER ON GOING FORWARD
THE UNDERLYING FUNDING AMOUNT IS
ADEQUATE TO MEET THE NEED WHERE
WE'RE STILL WE'RE- WAITING ON
ADDITIONAL DATA FROM- COUNTY IS
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT
QUESTION. NOW AFTER IT PRECIADO
AND ALSO APPRECIATED
MINISTRATION POINTING OUT THAT-
PART OF THE QUOTE REDUCTION IS
BECAUSE OF AUGMENTATIONS MADE
AND- MILLION PRIOR BUDGET SO-
BUT I DID I DO HOPE THAT AND YOU
KNOW BEGAN THE SYSTEM HAVING
BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE FIRST YET
FOR A FEW YEARS THAT- WE ARE.
DEVELOPING THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO
YOU IN THE BASE FUNDING ETCETERA
THAT WE ARE YOU KNOW I'D BE SURE
THAT WE MAINTAIN THE APPROPRIATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO ADMINISTER
THIS PROGRAM IN A WAY THAT EVEN
WITH FLUCTUATING CASES DUE TO
ECONOMIC YOU KNOW AND OTHER
REASONS THAT- WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO SERVE PEOPLE NOW
THAT THAT THE BENEFICIARIES AND-
THAT- THAT. THAT- YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT WHICH WE PREVIOUSLY DID HAVE
WHAT WOULD BE A RAMP UP AND YOU
KNOW WIND OUT AND RAMP UP THE
MINE DOWN OFTENTIMES IN BOTH THE
WINDING UP THE ON RAMP BEING
PARTICULARLY IN RAMPING UP WE
WERE ALWAYS PLAYING CATCH UP.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
SUFFICIENT BASE FUNDING AND SO
FORTH SO I JUST HOPE THAT AS
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE STORE
CONTINUE TO EXAMINE THAT AND
MAKING REFINEMENTS. AND OF
COURSE I'M SURE WE'LL HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES AS WELL FROM THEIR
EXPERIENCE HOW THEY FEEL THIS IS
WORKING AS WELL SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THE ANSWERS TO THAT. I
THINK WITH THAT- AT LEAST I
THINK I'M DONE WITH CALYXT IN
THIS BACK TO YOU OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MY- THE TIME IN THE
AFTERNOON. GETTING LET'S TALK A
- CAL FOR DIRECT JOHNSON. IT'S
CERTAINLY AN AGAIN I CAN JOHN
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO T. DEPUTY
TRAFFIC YOU THINK. THANK
DIRECTOR JOHN. AGAIN CHEN. I
DEATH DIRECTOR OF THE- SO. THE
FIRST QUESTION THAT YOU ASK FOR
SO TO CALPERS IN NATURE PROGRAM
WAS ALL. FOR AN OVER. OF THE
PATELLA BUDGET FOR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY- CALFRESH AS YOU KNOW
IT'S IS. CAL VERSION OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR SNAP
HISTORICALLY KNOWN AS FOOD
STAMPS- AND SOMETIMES STILL
REFERRED TO THAT WAY. THE
PROGRAM PROVIDES CLOSE TO TEN
BILLION DOLLARS AND FEDERALLY
FUNDED FOOD ASSISTANCE. TO
COMBAT HUNGER AND FOOD
INSECURITY AMONG CALIFORNIANS.
ANOTHER CRITICAL ASPECT OF OUR
SPEAKING THAT. AROUND FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
BENEFIT FROM THIS ESSENTIAL
SUPPORT. IN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL STATE AND
COUNTY FUNDS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CALFRESH
PROGRAM. SOME OTHER CRITICAL
ITEMS OF NOTE WITH RESPECT TO
NUTRITIONAL PROGRAMS OPERATED BY
CDSS AND THE COUNTIES IN THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET.
INCLUDES SOME ADDITIONAL DETAILS
RELATED TO THE EXPANSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR C. FACT. THE SEAT
BACK PROGRAM PROVIDES FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO INDIVIDUALS
CURRENTLY WHO ARE INELIGIBLE FOR
CALFRESH BECAUSE OF CHANGES THAT
WERE MADE IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
TO EXCLUDE CERTAIN NON CITIZENS
FROM FEDERAL FOOD ASSISTANCE.
LAST YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE AGREED TO EXPAND
THE FACT TO ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR CALIBRATION
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
. THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
PROPOSING SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAILS RELATIVE TO THAT
EXPANSIONAND MORE SPECIFICALLY
OUR PROPOSAL IS TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO ARE AGE
FIFTY FIVE OR OLDER. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR FOR
AUTOMATION OUT OF REACH AND
STATE OPERATIONS IN PREPARATION
FOR THIS EXPANSION. ANOTHER
THING I WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS THE
P. EBT PROGRAM OR PANDEMIC
ELECTRONIC BENEFIT TRANSFER PBT
IS A FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM AS
WELL IF MINISTERED BY CDFI IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. GROUP
P. A. B. TEAM WE PROVIDE FOOD
BENEFITS TO- CHILDREN WHO ARE
UNABLE TO ATTEND SCHOOL OR CHILD
CARE- IN PERSON BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
EXTENDED- THROUGH THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR SO PLANNING FOR THAT
EXTENSION HAS JUST BEGUN AS WE
ARE PLAYING SOME CATCH UP WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THESE
BENEFITS THAT WE STOOD UP DURING
THE PANDEMIC. SO CURRENTLY WE
EXPECT TO ISSUE BENEFITS THOSE
BENEFITS IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THE BUDGET DOES
INCLUDE SOME- FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR TRANSACTION
COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED.
FINALLY I WOULD EMPHASIZE BACK
HEALTH FOOD. WHICH IS AT A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION IN FUNDING TO
PROVIDE FOR THE PURCHASE AND
DISTRIBUTION OF ADDITIONAL FOOD.
FOR THIS EMERGENCY FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. SO WITH THAT
I WILL- LEAVE IT THERE FOR THE
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY AND FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN THIS
ITEM AND PASS IT TO OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER THE FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND EMPOWERMENT
DIVISION. JENNIFER HERNANDEZ.
THANK YOU WELCOME BACK TO BE
HERNANDEZ. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN YOUR WOMAN- WE ARE
WILL GO ON TO THE NEXT SERIES OF
QUESIONS- THE FIRST QUESTION IS
RELATED TO HOW WE REACH THE-
SETTLED ON THE FIFTY MILLION
AMOUNT PROPOSED FOR THE FOOD
BANKS- SO CURRENTLY AT CDSS
WE'RE PROVIDING TEN MILLION AND
FOOD BOXES PER MONTH TO THE FOOD
BANKS UTILIZING OUR COMPLETED
NINETEEN FOOD BANKS SUPPORT
FUNDING. AND THIS FUNDING IS
OLD- REALLY GEARED AT ALLOWING
OUR FOOD BANKS TO DISTRIBUTE AT
THIS LEVEL OF TEN MILLION
THROUGH JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THIS ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION AS AN AUGMENTATION TO
THE COP WOULD PROGRAM IS
PROPOSED TO ALLOW EMERGENCY FOOD
BOX PROGRAM TO END OUT WHILE
PROVIDING FOOD BANKS WITH
RESOURCES FOR THE SMOOTHER RAMP
DOWN AS FEDERAL AND STATE
EMERGENCY FOOD. ALLOCATION START
TO TAPER OFF. NICOLE ABOUT THAT
. THIS IS GOOD ALL THE WAY
THROUGH ALTHOUGH ALL RIGHT. THE
SECOND ITEM IS REALLY TO OUR
PRIDE AND OUR SPENDING PLANS-
FOR A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT FOR
FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO-
WE CONSULTED WITH OUR COUNTY
STAKEHOLDERS CLIENT ADVOCATES-
ED TO INVEST THE FORTY THREE
MILLION IN. THE FOLLOWING AREAS
WE INVESTED AROUND RACE
ACCORDING COLLUSION AND IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING- TARGETED OUTREACH
TO EXPAND CALFRESH INCLUDING
STRATEGIES ON ENSURING THAT
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
CAN COME INTO OUR PROGRAM. THERE
WAS ALSO AN INVESTMENT IN
BENEFITS CALON CAL SAUCE- WITH
SPECIFIC ENHANCEMENTS
ENHANCEMENTS THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT AS- ALONG
WITH APPLICATION THE SISTERS
NEEDED IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE. OUR
CLIENTS SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
WHICH WE KNOW IS THAT IS A
CRITICAL NEED IN IN MANY
COMMUNITIES- AND THEN LASTLY WE
DID INVEST ADDITIONALLY AROUND
EXPANDED ACCESS LANGUAGE ACCESS
INCLUDING. ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES
FOR ALL ONLINE AND PAPER FORMS-
AND THEN LASTLY WE ALSO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENT AROUND
IMPROVING EBT CARD SECURITY-
SUCH AS THE CVV WHICH IS
TYPICALLY WHAT YOU SEE ON CARDS
THE NUMBER ON THE BACK. I'M IN
TERMS OF OUR PLAN FOR FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE- WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF PLANNING FOR
CONVENE OUR STAKEHOLDERS I LATER
THIS SPRING WE WILL ALSO INCLUDE
OBVIOUSLY THE CALIFORNIA WELFARE
DIRECTORS. ASSOCIATION AND ITS
MEMBERS ALONG WITH OTHER CLIENT
ADVOCATES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN COLLECTIVELY IDENTIFY
PRIORITIES FOR OUR OUR BUT FUNDS
AND SO THAT WILL HAPPEN LATER
THIS SPRING AND WE CAN- REPORT
AT A LATER DATE IN TERMS OF
WHERE. WE LAND ON INVESTMENTS.
THE NEXT ITEM IN REALLY TO A
DEAN- CALFRESH- BUDGET METHOD-
IN TERMS OF WHERE WE'RE AT IN
THE PROCESS THE STATE IN
COUNTIES- WILL NOT BE RESUMING
ADMIN REBASE SCENE AT THIS TIME-
A NEW METHODOLOGY. AND TOLE-
WE'RE AT A PLACE IN THE PANDEMIC
WHERE- WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CAPACITY AND THINGS ARE
STABILIZED IN TERMS OF-
ELIGIBILITY IN THIS
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITIES.
WITHIN THE OPERATIONS- THE
CALIFORNIA ADMIN REBASE WILL
RIGHT SIZE THE CALPERS COUNTY
PROPHECIES THAT ARE IN PLACE-
WHILE WE ALSO DEVELOP A MULTI
YEAR PLAN TO BRING EFFICIENCIES
TO THE PROGRAM. IN THE END THOSE
ARE FIRST SERIES OF QUESTIONS IF
YOU'D LIKE OUR- ANY QUESTIONS
NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THIS IS
JIMMY DR WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. LMAO NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OKAY. M. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
JUST WANT TO. THANK THE
DEPARTMENT VERY MUCH ESPECIALLY
FOR THE EBT ONLINE PURCHASING IT
WAS SUDDENLY HEARD ABOUT A LOT
IN THE DISTRICTS. AND WAS SO
GREAT TO SEE THAT YOU WERE ABLE
TO GET MORE PEOPLE THAN JUST-
AMAZON WALMART TO GO ONLINE TO
AND GREAT TO SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO USE THAT.
ESPECIALLY TO SHOP SAFELY FOR
FOOD AT DURING THE PANDEMIC- DID
WE SEE THAT TALK TO ME ABOUT THE
CASELOAD NUMBERS. IN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CAL WORKS
CASELOAD NUMBERS. SURE SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY AT AN ALL TIME HIGH IN
TERMS OF OUR CASELOAD FOR
CALIFORNIA- WERE AT OVER TWO
MILLION- HOUSEHOLDS AND OVER-
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR MILLION
INDIVIDUALS- IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN- COMPARED TO CAL
WORKS. OBVIOUSLY THE INCREASES
HAVE BEEN FAR GREATER- IN IN
CALFRESH HOWEVER- THERE ARE
HISTORIC SORT OF CHIPS THAT WE
SEE TYPICALLY TOWARDS THE END OF
THE YEAR. DECEMBER JANUARY ISSUE
AND WE DID SEE THOSE MATERIALIZE
HOWEVER- WE STARTED TO SEE A PIC
IN APPLICATIONS IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND MAYBE THIS IS FOR A
DIRECTOR JOHNSON HOW ARE WE
DOING AND I KNOW IT'S THE NOTES
ARE IN THE PROCESS BUT WORLD I
WOULD HAVE ONE APPLICATION AND-
GOING TO QUALIFY FOR EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'RE QUALIFIED FOR. HOW
IS THAT PROCESS COMING ALONG.
YEAH WE ARE ABSOLUTELY. SURE WE
ARE WORKING ON OUR HEALTH
BENEFITS. AT EXTERNALITY WITHIN
OUR COUNCIL COUNCIL SYSTEMS SO
WE'RE GLAD TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. TO THE
COMMITTEE I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THAT AFRICA COMING ON AN
AGENDA BUT TO YOUR
THINK ONE OTHER POINT ON THE
LAST SECTION OF YOUR AGENDA IS
THAT WE ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME
ARE ACTUALLY HAVE SOME.
DEDICATED RESOURCES TO START
WITH ON CAL WORKS OUT REACH TO
HOWARD THAT HEALTH PRESSURE OUT
REACH CAL WORKS OUT REACH. OF
THE TOTALITY OF THE ARRAY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BUILT TO SUPPORT
IN DESTRUCTIVE READY FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCE AND HOW
THOSE THINGS COME TOGETHER. AT
THE DOOR AT DOES NO WRONG DOOR
INTO EVERY SINGLE ENTRY QUITE
SO. AT THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
ACT OF A BENEFIT FOR IT- IS A
COMPONENT OF THAT BUT ALSO WE
REALLY ARE WORKING TO INTEGRATE
OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS. AT. TO
ENSURE THAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
FRONT END. OKAY WE THANK YOU FOR
WORK AT THE IT'S JUST VITAL AND
- AMPARO THINK ABOUT IT WITH
WHEN WE THAT SOON. RIGHT OKAY DR
GRANT. OF THE YOU ACTUALLY THE
FIRST OF AUGUST TO CALM I KNOW
IT'S A THE PREVIOUS ITEM THEN
I'M GOING TO SELL- JUST. SORRY
FOR NOT MAKING IT TO HAVE AT THE
END OF THE PREVIOUS ITEM I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT ON THE COW WORK
SIDE. WHEN THE GOALS FOR THE
PROCESSOR TO MY CHAIRMANSHIP-
NOW SUPERVISOR HOW INITIAL THEN
CENTER HOLLY MITCHELL LIST AT
LEAST TO GET TO. 50% OF POVERTY
SO I DO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION PLAYING THE SEVEN
POINT ONE PERCENT. BUT I BASED
ON THE CALCULATIONS WERE JUST
SHORT OF FIFTY PERCENT. I'M
HOPING WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THE
50% THIS YEAR SO JUST JUST A
COMMENT THERE- THAT- AND STILL
THAT WOULD BE POVERTY AND THAT'S
STILL NOT VERY MUCH SO. 50% OF
OUR POPULAR SUBS BUT DOWN THE
SIDE I SHOULD MENTION EARLIER.
ON THE CAO WORKSITE. REALLY THAT
. THE- THE PRESENT. I GUESS IN
TERMS OF THE- AND AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE INVESTING
IN LANGUAGE ACCESS IS. AS WELL.
ON ON THE EBT CITING APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THERE- AND- I KNOW
WE INCREASED ACCESS FOR PEOPLE
TO BUY THINGS ONLINE SPECIALLY
CODED BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF
ACCESS TO. FRESH FRUITS
VEGETABLES AND SO FORTH ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT I'VE HEARD COME
UP IN. MY DISTRICT AND OTHER
PLACES IS- WANTING MORE HELP
FROM THE AGENCY BECAUSE
ACTUALLY- SETTING UP FOR EDT IS
ACTUALLY TAKES A LOT OF WORK. AT
WORK IT'S NOT JUST TECHNICAL
THERE'S A LOT OF LIKE FORMS AND
SO FORTH INVOLVED. IT DOES IS-
CAL FRESH- IS A STATEMENT
HELPING PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
PEOPLE AND BE ABLE TO SET UP
THEIR E. B. T. M. AND- M.
DEALING WITH ALL THE SORT OF
PAPERWORK ASSOCIATED WITH THE
LEGALESE AND- ALL THAT. IS THERE
IS THERE OF THIS IS THERE. IS
THERE SYSTEMS PROVIDE TO THE
STATE FOR LIKE FARMERS MARKETS
AND OTHER TYPES OF AND- WHERE
THEY CAN GET ESTO THEY WANNA DO
EDT- BUT ASIDE FROM THE
TECHNOLOGY AND SO FORTH JUST.
SAID EMAIL PROVIDING A- IN TERMS
OF. FILLING FORMS AND
REGISTERING WITH- THE DEPARTMENT
OF CULTURE AND ALL THAT OTHER
STUFF. CANYON DR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'D LIKE TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE PROGRAM LEVEL
YEAH YES. I WAS EXPECTING THE
PROGRAM PEOPLE ANSWER THE
QUESTION. SORRY TRYING TO GET
OFF ME HELLO I'M SO WE DO HAVE
SOME CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT. WITHIN OUR TEAM
THAT IS DOING THE TECHNOLOGY- SO
YES TA IS PROVIDED AS MUCH AS WE
CAN HOWEVER THERE IS THIS FINE
LINE IF YOU WILL- WHERE USDA
DOES NOT NECESSARILY ALLOWANCE-
TED DIRECTLY- HELP CONNECT.
ENGAGE WITH VENDORS IN A IN A
MORE DIRECT. WAY RIGHT SO WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE THE OKAY
THE REQUIREMENTS WITH OUR
ABILITY TO WANT TO EXPAND AND
GROW OKAY SO AND AGAIN IT'S NOT
JUST TECHNOLOGY IT'S JUST TRYING
TO DEAL WITH THE LEGALESE ARE
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO SELL. IT SO
THE PRECIADO WE CAN LOOK INTO
HOW TO ACHIEVE THAT- EIGHT PIECE
YOU SAYING THERE MIGHT BE SOME
RULES FOR DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW
AGRICULTURE BUT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. THAT KIND OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE LEGAL ASSISTANCE OR
WHATEVER- OR AT LEAST FIND
SOMEONE WHO CAN HELP THEM WITH
THAT I THINK WOULD BE. HELPFUL
IS TO AGAIN PROVIDE BETTER
ACCESS TO NUTRITIONAL FOODS THE
OTHER THING I QUESTION I JUST
HAS I KNOW THAT. THE IN TERMS OF
THE- BUDGETING METHODOLOGY
UPDATING VEGGIE METHODOLOGY HERE
REMIND ME I KNOWN TWENTY TWENTY
WE DID. NOW SAY THAT WE'RE GOING
TO UPDATE THE BUDGET METHODOLOGY
WHAT IS THAT. I GUESS WHAT IS
THE CORE ISSUE THAT WE'RE HAVING
TO UPDATE OR AS WELL AS A CORE
PROBLEM THAT- WAS LEADING TO THE
NEED FOR A BUDGET UPDATE. I JUST
I'M TERM MEMBER WHAT THE ISSUE
WAS. PERHAPS THE- SUMMARY OF THE
METHODOLOGY BE HELPFUL SO PRIOR
TO FISCAL YEAR. TWO THOUSAND ONE
TWO THOUSAND TWO. THE BUDGET FOR
COUNTY ADMINISTRATION WAS BASED
ON COUNTY IS ADMINISTRATIVE
BUDGET REQUEST ME THROUGH WHAT
WAS KNOWN AS THE- PROPOSED
COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE BUDGET
PROCESS. AND THEN- BEGINNING
WITH FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
ONE TWO THOUSAND TWO. THAT
PROCESS WAS SUSPENDED. SO THAT
BECAME- THAT THE BASELINE FOR
WHICH FUTURE COSTS ARE
DETERMINED. AND SO THAT BASS
LINE HAS BEEN ADJUSTED EACH
SUCCESSIVE GOVERNORS BUDGET AND
MAY REVISED- PROCESS BURKE
CASELOAD CHANGES. AND SO FUNDING
FOR ANY NEW POLICIES THAT ARE
NOT FULLY CAPTURED IN THE
CASELOAD. TRENDED EXPENDITURE
PROJECTIONS OF CENTER ARE ALL
BUDGETED SEPARATELY IN THE
CURRENT METHODOLOGY. SO- THIS IS
SORT OF THAT THE INITIAL
FRAMEWORK THAT WERE OPERATING
UNDER. OKAY AND SELL OTHER WORDS
AFTER TWENTY YEARS THIS FRIDAY
AT GREATER AND GREATER
DISCONNECT BETWEEN- WHAT'S.
REALLY GOING ON AND HOW WE'RE
FUNDING IT. HE HEARD MY
COLLEAGUES SAID DR IF THEY WANT
TO ADD ANY OTHER. I YES I JUST
REYES MARNA FINANCE A I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THINGS THAT-
SERVING THAT THE- THE REBATES
FOR DISCUSSES THE LOOK AT GIVE
AND- A COMPARISON OF HOW. OUR
RESORT COSTS ARE RELATED TO THE
PROGRAM BUT ALSO IN COMBAT AND
COMPARING THAT TO ALL THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF MADE OVER THE
YEARS STOP STREAMLINED THE
PROGRAM. AND THEN HOW FUNDING
HAS BEEN PROVIDED FOR ALL OF
THIS NEW PROGRAM SAYS APARTMENT
AS- DIRECTOR- AS MENTIONED.
AGAIN THERE IS A NEW PRO AND- IN
CAIRO RECALL. OF THE DEPARTMENT
FOR THIS PROGRAM- THERE'S ALWAYS
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE- THE
BUDGET BY THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION PARTS SO. IT'S IN
A SENSE ALMOST TO LOOK LIKE
THAT. I GUESS IT SEEMS A LOCAL
EVENT LIKE TO SING OBLIGATION
ACCOUNT JUST CLICK ON THAT. WHAT
THE COST WOULD BE BUT IT WAS
JUST DELAYED DUE TO COPE AND
OKAY ALL RIGHT NOW I APPRECIATE
THAT I JUST I THINKIT'S
IMPORTANT RETALIATES I KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES WE- HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS OF A YEAR TO YEAR
THING BUT- ALSO THESE THINGS
THAT SOMETHING HAS GONE ON FOR
DECADES. AND I THINK WE TOUCH ON
SEVERAL THEM RAY EVEN JUST
TODAY. SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT I
HOPEFULLY- UNDERSTANDING COVE IT
HAS THE LATEST BUT I THINK IT'S
JUST IMPORTANT TO REMIND US-
KEEP THAT IN MIND AND THAT WE DO
NEED TO FIX THESE THINGS SO THAT
THEY'RE- YOU KNOW. DATE THEY
WORK WELL AND THAT IT'S FAIR FOR
COUNTIES AND STATE AND SO FORTH
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY OF COURSE
THAT WE MOST EFFICIENTLY ARE
ABLE TO DELIVER THE- YOU KNOW
THE HELP TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
CELL. DEATH OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MOVE ON TO
A- NUMBER EIGHT STAYING WITH
CALFRESH AND NUTRITION PROGRAMS
. SURE THANK YOU AND- I WILL GET
IT STARTED AGAIN JENNIFER
HERNANDEZ SO IN TERMS OF WHERE
WE'RE AT WITH THE SEA FROM
EXPANSION- WE KICK OFF OUR
PROCESS LATE LAST YEAR IN
OCTOBER- WHERE WE HAD. THE
HOLDER LISTENING SESSION THERE
ARE REGULARLY SCHEDULED
QUARTERLY SEEK OUT STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS I'M ALREADY UNDER WAY
WHERE THE FOCUS IS PRIMARILY ON
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES- AND
THE THOUGHT RIGHT NOW WE GET IS
THAT WE WILL BE RAMPING UP THAT
EFFORT THAT ENGAGEMENT TO BUY
MONTHLY. EVERY OTHER MONTH AS WE
GET CLOSER TO ANTICIPATED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE I IN TERMS
OF THE AUTOMATION WE ARE MEETING
ON A MONTHLY BASIS WITH-
DEPARTMENTS ENTITIES THAT ARE
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS WITH CAL
SIDES. AND CEDAR BDA JUST TO
START PLANNING AND- ARRANGING
WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS WILL BE-
SO I DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE A
FURTHER DETAILS ON THE SPECIFICS. BUT WE ARE IN IN THE STATE OF.
THE NEXT ITEM. ISRAEL TO THE
STATUS OF THE SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES-
BEING ARE CURRENTLY THE PROGRAM
CALFRESH NUTRITION BRANCH HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH OUR RESEARCH
AUTOMATION AND DATA DIVISION
HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN UNIT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. TO START
TO- FACILITATING THE PLANNING
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT- THE NEW
APPLICATION SO WE'VE ALREADY HAD
A SERIES OF INTERNAL MEETINGS-
ACROSS THESE ARE TEAMS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS. AND
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WE
WILL BEGIN BRINGING OUR EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS TO OBTAIN
THEIR INPUT ON THE SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION AND WE ARE ON TRACK
TO. RELEASE. IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE THIRD ITEM IS
RELATED TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
NUTRITION BENEFITS SMB AND
TRANSITIONAL NUTRITION BENEFIT
TNB PROGRAMS- IN TERMS OF. HOW
MANY FAMILIES ARE ENROLLED
ETCETERA AND SO- AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO DATA AVAILABLE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE
INVESTMENTS PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET HELP TO
MITIGATE ATTRITION IN THE TNB
PROGRAM HOWEVER WE ANTICIPATE
RECEIVING UPDATED DATA WITHIN
THE FOLLOWING WEEKS- AS A
REMINDER I FOR EVERYONE HERE.
THAT TNB RECERTIFICATION POTS
WENT INTO EFFECT IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY ONE AND SO WITHIN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS WE WILL BE APPY
TO REPORT BACK WITH- UPDATED
DATA. MOVING ON TO NUMBER FOUR-
RELATED TO THE SS I SS P.
EXPANSION. SO THE EXPANSION OF
CALFRESH TO ACCESS SITE AND
ASSESS THE RECIPIENTS WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN JUNE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND SINCE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION- BAND I'D GRADUAL
INCREASES IN TOTAL SS I SS BE
RECIPIENTS WITH THE MOST RECENT
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE MONTH
TOLD LIVING TOTALING. ABOUT
600-234-0040 ONE THOUSAND-
INDIVIDUAL RECIPIENTS RECEIVING
CALFRESH SO THAT HAS BEEN MOVING
ALONG. QUITE WELL. THE LAST
ITEM- IN TERMS OF OUR- JUST THIS
CATEGORY IS RELATED TO
RECOMMENDATIONS- AROUND A STATE
WIDE TELEPHONE BASED SERVICE
MODEL. AND SO- PURSUANT TO
SECTION SEVENTY. OF ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THIRTY FIVE I THE
DEPARTMENT WAS CHARGED WITH-
ENGAGING WITH COUNTIES WOULD
ADVOCATES BEST I SEE ARE YOU AND
THE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM SIZE- TO UNDERGO A
PROCESS WE WOULD FACILITATE AND
IDENTIFY RECOMMENDATIONS- TO
IMPLEMENT- FULLY TELEPHONE BASED
SERVICE MODEL. AND SO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED ARE AGAIN REFLECTIVE
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS PURSUANT TO
THE STATUTE- AND THE INDUSTRY
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT YET
EVALUATED OR TAKING A POSITION
ON THEM- HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
PROCESS THAT WE USED- IN
IDENTIFYING- THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. SO AS MENTIONED
CALFRESH ELIGIBILITY
REPRESENTATIVES WERE ENGAGED THE
COUNTY FOOD ADVOCATES AND OUR
PARTNERS. S. C. A. YOU I'M
COUNTIES WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE US
WITH INFORMATION ON THEIR
EXISTING TELEPHONE BASED
PRACTICES- AND THEIR BUSINESS
OPERATION PRACTICES INCLUDING
CALL CENTER ACTIVITIES- WE ALSO
COLLECTED FEEDBACK FROM THE
SIZE. AND INCORPORATED THOSE
SUGGESTIONS INTO OUR FINAL-
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT. WE ARE
CURRENTLY EVALUATING. A THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT INFORMATION
THERE WAS ALSO A- OUR PARTNER
NOURISHED. WHO WAS A SPONSOR OF
THIS SECTION OF THE BILL POSTED
A LISTENING SESSION TO GATHER
ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK FROM OTHER
EXPERTS WITH EXPERIENCE IN
TELEPHONE BASED SERVICE MODELS.
AND SO- IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
ALSO HIRED- COUNTY- AT WELFORD
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND THEIR
MEMBERS- AND OTHER FOOD ADDICT
ADVOCATES WHO PARTICIPATED AND
IN THE PROCESS- SO THE END
RESULT. AT THE MOMENT IS THAT
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS- I SORT OF
HAVE FOR HIGHER HIGHER TEAMS IF
YOU WELL. CENTERED AROUND HOW
TO. A TELEPHONIC- ACROSS THE
STATE AND THOSE A RECORD AND
TWENTY CALL CENTER. TO EXPLORE
EXPANSIONS- INTERACTIVE VOICE
RESPONSE OR OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
I. VR'S AND TRANSFORM CREW
MENTIONED HOW THE COUNTIES- I
IDENTIFIED AS CALLERS IN
OUTBOUND CALLS FOR INSTANCE- IF
IT SACRAMENTO CALLING YOU THAT
IT WOULDN'T SAY IT'S BLOCKED IT
WOULD BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY PER SE- SO
THAT'S- A GREAT SUMMARY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED- FOR CONSIDERATION-
BY THE STATE. WHAT OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BYE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. MR NEED DOCTOR WITH
FINANCE NO COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ILIO. RYAN ANDERSON
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE JUST
SOME CONTEXT AND- COMMENTS WITH
REGARDS TO THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF C. FAP- IN JUST TO
START BY REMINDING US ALL HOW WE
GOT HERE- THE C. FLAP IS A
PROGRAM THAT CURRENTLY SERVES A
VERY SMALL SLICE OF FOLKS WHO
ARE INELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
CALFRESH SHORT SNAP BENEFITS DUE
SOLELY TO IMMIGRATION THIS IS
ABOUT THIRTY SOME THOUSAND A
LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENTS WHO.
UNDER EARLIER REGIMES FOR THE
FOOD STAMPS PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
BEEN ELIGIBLE BUT- AFTER THE
WELFARE REFORM OF THE LATE
NINETEEN NINETIES FOR NO LONGER
ELIGIBLE OF COURSE THERE ARE
MANY MORE. OF RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
MORE THAT ARE INELIGIBLE FOR
THESE BENEFITS ENTIRELY DUE TO
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS AND THE
LEGISLATURE STRODE- A LOT OF
INTEREST IN EXPANDING BENEFITS
TO THOSE FOLKS IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET THEY- THEY PUT IN SOME
MONEY TO START OVERCOMING. SOME
OF THE MANY AUTOMATION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE CHALLENGES THAT
YOU WOULD NEED TO OVERCOME TO
SERVE THOSE POPULATIONS AND THEY
SAID THAT- BENEFITS WOULD ROLL
OUT USING AN AGE BASED APPROACH
BUT THEY THEY DON'T REALLY
SPECIFY. WHICH AGE RANGES WOULD
BENEFIT FIRST NOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS TO
START WITH- ALL THE IMMIGRANTS
FROM PRIMARILY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT UNAUTHORIZED INDIVIDUALS-
AGES FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE BE INCOME
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM. IN
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY CONSISTENT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT
BUT- WE DO JUST WANT TO REMIND
YOU ALL THE NEAR YOU COULD
CHOOSE TO TARGET OTHER
POPULATIONS CERTAINLY- BASED ON
OUR INITIAL ESTIMATES WHAT WE
THINK THAT. THERE ARE OTHER AGE
POPULATIONS YOUNGER- POPULATIONS
THAT ARE MORE NUMEROUS IN THE
STATE AND IT MAY ALSO BE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE A HIGHER
PROPORTION WHO ARE INCOME
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM SO A
LOT OF CONSIDERATIONS THERE OF
COURSE. IN THE MEANTIME- BUT IT
MINISTRY AND- AUTOMATED MASON
CHALLENGES ARE GOING TO BE THE
SAME FOR ALL THE POPULATION SO.
THAT DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT IN
THE BUDGET HERE ARE BEING
PROPOSED FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
WOULD BE APPLICABLE TO ALL THOSE
RANGES. THAT'S ALL FOR NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN
BACK TO THE PARTY CAN YOU CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT HOW YOU LANDED ON
FIFTY FIVE AN OLDER AND AGAIN
THAT THAT HAS ALSO BEEN A TARGET
POPULATION WE'RE LOOKING AT. BUT
AS WE JUST WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT MOVING YOU KNOW MOVING SOME
FAMILIES WITH KIDS OUT OF
POVERTY- HOW DO YOU PICK FIFTY
FIVE AN OLDER HAS DIPPED
POPULATION YOU'RE GOING TO START
WITH FOR THIS PROGRAM. I CAN NOT
A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT THERE
SO- AS YOU MAY KNOW IN GENERAL
THERE TEND TO BE FEWER SUPPORTS
AN ALTERNATIVE. FOR OLDER ADULTS
RIGHT- AND SO THAT THIS WOULD
PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
THAT PARTICULAR POPULATION- ALSO
WE THINK ABOUT IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING HE NEEDS AND SUPPORTS
FOR OLDER AND INDIVIDUALS. THAT
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING- AND SO. YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S ANOTHER RATIONALE-
BUT ALSO THERE ARE KEY GAPS IN
SOCIAL SAFETY NETS FOR OUR FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND- THIS PART
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION IS-
ALSO CONSISTENT WITH THE MEDICAL
EXPANSION- MEDIC CAL EXPANSION
TO ALL PERSONS REGARDLESS OF
DOCUMENTATION STATUS SO- THERE
THERE SEEM TO BE. A STRONG
ALIGNMENT AND IN THOSE OTHER-
PRIORITIES AS WELL. OKAY THANK
YOU. CAN AND TELL ME AGAIN WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO WHEN YOU ADD
ANTICIPATE GETTING UPDATES ON ON
BOTH THE TMB IN THE S. AND B.
PROGRAMS I KNOW JUST. START
RECENTLY BUT WHEN YOU. EXPECT TO
BE ABLE TO- SEE HOW THAT'S
GOING. WE ARE A FEW WEEKS OUT-
RECEIVING THAT DATA. OKAY THANK
DR PEPPER. THANK YOU SO- SO
BASICALLY JUST JUST TO BE CLEAR
THE PROPOSAL START WITH- AT THAT
FOR THE C. FLAP PROGRAM. FIVE
MILLION THEN FORTY MILLION
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR.
RESIDENTS FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER-
I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP AND ACTUALLY CLOSING
THE FINAL GAP HOPEFULLY. WE'LL
PASS AT THIS YEAR I KNOW- WILL
HAVE SOME DEBATE ABOUT HOW LONG
IT TAKES TO REALLY IMPLEMENT IT
BUT AT LEAST THAT IS A PROPOSAL
ON THERE TO AT LEAST A FEW YEARS
TRYING TO GET TO THAT PLACE. IS
THERE IS THERE A PROPOSAL TO. SO
IN THE OUT YEARS TO GO BEYOND
THE FIFTY FIVE IT WHAT HOW MUCH
WOULD IT COST TO. TO BRING THAT
AGE DOWN ARE ACTUALLY JUST
ELIMINATE THAT GAP ALTOGETHER.
I'LL LET MY COLLEAGUE SENT OFF
ON. YOUR. YEAH YOU GUESSED
RESPONDFINANCE AND AT THE SAME
THAT THE PROPOSAL JUST IS TO
EXPAND BEYOND OUR EXPAND TO
THOSE FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER I
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS- DURING JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF EXTRA CONTEXT AND WHAT- DALY
RESPONDED OR COMMENTED ON THAT-
THERE WASN'T UNDER IS THERE
THERE IS A DISCUSSION AGREEMENT
THE FINAL BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS
THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTS. SIX
SPEND THE PROGRAM BY IDENTIFYING
WHICH POPULATION AND THEN
POTENTIALLY SOME THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT WERE
SOMETHING THAT WERE PROPOSED WE
LOOKED AT THIS YEAR SO AGAIN TO
REITERATE- DIRECTOR HERNANDEZ'S
COMMENTS THAT- ADMINISTRATION
EXIT AT LEAST FOR THE EXPANSION
TO THE FIFTY FIVE PLUS IT MAKES
MORE SENSE NOW. GIVEN THAT YOUR
SUPPORT SIR ALTERNATIVES AS
OLDER ADULTS FOR EXAMPLE- SOME
USE MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR SCHOOL
BASED- MEALS- CAL WORKS PROGRAM
ETCETERA BUT AT THIS TIME NO
OTHER EXPANSION THE ON THIS- THE
STATE'S POPULATION HAS THERE
EVER HAS IT HAS ESTÁ BEEN BEEN
MADE IF WE DECIDED. TO JUST FIND
EVERYBODY HOW MUCH THAT WOULD
COST. WE CAN WITH SOME THAT WE
AT. WE HAD OUR- WHAT WE WOULD I
GUESS A PROBLEM ONE WE WAS
SHARED BY INDUSTRY WITH ALLEGE.
DURING THE FINAL BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS LAST FISCAL YEAR-
BUT WE HAVE ONCE BEEN REQUESTED
AND WE'VE- COMMENTED THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON ONE WE JUST WEREN'T
ABLE TO GET ONE TOGETHER OTHER
TIMES ARE QUESTIONING FOR THIS
HEARING. OKAY SO MANY RECEIVED
REQUEST LAST WEEK I JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO. SO I THINK OF THE
HELPFUL JUST AT LEAST ESTABLISH
I GUESS WE CALL THE OTHER BROWN
GREAT WHAT'S IF WE JUST WENT FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE THE LAW OF SALES
TO. NEGOTIATE GO BACK AND FORTH
AS TO WHAT WE THINK WE CAN
ACTUALLY DO- BUT I'D LIKE TO
KNOW. THAT THEY'LL BE HELPFUL WE
CAN GET THAT NUMBER- THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD IS- ACTUALLY
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE THAT-
WE'RE WILL CONTINUE TO GROW THE
NUMBER OF- THAT TO. INCREASE
ACCESS TO CALFRESH AND PEOPLE OF
S. S. I. S. P. THAT WAS- THAT
TOOK DECADES BEFORE WE- THAT
HAVE- SO NOW THAT WE MADE IT
HAPPEN SEVERAL YEARS AGO. DOES
MENTION TO ACTIONS QUITE PRECISE
WE HAVE SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE. THOUSAND FOUR TO FOURTY
ONE PEOPLE. UNNECESSARY ASSIST
YOU ON CALFRESH. DO WE KNOW IF
YOU HAVE A ROUGH IDEA OF LIKE
WHAT WAS AS A PERCENTAGE OF ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE
I MEAN ARE WE- ARE. AT THE END
IS THERE SOME SPEND NEARLY. ALL
OF THAT IS THAT ALMOST EVERYBODY
IS THAT HALF OF THE PEOPLE DO
HAVE SOME IDEAS TO. SELL AGAIN
FREESHEET IT'S INCREASING
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
PUT INTOIT JUST WANT TO GET A
SENSE OF. OUR YOU KNOW HOW HOW.
HOW HOW MUCH WE'RE PENETRATING
THE MARKET CONSIDER THAT LIKE.
OF PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY COULD
BENEFIT FROM WHO ARE IN ESSENCE
I ASSIST YOU BENEFIT FROM B. AND
CALFRESH. SO I THINK WE'LL HAVE
TO- GO BACK- COME BACK TO YOU
AND PROVIDE YOU WITH THAT DATA I
DON'T HAVE THAT OFFHAND. OKAY IF
YOU COULD THAT BE GOOD SO AGAIN
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE INCREASING
EVERY YEAR SO THAT'S THAT'S
GREAT I JUST WANNA KNOW LIKE HOW
MUCH FARTHER DO WE HAVE TO GO I
KNOW THAT'S IT. I MEAN OVERALL
FOR CALIFORNIA THE MET DID
MENTION WE HAVE A RECORD NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN CALFRESH. BUT
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA IS A STATE
HISTORICALLY HAS ACTUALLY. BEEN
LOWER THAN ANY OTHER STATES IN
TERMS OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO PEOPLE. ALLEN TERMS
OF PEOPLE WHO'D BE ELIGIBLE
CALFRESH VERSUS WHO'S ACTUALLY
AND ROLL. AND- OF COURSE WE'VE
HAD MANY DISCUSSIONS AS TO THE
REASONS WHY. AND SEEMS LIKE A SO
MANY OTHER STATES HAVE DONE MUCH
BETTER. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET A SENSE OF. YOU
KNOW WHAT CAN WE TRY TO DO AGAIN
FOR PEOPLE QUALIFY CUTTER FOR
CALFRESH- WHAT IS IT. THAT KEEPS
THEM FROM BEING AND ROLLED AND-
SO- ALWAYS AN UPDATE AS TO WHERE
WE ARE AND- RELICT AND- I THINK-
IT IS ALWAYS HELPFUL TO NOW. SO
AND I'M CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION BUT
PERHAPS EVEN OVERALL- AND THEN
FINALLY I GUESS AND- IN TERMS OF
THE PHONE. SERVICE AGAIN
FEATURED THE WORK THERE AGAIN
THIS IS A- AN EFFORT TO REDUCE
THE BARRIERS TO PEOPLE. SIGNED
UP FOR COVERAGE WOULD QUALIFY-
AND DOING THE STATE WIDE
NETWORK. I GUESS ONE OF. THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE IS THAT-
NOWADAYS- USED TO BE WHEN PEOPLE
OF THE LAND LINES THEY WOULD
HAVE A- AREA CODE THAT'S TIED TO
GEOGRAPHY. NOW PEOPLE GET A
CELLPHONE AND THEY MIGHT HAVE
MOVED INTO THE STATE TO MOVE
FROM ONE PLACE. TO ANOTHER PART
OF THE STATE IN THEIR AREA CODE
IS SOMEWHERE ELSE. SO YOU ABLE
IN TERMS OF BE SURE THAT YOU
CAN. AND IN A STATEWIDE. SYSTEM
TELEPHONE BASED SERVICE MODEL.
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW YOU
DIRECT PEOPLE TO DIFFERENT
LOCALITIES- ARE YOU. ARE YOU.
HOW HOW'S THAT GOING HOW'S THAT
WORKING WITH DO YOU YOU CAN
OVERCOME THAT TECHNICAL PROBLEM
WHERE. SOMEONE'S YOU KNOW IT CAN
YOU ACTUALLY DEFY THE GEOGRAPHY
IN WHICH THE PERSON'S ACTUALLY.
LIVING JUST BASED ON WHERE.
CALLING FROM TO BE SURE YOU.
SIMPLY ARSENAL. ANYWAY TO THAN I
AM CURIOUS ABOUT THAT- THAT
ISSUE. YES SO WE THERE'S STILL A
LOT THAT WOULD NEED TO HAPPEN IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THAT WE'VE ALSO
HEARD FROM- EXISTING OPERATIONS
ABOUT. AND THIS IS THIS ISSUE
AND IT KIND OF FEDS INTO- SORT
OF HOW THE APPROACH WOULD BE
TAKEN SO I DON'T HAVE A SOLUTION
PER SE- BUT IT IS ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
IN THIS STAKEHOLDER PROCESS JUST
BECAUSE- THAT FOLKS I'M
TRAVELING WITHIN THE STATE- AND
THE REALITY THAT THEY MAY HAVE A
HOME A HOME CELL PHONE NUMBER
THAT ISN'T REFLECTIVE OF WHERE
THEY LIVE SO WE RECOGNIZE THE
CHALLENGE NOT SURE YET IF WE CAN
OVERCOME IT- ON THE TECHNOLOGY
SIDE OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I GUESS
IT'S ON YOUR RADAR SCREEN JUST.
THERE SORRY THANK YOU. AND THEN
IF I MAY DOCTOR PENSA AD IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF YOUR OTHER
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS WE WERE
ABLE TO- PHONE A FRIEND WHILE
HIM WELL. DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HERNANDEZ WAS SPEAKING AND TO
FIND OUT THAT WITH RESPECT TO
THE EFFORTS BY S. S. B.
RECIPIENTS WE ARE ACTUALLY WE
HAVE ACTUALLY MET OR EXCEEDED
THE NUMBER. OF THE ALLEN
INDIVIDUALS WE HAD ESTIMATED
WERE ELIGIBLE- AND THEN I WOULD
ALSO ADD AND WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT- IN THE PAST
WITH OUR OUR REACH OF THE
CALIBRATION PROGRAM THAT AND- IN
TWENTY TEN- WE WERE ESTIMATING
THAT WE HAD REACHED 50% OF
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS. AND
THROUGH VERY TARGETED EFFORTS TO
THEM AND QUITE A BIT OF WORK
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO IMPROVE THAT
UPTAKE AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE
WERE UP 270% SO THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT GAINS IN.
RECENT YEARS WITH RESPECT TO
PROGRAM PARTICIPATION BUT OF
COURSE WE SHARE YOUR INTEREST IN
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE WHO IS
ELIGIBLE. DOES INDEED TAKE UP
THE PROGRAM SO THERE IS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN THAT AND STILL TO
COME. WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SHARING THOSE METRICS. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH. LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE. HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS OVERVIEW. AND
WE KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE ALL THE
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE BUT YOU HAVE A BUNCH.
YES YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU
RICHARD JUST REALLY QUICKLY CAN
JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
INTO YOUR POINTS ADDED JUST
THRILLED TO BE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES AS
A MINISTER AND IT'S MINISTERING
TWO BILLION AT THAT TWELVE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
THIS PAST YEAR JUST THAT
SIGNIFICANT I'M PRECEDENT IT AND
A LOT OF EXPANSION OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS A BRAND NEW
PROGRAM I AND I'M GLAD TO TURN
IT OVER TO ACTING BRANCH CHIEF.
ACCORDING TO GIVE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF THE US. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND THE TEACHER AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JULIE MCCARTY AND
SERVING AS ACTING BRANCH CHIEF.
FOR THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
BRANCH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE SOME UPDATES ON OUR
PROGRAMS. THE ENGINE INCLUDES A
VERY COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW OF
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. MANAGED BY CVS ACCESS.
SO I CAN TURN STRAIGHT TO THE
QUESTIONS- FIRST ASKING TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE- AND AN
OVERVIEW. OF THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PROVIDED A
SIGNIFICANT AND HISTORIC TOTAL.
OF OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR
CDS ASKED TO PROVIDE GRANT FUNDS
ESTABLISH CONTINUE AND EXPAND
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. TO SERVE
CLIENTS OF LOCAL SOCIAL SERVICE-AGENCIES. INVESTMENTS WERE MADE.
TO EXPAND THE COW WORKS HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAMS THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM THE
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM. THE HOME SAFE PROGRAM
THE PROJECT GRAN G. AND WE
HOUSING STRATEGY AS WELL AS TO
ESTABLISH THE. COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM. AB ONE THIRTY
FIVE FOR THEIR X. THIS. OF THESE
. PROGRAMS AND THEIR POTENTIAL
REACH AND THE TICKET WHERE FOR
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING THOSE
NOT IN RECEIPT OF AN ADDICTION
NOTICED. THE SAME LEVEL OF ONE
TIME FUNDS APPROPRIATED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET FOR THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM AND HOME SAFE PROGRAM.
IS ALSO PROPOSED AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET. THE NEXT SECOND
MOVED TO THE SECOND QUESTION I'M
REQUESTING A STATUS ON
ALLOCATIONS AND IMPLEMENTATION.
SO SOON AFTER THE BUDGET WAS
ENACTED ON JULY NINETEENTH THE
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS RANCH AN
OUNCE ALL CURRENT. PROGRAM
GRANTEES WERE AUTHORIZED TO
BEGIN UTILIZING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FUNDING
APPROPRIATIONS AFFECTED BACK TO
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND MEDIA WE FOLLOWING THE
BUDGET ENACTMENT WE BEGAN
DEVELOPING GUIDANCE RELATED TO
STATUTORY CHANGES MADE BY AB ONE
THIRTY FIVE AND THREE ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT THE
DEPARTMENT EVALUATED LESSONS
LEARNED AND PROMISING PRACTICES
WHICH WERE USED TO STRENGTHEN
AND EXPAND. THE PROGRAM GUIDANCE
THEN USED TO SUPPORT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO PREPARE TO SCALE
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS AND EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE
THE TREMENDOUS FUNDING
EXPANSIONS. THAT WERE MADE THIS
BUDGET YEAR. C. IS ANNOUNCED TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AND AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAM FOR A TOTAL OF THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO SUPPORT
AND STABILIZE FAMILIES.
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. THESE FUNDS ARE
EXPECTED TO SERVE NEARLY TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND FAMILIES FOR BOTH
THAT HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM IN
BRINGING FAMILY SOME PROGRAM
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS. IN
ADDITION TO THE FAMILY PROGRAMS
BY- AS A JUDGE JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO CDSS IS
MADE OVER NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO SERVE
SENIORS. AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES CURRENT WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. TWENTY SIX TO
SERVE THIRTY TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SENIORS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES THROUGH THE HOUSING
AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY AND HOME
SAFE PROGRAMS OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS WITH THESE HISTORIC
FUNDING EXPANSIONS. IN ADDITION
TO UPDATED PROGRAM GUIDANCE CDSS
IS UTILIZED A PORTION OF THE
FUNDS APPROPRIATED TO ESTABLISH
A COMPREHENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE INITIATIVE WHICH WE
LAUNCHED IN EARLY JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE TA
INITIATIVE IS DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION AND GROWTH
OF THE CDSS FUNDED HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS STATEWIDE.
AND BASED UPON IS BASED UPON
NEEDS IDENTIFIED BY COUNTY
STRIVES AND A LACERATED
STAKEHOLDER THE TA OFFER AND A
SWEET. AS STATEWIDE. INCLUDE
LEARNING. DISCUSSION WEBINARS
SECURITY PROGR TOOLS AND GUIDE
AND WHY ON. ONE AND I DESIGNED
ALONG SAN TRACK. AIMED AT STAFF
NEEDS. AND NOW I CAN ON TO THE
THIRD QUESTION REALLY TO PAY
BRING. PROJECT RANKING IS A
GROWN PROGRAM THAT WAS TO
DISTRICT TO SAY LIVES BY MATTER
WRONG KEY A HOMELESS. AND TO SEE
NON CON SHELTER DURING COLD IN
PANDEMIC ANTENNA HOSPITAL
STORAGE. PROJECT WHEN HE SERVES
BALL XP OMELESSNESS WHO ARE
NINE HIGH ORYX HE OUT FOR DAYS
STATE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO AT HIGH
RISK A MEDIC CUMPLIR. SHOULD
THEY CATCH THAT I OFTEN FOR
LONGER STATE. PROJECT IS A LOW
LET OF AND. AND DATE OF FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE SERVED
PROJECT HE AND AS OF EARLY FOR.
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND ARE BEING.
THREE SITES ACROSS FORTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. THE KERN
OCCUPANCY DATA CAN BE FOUND ON
OUR DATA WHICH IS A THE- AND AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE PRO AND AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY. SIXTEEN BALLOT
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
ROOMS FOR SIX. THEIR PROJECT
ROOM KEY AFTER STATE SIR. OUR
STATE GOAL AND FIFTH THOUSAND
RAM. AND MOVING ON TO OUTCOMES
TODAY TEN THOUSAND HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN PARTICIPANTS AND EXITED
TO PERMANENT HOUSING. 30% A
PARTICIPANT HAVE AG TODAY.
HOUSING ARE CONGER SHELTERS 8%
AND DOES. ANTI PERCENT TO
INSTITUTIONS OR OTHER
DESTINATIONS. LOCALLY OPERATED
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE
CONTINUE WORKING HARD TO HELP
PARTICIPANTS MEET THEIR HOUSING
GOALS. AND FINALLY THE FOURTH
QUESTION THERE IS- A GREAT OVER
THE- OF THE HOUSING DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM AND THE HEARING
AT GENPACT AND ALONG WITH SOME
OF THE PROGRAM OUTCOMES AND I'LL
ADD THAT IN RESPONSE TO THIS
QUESTION ABOUT INITIAL APPROVAL
RATES FOR INDIVIDUALS ENROLLED
IN THE HOUSING AND DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM. IS CLOSE 260%
COMPARED TO THE STATE AND
NATIONAL AVERAGES WHICH IS A
PART ARE APPROXIMATELY 37% AND
I'LL STOP THERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NINE
MONTHS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD
AT THIS MOMENT- LMAO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GINNY BALLOT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND YOUR AGENDA INDICATES AND AS
WE'VE JUST DISCUSSED THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATIONS FOR THEIR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
ONLY OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT AND RAPID GROWTH IN
THESE PROGRAMS. WE THINK YOUR
FOCUS TODAY ON OVERSIGHT AND
YOUR CONTINUED FOCUS ON
OVERSIGHT REALLY MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE IN THIS AREA. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING THE
OUTCOME THEY'RE PRODUCING AND
WHETHER THEY'RE EXPERIENCING ANY
CHALLENGES OR BARRIERS TO
GETTING THE MONEY OUT THE DOOR
OR GETTING THE PROGRAM UP AND
RUNNING. SO THAT THOSE
CHALLENGES CAN BE ADDRESSED AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. AND CERTAINLY
BEFORE ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING AS
AUTHORIZED. I WE ALSO JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THAT OUR
OFFICE RECENTLY PUBLISHED OUR
INITIAL ANALYSIS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL PACKAGE OF
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL. AND IT IS
REALLY FAN AS YOU INDICATED
EARLIER MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS IN
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BEYOND TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMS BUT-
ONE OF THE TAKE AWAY FROM THAT
ANALYSIS THAT IS MOST RELEVANT.
FOR OUR HEARING TODAY IS REALLY
THE FOCUS AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE COORDINATION OF THE VARIOUS
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS THAT EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. MAKING
SURE THAT THE IN THE STATE'S
ENTIRE PORTFOLIO OF PROGRAMS
WORKS TOGETHER EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND REALLY
UNDERSTANDING HOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. PROGRAMS
FUNDS INTO THAT OVERALL
APPROACH- ON THAT NOTE THERE IS-
AND IN YOUR AGENDA REQUEST- FOR
SOME POSITIONS TO ASSIST WITH
THE HOMELESSNESS. MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM AND WE'VE REVIEWED THAT
REQUEST AND WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
AS WE SEE IT TO BE VERY HELPFUL
IN FACILITY FACILITATING BOTH
OVERSIGHT. AND COORDINATION
THANK YOU. THE YOU VERY MUCH-
AND I KNOW WE'RE PLAYING WE'RE
PAYING CATCH UP WITH A HUGE
HUGE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WE SEE
ON OUR STREETS AND I APPRECIATE
THE WORK THE DEPARTMENT HAS
DONE- AND THE URGENCY WITH WHICH
IT IS DOING IT. CAN YOU CALL
BACK AGAIN TO TURN. TO THE
PROJECT ROOM KEYS ARE YOU
SAYING. THAT WE HELPED ABOUT
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE AND
THERE'S ONLY 18% OF THOSE. WHO
HAVE KIND OF CIRCLE BACK TO THE
STREETS. EVERYBODY ELSE NOW HAS
A PLACE TO STAY OUT OF THAT. I'M
I'M MIGHT DEDICATE THOSE NUMBERS
RIGHT. YES SO I'M THAT PROJECT
PEOPLE THIS STATE PROJECT
GRANTEES FOR ABOUT SHORT STATE
AND LONG TERM STAY. SO OVERALL
OF ALL THAT- THE PERCENTAGE AND
PEOPLE THAT HAVE. I PERCENT
EXITED THE TEMPORARY HOUSING OUR
CONGREGATIONAL CHURCH 18% AND
NOW I'M IN TEN PERCENT.
INSTITUTIONS ARE OTHER
DESTINATIONS. OKAY AND OF THAT
30% THAT WENT TO. A SHELTER OR
TEMPORARY HOUSING DO WE KNOW
THEIR STATUS AT ALL. SO WE DON'T
TRACK THAT STATUS AFTER THEY
REPORT AND EXIT BUT THOSE
STATUSES MAY BE TRACKED THROUGH
THE LOCAL HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM. OKAY OKAY I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO KEEP LOOKING
AT AND I MIGHT ASK THE L. A. O.
BACK AGAIN AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE COLLECTION OF ALL THIS DATA
AND IN YOUR ANALYSIS WERE YOU
ABLE TO TRACK THOSE THOSE
POPULATION TO WHO TEMPORARILY
TOOK OFF THE STREET BUT THEN
WHERE WAS OUR FINAL DESTINATION
THE FINAL STILL BREAK A YEAR
OUT. BUT IS THERE ENOUGH
COORDINATION AMONGST ALL THE
DEPARTMENT WHO WHO HAVE THEIR
HANDS ON THIS AND FROM THE
LOCALS TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
TRACK THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS.
PERMANENTLYYOU MADAM CHAIR
GINNY PUBLIC IN WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND ONE THAT IS
CERTAINLY ON OUR MINDS AS WELL-
IT. NGUYEN VIET ARISTIDE BEGAN
THE SIGNIFICANT AUGMENTATIONS
TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS IN RECENT
YEARS. OUR OFFICE DID RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE COORDINATION
AND WHO IS SORT OF LEADING THE
EFFORT- WE WILL SAY THAT FROM AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PERSPECTIVE WE DO
SEE THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
PROGRESS DEFINITELY ON THE DATA
COLLECTION FRONT WITH THE- H. T.
I. AFTER THAT HOMELESSNESS DATA
INFORMATION SYSTEM AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BEING ABLE TO COLLECT.
MORE INFORMATION THAN WE HAD
BEFORE FROM THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE SO WE ARE CONTINUING. IT'S
NEW THOUGH I GUESS IS WHAT WE
WOULD SAY IF THE WORST SORT OF
STILL WAITING TO GET SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION OUT- AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO THAT CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS THE NEW.
RENAMED REVAMPED ORDINATING BODY
THAT REALLY FOR NEED TO CROSS
THE STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
ENTITIES AGAIN VERY NEW ALSO
ALSO. LOOKING TO SEE HOW IT
WORKS IN PRACTICE BUT SOMETHING.
THAT WE REALLY SEE AS- FROM IT
IN MINISTRY OF INFRASTRUCTURE
CROCKER PARK ASSEMBLY TO BE
PROGRESS. OKAY SO I GUESS- SO
OVERALL I MEAN. THE RICHARD
JOHNSON IF WE HAD TO SAY HOW ARE
ALL THESE PROGRAMS WORKING IF
YOU KNOW AS A PROFESSOR OF YOUR
GRADING. HOW ARE WE DOING
BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU ASK THE
PUBLIC WE'RE STILL NOT DOING
VERY WELL AND I'M YOU'RE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR PUBLIC OPINION
CERTAINLY- BUT AS WE'RE
INVESTING MILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS INTO IT HOW I MEAN.
DO YOU HAVE A MAGIC WAND TO TELL
US HOW HOW THESE ARE DOING AND
WHAT YOU'D LIKE TO SEE
DIFFERENT. WHAT WOULD HELP.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
THAT SHARE IN THAT I DO WANT TO
LIFT UP. WITH LA AND JUST
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF OUR
ABILITY COLLECTIVELY. TO AT TELL
JUST THAT STORY AS TO THE DATA
SYSTEMS AND REALLY BEING ABLE TO
LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUAL THE
PERSON. IN TERMS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO MEET THEIR HOUSING
GOALS AND BEING ABLE TO REPORT
ON THAT HOLISTICALLY. AND NO
MATTER IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAM. ADD
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
ETCETERA SO. THAT THAT. IS A
COMMITMENT I THINK OF ALL OF
OURS REALLY APPRECIATE BOTH THE
SECRETARY OF BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES HOUSING AND EXPECTED
CHERRY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. LEADING THAT EFFORT IN
ENSURING THAT THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE DEPARTMENT START THEIR
PRESENCE- AND WORKING TOWARDS
THOSE COMMON A WIND ADD GOALS TO
BE ABLE TO BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT OUTCOME. I
WOULD SAY THAT. I JUST WANT TO
LIFT UP THE TREMENDOUS WORK
THAT'S HAPPENING LOCALLY HERE. I
WHICH OBVIOUSLY MAKES ALL THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD IN TERMS
OF THE INVESTMENTS I CERTAINLY
WANT TO APPRECIATE OUR TEAM AND-
AND- ONLY AT WORKING. REALLY
DILIGENTLY TO GET OUT AT THE
GUIDANCE AND WORKING WITH
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT
GUIDANCE- IS CONSISTENT WITH
EVERYONE'S INTENTION AND WHAT WE
THINK WORKS FAST. BUT ALSO THEN
TO GET- STAFFING. RAMPED UP KIND
OF ACROSS THE BOARD TO BE OUT.
IN COMMUNITIES. IN SERVING
POPULATIONS AND SUPPORTING THEM
SO. I'VE CERTAINLY HAD THEIR
WORK FORCE HERE- READ MORE IS
NEEDED AS AS IN MANY OTHER
PLACES YOU CAN SEE ABBOTT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ADDITIONAL.
RESOURCES COMMITTED TO ENSURE
THAT THAT WORK FORCE IS
AVAILABLE- AND WE'RE INVESTING
THERE. IN TERMS OF THEIR ABILITY
TO REACH OUT POPULATIONS BUT
IT'S TAKING A MINUTE TO ENSURE
WE HAVE THAT WORKFORCE NOT THE
PLACE THAT. I WILL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS. SENATE OVER ARCH THE ABI
THIS ALL FITS WITH. A THE LARGE
. AMBITION OF THE GOVERNOR AND
IN OUR- APARTMENTS. AT WAR
AFFORDABLE. I IS TO MAKE A BIG.
SO THAT. IF WE ARE WE'RE ON ONE.
IS RIGHT AGAIN YOU HEARD FROM
ACTING BRANCH CHIEF WOULD
QUICKLY WAS THAT WE ARE.
EXPANDING SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS
NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF REACH
ACROSS THE STATE BUT ALSO IN
TERMS OF. ABILITY TO DO MORE ON
THE PREVENTATIVE ENDS- AND
THAT'S HUGE AND TREMENDOUS AND
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE- AGAIN
DOES ACTUAL PORTABLE HOUSING. AT
LOCATIONS TO BE AVAILABLE AND
OPTIONS TO BE AVAILABLE TO FIX
IT YEAH INDIVIDUALS IN NEED SO.
AGAIN I THINK OUR OUR EFFORT IS
MULTI PRONGED WE HAVE A
COMMITMENT ACROSS LEADERSHIP
ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT'S WORK
ON IT TOGETHER. AT TO BEABLE TO
TELL THE STORY AND I THINK ALSO
JUST AGAIN THE MORE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BOTH. ENSURE
INVESTING IN THE POPULATIONS
TODAY THAT NEED EXTRA NEED OUR
SUPPORT. BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
PREVENTATIVE. MEASURES SET TO
GET IN FRONT ADDS. ADD THAT THE
NEEDS GOING FORWARD. OKAY I KNOW
PROGRAM LKE. LIKE THAT IT LIKE
ALL THE COUNTIES ARE INVOLVED
BUT HOW ABOUT SOME OF THESE
OTHER BUT THE PROGRAMS LIKE PROP
PROJECT ROOM KEY- HOME SAFE SOME
OF THE OTHER ONES. ARE ALL THE
COUNTIES EQUALLY- AT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES. I'M NOT A VISITOR
A LOT OF PROGRAMS AND SOMETIMES
YOU HEAR FROM FOLKS ON THE
GROUND THAT. THAT THERE COUNTY
HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO APPLY OR
PURPLE DOWN FUNDING OR- OR
PERHAPS- NO WILLING TO SOME OF
THE- TO RECEIVE HOLES THE STATE
. WERE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED.
GET OUT. TURNOVER AT BRANCH
CHIEF FOR TO GO OVER ONE TIME
KIND OF THE PROGRAMS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS ADMINISTERING HOW
MANY COUNTIES ARE PARTICIPATING
IN EACH SO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
BACK- YOU KNOW THE PROGRAMS
THEMSELVES ARE ALSO IN
DIFFERENT- EVOLUTION IN TERMS OF
HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN AROUND IN
OUR ABILITY TO REFINE AND
STRENGTHEN NEEDS TO GO FORWARD
THAT HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT
BUT- YOU ALSO HEARD. ACTING AT
SHE'S MCCARTY SPEAK TO THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FFORTS
THAT WE ARE KIND OF BRINGING ON
ALL PARTIES TO HELP INSURE THAT
WE HAVE OF BOTH THE TOOLS AND
GUIDES AT THE STATE'S DEVELOPING
AROUND. BLENDING AND BRAIDING
THAT THE DIFFERENT RESOURCES THE
FUNDING THAT STAND OUT BUT ALSO
HAVE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HELPING
AT TRAINING THOSE CASE MANAGERS
AND SUPPORT. THE ON THE GROUND
COMMUNITY EFFORTS ACTION SURE
THAT AGAIN OUR INDIVIDUALS ARE
MEETING THEIR HOUSING GOALS FOR
ALTERNATIVE ROUTES YOU ACTING
CHIEF RECORDED TO SPEAK TO YOU.
KIND OF THE. REACH OF OUR
PROGRAMS BY PROGRAM. THINKING
STRAIGHT JOHNSON YES WE ARE ON
STATE. WE'RE NOT. 100% STATEWIDE
BUT THERE'S A C. INCREASE. IN
PARTICULAR AND THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM THAT THAT PROGRAM IS
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY HAS ACCEPTED
THE NONCOMPETITIVE ALLOCATIONS
THAT WERE MADE AVAILABLE EARLY
AGE EARLIER THIS YEAR- WITH THE
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM WE HAVE FIFTY SEVEN
COUNTIES. AND TO TRIBAL ENTITIES
WHICH ARE SERVING EIGHT TRY-
WITH THE HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM
WE HAVE FIFTY FIVE PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES. AND WITH THE BRING
FAMILY'S HOME PROGRAMS THAT
ALLOCATIONS WERE RELEASED JUST
EARLIER THIS WEEK WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWENTY TWO COUNTIES AND ONE
TRY BUT WE ARE EXPECTING. A
GREATER. PARTICIPATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. OKAY AND
YES THE NEXT STEP OF ACTUALLY
HAVING HOUSING FOR PEOPLE TO
MOVE INTO AFTER WE GET THEM
STABILIZED IS A IS A IS A HUGE
ISSUE AND CERTAINLY WE ALL HEAR
ABOUT I AM TOLD WILL BE
INTERESTED TO HEAR ABOUT THE
NEXT BUT THE NEXT BRIDGE COMING
UP ALSO. DR THANK YOU AND-
APPRECIATE THE WORK BEING DONE
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND TRYING TO PROVIDE
HOUSING. I GUESS- THE FIRST
QUESTION I GUESS I HAVE IS THAT-
AND YOUR YOU HAVE TO BILLION
OTHER TWELFTH THAT'S BE
INVESTED- THERE ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS- I REALIZE EACH ONE HAS
ITS OWN PERHAPS NICHE. BUT AND
SOME OF THEM SEEM TO BE SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR AND AGAIN MAYBE THAT'S
DUE TO IGNORANCE- AND YOU CAN
SPECIFY THE BUT- SO. DO WE KNOW
TO WHAT DEGREE DO PEOPLE AND UP
BEING SIR YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE
MAY BE SERVED BY MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS OTHER. NOT AND AS YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE PROGRAMS- AND
ONLY IN SOME OF THE COUNTY SO
FOR EXAMPLE. THE DOCTOR VIA CAL
WORKS HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM WE
WILL BRING FAMILY'S HOME PROGRAM
ONES IN FIFTY FOUR COUNTIES AS
WELL TWENTY TWO COUNTIES AND ONE
TRIED. DESCRIPTION SEEMS
SOMEWHAT SIMILAR SO. SO ANYWAY
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE
OF HOW DO YOU. HOW TO BE SURE
THAT THERE'S COORDINATION
BETWEEN ALL THESE ARE THEY BEING
CORNY AT THE STATE LEVELS ARE
COORDINATION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IF YOU'RE PURCHASING THE
MULTIPLE COUNTY SO- AND THEN I
GUESS H. TAPPED THE HOUSING THIS
BILL HAS THE PROGRAM MADE
MENTION THAT THEY'RE ALSO
INTEGRATING WITH PROJECT ROOM
KEYS I GUESS THAT'S A POSITIVE
MOVEMENT OR TRY TO LIKE FIGURE
OUT HOW TO THE SCENE INTERFACE.
HE SPEAK TO HOW. HOW RECORDING
BETWEEN SETS EIGHTY SEVEN
PROGRAMS THAT ARE JUST IN THE
PARCEL SERVICES ALONE THERE'S
OTHER PROGRAMS AND OTHER
AGENCIES- SELL SELL. YOUR FARMS
OKAY. OR EVEN WITHIN THE PARTY
SOCIAL. BETWEEN THE SEVEN
PROGRAMS AND EIGHT OTHERS THIS
ENTERED THIS OTHER THERE'S ALSO
THERE'S INTERAGENCY COUNCIL. BUT
BASICALLY HOW TO BE SURE WE'RE
OPTIMIZING OUR MAXIMIZING. WHO
ARE DELIVERING YOU KNOW THE
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES. YES SO-
I WOULD SAY COORDINATION AT ALL
LEVELS IS REALLY IMPORTANT SO AS
THE STATE WE PRIDE WE- AIM TO
PROVIDE COORDINATED GUIDANCE
ACROSS ALL OF THE PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THAT. A LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE OPERATIONAL ISING IN
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM HAVE
LOW BARRIERS TO PROVIDE DAY
CRITICAL HOUSING SUPPORTS TWO
DAY INDIVIDUALS AND THEY'RE
SERVING. SO YOU'RE RIGHT THERE
IS A LOT OF SIMILARITY ACROSS
ALL OF THE PROGRAMS THEY'RE ALL
VERY FLEXIBLE- IN INTENDED TO BE
HOUSING FIRST LOW BARRIER AND
PROVIDE- HOUSING SUPPORTS TO
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
FOR AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. AND
THEN THE PART WHERE IT DIFFERS A
LITTLE BIT IS JUST BASED ON THAT
THE SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAM AT
THE INDIVIDUAL MAYBE SERVICE
THROUGH A LOCALLY SO. FOR
EXAMPLE AND THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM FOR A FAMILY THAT'S
RECEIVING HOW WORKS IF THERE'S A
HOUSING NEEDS. THAT THAT COW
WORKS CASE WORKER IS ABLE TO
IMMEDIATELY PROVIDE HOUSING
RESOURCE TO THAT PERCENTAGE
THERE'S NOT A REQUIREMENT THAT
THE- YOU KNOW GO THROUGH
DIFFERENT DOORS OR- FOLLOW
DIFFERENT PASSED IN ORDER TAKE.
AND ACCESS TO HOUSING SUPPORTS
SO- COORDINATION AT THE STATE
LEVEL WITH OUR GUIDANCE
COORDINATION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND JUST MAKING SURE THAT
NINETEEN EIGHTIES ARE LOOKING AT
HOW THEY'RE ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. ACROSS THE BOARD
IN A CLASSIC COMMUNITY AND
WE'VE- AND PARTICIPATED IN. THAT
STRATEGIC FUNDING GUIDE THAT WAS
SPREAD OUT THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS WITH HOW
COMMUNITIES CAN LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE IN THEIR COMMUNITY TO
SERVE THE DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
IN NEED. BUT ESSENTIALLY WE AIM
FOR THERE TO BE NO WRONG DOOR
THAT ANY FAMILY OR INDIVIDUAL
THAT SERVES THERE IS SOCIAL-
SERVICE PROGRAM HAS. ACCESS TO
HOUSING SUPPORT. I SO I GUESS
THE THAT IS I'M GONNA BRING UP
THIS IS THAT I. P. AND RONGO
APPROACH IS THAT. IT SAYS
DIFFERENT PROGRAM- AND THERE BE
SIMILARITIES- WHETHER- PEOPLE
ARE HAVING THIS SPEND TIME
FIGURING OUT OKAY DO CLASS OR
THIS ONE OR THAT ONE AND OR SO
FORTH SO TO THINK ABOUT IS THERE
A WAY TO SIMPLIFY IT SO DON'T
HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
WHICH NOW WE'RE GOING OKAY WHEN
A CHECK FOR THIS PROGRAM WILL
TAKE THAT PROGRAM CHECK THAT
PROGRAM. AND YES THERE'S NO
WRONG DOOR BUT BUT THERE THERE'S
LIKE OKAY WELL CAN WE SIMPLIFY
THE OVERHEAD AND ADMINISTRATION
OF MULTIPLE PROGRAMS AND
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
I GUESS ARE ARE DECREASE THE
BARRIERS YOU KNOW HOW TO
ADMINISTER AND FORTH. AND-
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE
MULTIPLE ROMANCE BECAUSE
MULTIPLE FUNDING STREAMS AND IF
IT'S A FEDERAL FUNDING STREAM
THEM IF CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS ONE
FUNNY SCENE VERSUS THE OTHER BUT
I NOT SURE THAT'S NECESSARILY.
TRUE IN THIS CASE ALTHOUGH I
COULD BE WRONG. HEY JULIE YEAH.
ONE POINT I WAS JUST GOING TO
MAKE THAT- WE SAID ASSISTANCE
NOW WE THIS CIGNA INCREASE IN
THE FUNDING WE ARE LOOKING- IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE PROJECTS
FOR THE PRO TO. AND TO WIN THAT
STREAMLINED AND THE MOST
EFFECTIVE USE OF THE FUNDS SO
THERE'S NOT ISN'T THIS PROGRAM
OR THAT PROGRAM OKAY I'M ANSWER
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THESE ARE
POPULATION SPECIFIC SO YOU KNOW
HOME SAFE IS SUPPORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S BEEN ENGAGED
IN THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
SYSTEM CAL WORKS HM HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM IS BECAU WORKS
RECENTLY THE FAMILY THEY ARE
DIFFERENT POPULATION FOCUSED.
PROGRAMS AT THIS POINT BUT TO
YOUR POINT THERE'S ALWAYS
OPPORTUNITIES NO MATTER IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS
OTHERS AGAIN THAT WERE PARTNERED
WITH TO ADD BRIDGE SHE'S MCCARTY
MENTIONED TO BE FINANCING GUY
WE'RE TRYING TO LAY OUT- THAT
ROAD MAP IN THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
LOCALLY SO THAT THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE AVAILABILITY AFTER
THROUGH THAT TARGETED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THIS I RESOURCE
TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT.
INDIVIDUALS ARE CONNECTED WITH
THE APPROPRIATE PROGRAM BATCH I
ALWAYS A WORTHWHILE GOAL IN IN
SOMETHING THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE OKAY YES SIMPLIFICATION
IS THAT AND TRYING TO FIND PUT
THINGS TOGETHER AFTER ALL IF YOU
END UP FIND YOURSELF HAVING TO
TRAIN PEOPLE EXTENSIVELY TO
NAVIGATE ALL THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS WELL THAT MAY BE OF
SOME BENEFIT MAYBE WE'VE MADE
THE- ROAD MAP TO COMPLICATED FOR
PEOPLE IF WE IF PEOPLE NEED TO
HAVE BE TRAINED UP TO FIGURE OUT
WHICH PROGRAM. PEOPLE FIT INTO
HM GPS HAS ROAD MAP OUT EXACTLY-
THE OTHER THE OTHER THING IS I
DO APPRECIATE SO WE HAVE A YOU
KNOW I GUESS 300-520-0042
POSITIONS TO HELP PEOPLE WITH
THE HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS GIVEN. THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND SO FORTH IS THAT
ENOUGH THAT I MEAN- IS TO BE T.
PEOPLE'S GOING TO IT SO WE
TALKED A BIT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF DATA AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW WHAT OUR
RESULTS ARE- IT'S MY CHECKED.
ESTIMATE THAT THE SMALLER I M.
IN OUR USUAL BUT THINGS. AND IF
THAT'S ENOUGH THAT ENOUGH- BUT I
DID WANT TO RAISE THAT GIVEN HOW
MUCH. OF THE RESOURCES ARE PUT
INTO A- THE DRESSING THE ISSUE.
EVERY THAT QUESTION VERY MUCH
SENATOR- I DO THE T. HAS- BIG
STAFFING READ THAT WE HAVE A
WHOLE LIST LOOKING AT DATA THE
THIS IS. ABOUT THIS THAT THERE
OF WHAT WE CHARACTER STILL THE
IN TERMS OF THE EXPERT OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND ARE AT OUR
INTERACTION WITH THE STATE
ASSISTANT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION SO I'M JUST GONNA
SAY IS DON'T TELL ME YOU DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE. DON'T TELL
ME THAT A COUPLE YEARS LATER YOU
WON'T TELL CENTER EGGMAN THEY
DON'T HAVE THE PEOPLE TOGETHER
TODAY THAT SHE NEEDED BECAUSE
YOU ONLY ASK FOR TWO PEOPLE
TODAY SO JUST JUST RAISING THAT-
OKAY. NO I APPRECIATE THE THAT
I'M SURE THERE'S MORE THAT WE
CAN GET INTO- BUT- YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD WORK BEING
DONE- WE UP BY LKE ONE JUST
LAST THING A PROJECT ROOM KEY- I
UNDERSTAND AND- OUR ANALYSIS
THAT WE EXPECT THAT- FEMA'S
GOING TO FUNDED THROUGH AT LEAST
APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SECOND
AS OUR ANTICIPATION ALTHOUGH I
KNOW YOU CAN'T PREDICT THE
FUTURE. THAT'S GOING TO GO
BEYOND THAT OR- BESKOW. WE HAVE
CERTAINLY THIS IS OBVIOUSLY BEEN
THAT A TREMENDOUS PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NEEDS RESOURCES THAT I'VE MADE
AT OUR OFFENSE THAT LEVERAGES
DIDN'T EVEN FURTHER AND SO THERE
IS A COMMITMENT THAT THEY HAVE
TO ALWAYS GIVE US AT LEAST A
THIRTY DAY NOTICE OF TURNING THE
PROGRAM OFF WE WE'RE THRILLED
THAT WE WERE GETTING KIND OF THE
MONTH TO MONTH APPROVALS THAT
SHIFTED AT SAID MANY MONTHS
ADMIN THIS LAST APPROVAL SO I
CERTAINLY ENGAGED AND ADDS
TALKING WITH THEM FREQUENTLY
AROUND- THE POTENTIAL FOR EXTRA
. AND SENDING I REALLY. LAST
SURE THAT OUR BEST. YOUR
SUPPORTING THE READ- STRATEGY
AND SEARCH THAT'S OUR AS WE ARE
SEEING SOME OUR PROGRAM- BAG IS
AT AT AND USE THE KIND TO PASS
THAT THEY'VE HAD A TO DATE OF
COURSE WE ALSO HAVE THE
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS OF THE HOME
KEY TRANSITION STORY ACTUALLY
BEEN ABLE. TO ACQUIRE SOME OF
THESE PROPERTIES BUT CERTAINLY
WE ARE IN TOUCH WITH THE MAC
FREQUENTLY AND WILL GIVE YOU
THAT UPDATE AND HOPEFULLY GOOD
NEWS THE CENTERS WE RECEIVE IT
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL CERTAINLY I
GUESS WE JUST HAVE TO AND
RECOGNIZING OF THOROUGHLY
PROVIDING US IN DEPRECIATED
PRICE AT LEAST SEVERAL MONTHS
THAT WE'RE ALWAYS GONNA HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT- POSITION. TO
POSITION OURSELVES FOR. A YOU
KNOW PLAN B. F. SOME REASON THEY
SOMEBODY TELL US WHAT THE
MONEY'S GONNA START DRYING OUT-
THAT- GIVEN THAT THE SIZE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT- WE'RE NOT CAUGHT
FLAT FOOTED SO- AGAIN HOPEFULLY
THE GOVERNMENT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PROGRAM THE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO FUND IT AND-
I CERTAINLY HOPE MY
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTS A
HEARING YOU SAY THAT RIGHT NOW-
BUT ALSO JUST. YOU KNOW BE SURE
WE ALSO ARE READY THAT WE DON'T
LEAVE PEOPLE STRANDED WHICH I
KNOW YOU WANT TO SELL. THANK YOU
. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TEN. COMMUNITY CARE.
EXPANSION C. C. E. PROGRAM. OKAY
SO AGAIN ENGINE THAT PROVIDES AN
OVERVIEW AND I'M THE COMMUNITY
CARE EXPANSION PROGRAM. ON M. P.
H. TWENTY SIX AND- IT'S EXCITING
TO TALK ABOUT AND THAT BUILDING
HAVE HOUSING OPTIONS SO AS
INDICATED THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS MADE
AVAILABLE VIA THEIR REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS ON JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR THIS
YOU SEE CAPITAL EXPANSION
PROJECT. ON AN INFORMATIONAL
WEBINAR WALKING THROUGH THE
REQUEST FOR APPLICATIONS WAS
PRESENTED ON FEBRUARY TENTH AND
INCLUDED OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
WEBINAR PARTICIPANTS FOLLOWING
THE WEAPON ARE WE'VE HAD A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN PRE
APPLICATION CONSULTATION
REQUESTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
THAT NUMBER'S BEEN GROWING BY
THE DAY SO- IT'S PROBABLY EVEN
HIGHER THAN THAT THEY COUNT THAT
I GOT LAST NIGHT. THESE
PROSPECTIVE APPLICANTS ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
IMPLEMENTATION SPECIALIST
SPECIALISTS TO DEVELOP THEIR-
COMMUNITY CARE EXTENSION
APPLICATION AND WE'RE MONITORING
THE APPLICATION CONSULTATIONS
VERY CLOSELY TO UNDERSTAND WHICH
TYPES OF PROJECTS WILL BE
SUBMITTED ANY ASSESSMENT OF NEED
FOR THE RESIDENTIAL CARE
SETTINGS COMMITTEE SUBMITTED BY
EACH OF THE APPLICATIONS. ON THE
NUMBER OF NEW BADGER UNITS THAT
WILL BE ESTABLISHED THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION WILL
ULTIMATELY DEPEND ON THE TYPE OF
FACILITIES AND PROJECTS THAT ARE
APPROVED AND FUNDED WITH EARLY
ESTIMATES WE PROJECTED AT
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND BEDS
CREATED AND ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
ADS TO BE PRESERVED AGAIN THOSE
ARE EARLY ESTIMATES- AND MOVING
ON TO THAT SECOND QUESTION IN
RELATION TO THE ESTIMATED. NEED
FOR THE PRESERVATION. I'M
SPECIFIC. CAPITAL ON SUBSIDY
RAZOR. SO THEY CAN CARE. WAS
ESTABLISHED A RECOGNITION THAT
THE STATE NEEDS A BROADER
PORTFOLIO OF HOUSING TO END
HOMELESSNESS WHICH CAN BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH CONTINUED
ACQUISITIONS AND CREATION OF NEW
UNITS. SO THIS IS C. C. E.
INCLUDES A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT OF FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY TO PROVIDE.
OPERATING SUBSIDY PAYMENTS IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE BADS FOR SSI
RECIPIENTS AND LICENSED ADULT
AND SENIOR CARE FACILITIES. AND
THRILLED COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING SURVEY DATA WE
ESTIMATE THAT THERE ARE ABOUT
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY RECEIVING
SSI AN EXISTING LICENSE ADULT
AND SENIOR CARE FACILITIES. SO
IF WE USE AN ESTIMATE OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER AND NEED FOR EACH
CURRENT SSI RECIPIENTS IN
LICENSE FACILITIES. THAT WOULD
PROVIDE OPERATING SUBSIDY
PAYMENTS FOR JUST ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS IF WE LOOKED AT. THE
FUNDING DISTRIBUTED STATEWIDE.
AND IN PARTNERSHIP COUNTY STRIVE
AND THIS R- ARE DEPARTMENT WILL
CAN TO. THE NEEDS OF THE PROGRAM
A IMPLEMENTS THEIR THIS. AND
FINALLY THE LAST QUESTION-
ASKING HOW THE DEPARTMENT
ENVISIONS THE PRESERVATION FUNDS
WILL BE ALLOCATED WE ARE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY BUT WE
ARE ANTICIPATING TO USE. THAT
ESTIMATES OF THAT CURRENT- SSI
RECIPIENTS IN LICENSED AT.
LICENSE FACILITIES AS I
MENTIONED THERE'S FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SO WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT USING THAT
ESTIMATE AND THE PROPORTION OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE BAGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND I WILL
STOP THEIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
DIFFERENT FINANCING THING TO ADD
. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING AT THIS MOMENT LMAO.
ANGELA SHORT WITH THE L. A. O.
JUST A SOMEWHAT ECHO MY L. A. O.
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS FROM THE
PREVIOUS AGENDA ITEM- WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT CCP DOES
REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT-
AUGMENTATION FOR A NEW PROGRAM-
FOR DEEP A CDS US FOR HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS- AND AS THE
PROGRAM MOVES INTO DE UM APPLE
APPLICATION AND ALLOCATION FACES
WE- THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROACH ON OVERSIGHT MAKES
SENSE- AND ALSO WOULD STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF ONCE AGAIN
UNDERSTANDING THAT COORDINATION
PIECE. AND HOW THIS PROGRAM-
FITS INTO THE STATE'S OVERALL
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK- I
MEAN IT WE OUGHT WE ALL SEE THAT
THE PERFECT SENSE- THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL MAKES AT THAT. WE HAVE
ALL THE STUFF UP FRONT WE HAVE A
HUGE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUT WE NEED THAT BRIDGE IN
PLACE. TO KEEP PEOPLE IN
SOMEPLACE. AS WE CONTINUE TO
BUILD OUT. CAN I ASK HOW HOW DID
YOU COME UP WITH THAT AMOUNT. I
MEAN IS IT BASED ON THE-
ANALYSIS OF THE NEED OF THE
AMOUNT OF BEDS. OR DID YOU JUST
DOUBLE WHAT WHAT THE FEDS ARE
PAYING OR HOW DO WE COME UP WITH
A EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIVE.
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THREE
YEARS. I'M CENTER EGGMAN
DESIGNS- NINE GOT IT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAID THE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION
WAS INCLUDED IN THAT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT- BOTH ON
DISCUSSIONS ON WHAT WAS
AVAILABLE OF A GENERAL FUND AND
THEN THAT. ARE H. C. B. S. AND
IN THE STATE THIS GOAL RECOVERY.
OKAY AND WE AND WE FEEL LIKE
THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO FOUR THOUSAND BEDS. OR
PROJECTING. EARLY ESTIMATES AT
THIS TIME FOR THE EXPANSION
COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM
ESTIMATE FOUR THOUSAND ADS. AND
THEN THREE THOUSAND BEDS FO
THAT PRESERVATION THE PROGRAM
COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM. OKAY
AND SO THE DATA AND AGAIN THAT
JUST WENT OUT SO YOU'RE THE
APPLICATIONS ARE ARE COMING IN.
AND DO YOU FEEL LIKE WE HAVE
ENOUGH STAFF TO BE ABLE TO TURN
THOSE AROUND TO BE ABLE TO START
GETTING THAT MONEY OUT THE DOOR
IN TIME FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
TO BE OUT. SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH A THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
FISCAL INTERMEDIARY- TO HELP US
ENSURE THAT. THE PROGRAM IS
STOOD UP AND IMPLEMENTED AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE UNDERSTANDING THE
URGENT NEED. FOR IT BUT THAT'S
TO BE CREATED AND PRESERVED SO
WE ARE AND- WE DESIGNED A
PROGRAM THAT CONSISTENT WITH THE
SPENDING TIME LINES THAT. HAVE
BEEN THAT ARE IN PLACE WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDS BEING USED. WE'RE
ALSO ALSO SEE WE'RE PROVIDING A
SIGNIFICANT LEVEL OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP APPLICANTS
UNDERSTAND THAT DESIGN AND
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION
PROCESS. OF THESE FACILITIES AND
SETTINGS TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO. AGGRESSIVE TIMELINES.
OKAY AND WHEN YOU SEE THE- THE
CERTAIN AMOUNT FOR THE OPERATING
AND THAT THAT IS JUST. HE DID SO
THAT'S NOT FOR THE PRESERVATION
AS FOR THE OPERATION OF THE
FACILITIES SO AS I JUST MCNALL
ADJOURNMENT THAT OUR CURRENT
LEVEL OF REIMBURSEMENT FOR A
BED. IS INADEQUATE FOR THE LEVEL
OF NEED. OF EACH INDIVIDUAL IN
THE BED HAS GONE UP. SO THE
QUESTION IN THE AGENDA RELATING
TO THE FIFTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THE OPERATING SUBSIDY PAYMENTS
IS IN RELATION TO- PROVIDING HE
MAN. FOR EXISTING- FACILITIES
SERVING AND SSI RECIPIENTS SO
WHO KNOWS AND TYPES OF PAYMENTS
WOULD BE USED TO COVER
OPERATIONAL DEFICIT SO IT COULD
BE- THINGS TO DO WITH JUST
OPERATING A FACILITY NOT RELATED
TO THE SERVICES. THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO INDIVIDUALS IN THE
FACILITIES SO THAT UTILITY BILLS
FOR- ADMINISTRATION AND THOSE
TYPES AND- ACOSTA COVERAGE TO
THE OPERATING PAYMENT. THE
INSURANCE ADD AS CERTAINLY WE
BEEN FOCUSED ON ENSURING THAT WE
ARE AT RETAINING THE ADULT
SENIOR CARE SETTINGS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHILE WE SEE WHEN WE
SEE PROGRAMS CLOSE RIGHT THEY
INDICATE DIRECT COMMUNICATOR
LICENSING DIVISION THAT THEY'RE-
PLANNING TO GO ON TO BE AN
ACTIVE STATUS ARE CLOSE WE'VE
BEEN SERVING THOSE PROGRAMS- AND
SO AT THE COST OF OPERATING WAS
ONE AND THEN CERTAINLY THAT KIND
OF LARGEST RESPONSE. ON THOSE
SURVEYS THAT WE SAW ESPECIALLY
AS IT RELATES AGAIN TO SETTINGS
THAT WERE SUPPORTING SSI
RECIPIENTS SO THAT'S KIND OF HOW
WE'RE GETTING TO- THIS OPERATING
SUBSIDIARIES RESERVE COMPONENT
AT THIS PROGRAM AND WILL
CERTAINLY BE STUDYING. IT'S
IMPACTS ON THE ABILITY OF
PROGRAMS TO USE THATREMAIN OPEN
THEY NEED THEIR COSTS RIGHT
BECAUSE ONCE THAT SUBSIDY GOES
AWAY WE'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE
THAT. THAT GAP THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO FILL SOME KIND OF WAY
FOR. AN END CAN YOU WIND WHEN
YOU'RE SERVING THE- THE
FACILITIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
THINKING ABOUT CLOSING. IS IT
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF REAL
ESTATE OR IS IT BECAUSE THE COST
OF PROVIDING CARE IN THE AND THE
COMPLICATIONS. OF FUNDING. YEAH
WE IT'S A BIT HABIT WORK
REFINING OUR SURVEY TO OVER TIME
IT'S BEEN A BIT OF THAT A MORE
OPEN ENDED. QUESTIONS SO IT'S
BEEN MOSTLY AND MORE GENERICALLY
RESPONDED TO BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK AT. HOW WE'RE
ASKING THAT QUESTION IN OUR
ABILITY TO GET A LITTLE MORE
SPECIFIC TO YOUR QUESTION- IS
THAT WE DO EXACTLY WHAT HAS BEEN
WAS THE DRIVER AROUND ANY COSTS
AT A CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE
FACING SO GLAD TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S- A PART OF OUR OUR
QUESTIONS GOING FORWARD. THAT
WOULD BE GREAT BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE HEAR REPEATEDLY
THAT THESE THAT THE STEP DOWNS
ARE OR CLOSING THAT'S HARD TO
FIND- AND IF WE CAN'T SOLVE THAT
THEN. THEN THAT'S A HUGE CHUNK
MISSED OUT OF OUR OUR SYSTEM.
AND WILL IMPACT EVERYTHING ELSE
SO I THINK IF WE COULD FIND OUT
EXACTLY SOME OF THE DIRECT
REASONS- AND SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT. FOR THOSE HOLES OR- DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT GAPS. I THINK TO
KEEP THOSE THOSE. NOT ONLY TO
GROW THE NUMBER WHO ARE OFFERING
THE SERVICES BUT TO MAINTAIN THE
ONES. THAT WE HAVE WHICH- IS
WOULD BE REALLY VALUABLE DATA
AND I'D APPRECIATE IT. IF WE
COULD FOCUS ON THAT. DOCUMENT I
THANK YOU AND I JUST ALSO WANT
TO REITERATE WHAT- CARE EGGMAN
MENTIONED I THINK FOR BOTH OF
THESE. NOW FOR THIS PROGRAM BOTH
CAPITAL EXPANSION PROJECTS WHERE
YOU HAVE A CAPITALIZE OPERATES
OF THE RESERVE. FOR FIVE YEARS
AND THEN THE FACT ALLOCATED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION FOR. YEN
OPERATING. A SPEAKS TO WE NEED
TO REVISIT THAT OUR
REIMBURSEMENT PAYMENTS BECAUSE-
I MEAN I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
TELL SOMEONE WELL. YOU KNOW
WHAT. YOU DON'T WORRY ABOUT
UTILITIES. BECAUSE ON OUR
SUBSIDIZING WELL DIFFERENTIALLY
AT LEAST ONCE OF THE STOPS WE'RE
GOING TO ASK. YOU KNOW THE
THOUGHT THE PD TELECEL- OUR
WATER. SO WE REALLY DO NEED I
THINK THIS INDICATES THAT WE
REALLY DO NEED TO LOOK AT THESE
THINGS SO IT'S GREAT WE'RE
PROVIDING. PEOPLE SOME TEMPORARY
RELIEF. BUT YOU KNOW YOU DON'T
BUILD A NEW BUILDING YOU
PROVIDING A SUBSIDY FOR FIVE
YEARS FOR. OPERATING SUBSIDY AND
THEN AFTER FIVE YEARS IS OVER
ESSENTIALLY THEY CAN'T STAY
AFLOAT RIGHT. AND STAY NEEDED
THAT SUBSIDY THAN- THAN- MAYBE
THEY ALSO NEED. BETTER
REIMBURSEMENT. I DO HAVE- AGAIN
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THIS THIS
INVESTMENT- OF. OF EIGHT HUNDRED
FIVE MILLION- HE- THE CONSULT
RESEARCH. WHAT'S THE WHAT ARE
HOW MUCH OF HOW MUCH THAT THE
HUNDRED FIVE NO. ARE THEY
GETTING PAID. FOR THAT THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR YES- WE'RE
WORKING ON OUR CONTRACT WITH
THEM CURRENTLY BUT WE ANTICIPATE
IT TO BE LESS THAN 5% OF THE
BUDGET EVEN PROBABLY LESS THAN
THAT. OKAY ALL RIGHT SO YOU
NICELY STILL WORKING ON THAT
HOPEFULLY IT'S LESS THAN 5% OKAY
WELL WE'LL JUST. I MEAN IT- AND
IT DOES STILL COST MONEY FOR
SOME TO DO THEIR JOB SO I'M NOT
SAYING IT'S- JUST WANT TO KNOW
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND THEN
THE OTHER THE OTHER QUESTION I
WOULD HAVE IS AGAIN YOU KNOW
ANYTHING APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT HERE- AND- TALKING
ABOUT OVERLAPPING PROGRAM SO
FORTH- SO. YOU KNOW PREVIOUSLY
WE HAVE A HOUSING DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM. ASSIST PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS I GUESS THIS IS THE
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS ALSO
LIKELY ELIGIBLE FOR DISABILITY
BENEFITS. SO SEEMS LIKE SOME
OVERLAP SO WHAT'S GOING TO BE
THE INTEGRATION BETWEEN C. C. E.
AND THE EIGHT STEP PROGRAM WHICH
SEEMS TO BE SERVING AT LEAST
SOMEWHAT SIMILAR POPULATIONS
MAYBE I'M MISSING IT. MAYBE THEY
ARE DIFFERENT- BUT I THINK IT
WOULD BE NOTE THAT- WELL LISA
PRESERVATION WE'RE TALKING TO
PEOPLE ON SS I SS PIECE THAT'S
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. WE
ALSO NOTE THAT EACH STEP PROGRAM
OR BACKGROUND AT LEAST SAID
THAT- THERE WERE FOUR THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED DISABILITY
APPLICATION OF THIS ALL BACK
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO
HELP TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE SO IT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED. SO CAN WE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THESE TWO
WHICH SEEMS TO DISTRICT
SOMEWHERE POPULATIONS WILL BE
COORDINATED INTEGRATED ARE-
CONNECTED. OR IS THIS ARE WE
GONNA FOLD EACH TAP INTO THIS
ARE SO I JUST YEAH AGAIN BACK TO
THE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS ISSUE. SO
THEY CAN BE CARED. PROGRAM
INTENDED TO BRING ON MORE
RESIDENTIAL CARE SETTINGS OKAY
MORE INDIVIDUALS SERVICE THROUGH
FOR EXAMPLE THE AGE THAT PROGRAM
OR FOR EXAMPLE THROUGH THE
PROJECT CAN KEEP PROGRAMS. THOSE
ARE IDENTIFIED THAT NEED A
HIGHER LEVEL OR A LONGER TERM
CARE. PLACEMENTS SETTING- WITH
THE LEAST. AMOUNT OF
RESTRICTIONS AND TO AVOID A
FACILITY. OKAY SO-
INSTITUTIONALIZATION EXCUSE WILL
SELL YES WE DEFINITELY SEE A
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE HOUSING
AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM.
AND THE COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
LONGER TERM CARE OPTIONS. FOR
INDIVIDUALS. HM FOR EXAMPLE THAT
REQUIRE THAT LEVEL OF CARE OKAY
SO CCP PROVIDES THE NEW.
PLACEMENTS ARE LOCATIONS FOR
PEOPLE WHO IN THAT SAME MIGHT
NEED HOUSING AND H. WHO WERE
TRYING TO HELP AN H. DAPPER ROOM
KEY. THAT TELLING ME. OKAY AND
REALLY ABOUT THE LONG TERM CARE
CONTINUUM SENATORS RIGHT SO.
IT'S REALLY BASED ON THE NEEDS
OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE GONNA NEED THAT THE
LEVEL OF CARE THEY'RE GONNA NEED
IN HAVING THOSE OPTIONS ALONG
THAT CONTINUUM SO THAT'S REALLY.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
WITH WITH THIS PROGRAM OKAY. AND
I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION A
TYPICALLY WHAT THE PRESERVATION. PROJECTS- SO YOU KNOW SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE INVESTING TO HUNDRED
ONE FIFTY FIVE WILL BE FOR
OPERATOR PIECE RIGHT SO THAT'S A
25% THE OVERHEAD WHATEVER SO
ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION- TO
PRESERVE LICENSE FACILITIES NOW
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
FACILITIES AND WE'RE PROVIDING.
GRANTS TO- THE COUNTIES AND
TRIBES PROVIDES FACILITIES.
RECOGNIZING THAT AT LEAST IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A HOUSING
SHORTAGE AND- THAT'S DRIVING UP
THE COST OF HOUSING BUT ALSO.
DRIVING UP THE VALUE OF SOME OF
THESE PROPERTIES AS WELL. HOW DO
YOU HOW WELL THE THINK THAT THIS
PROGRAM WILL BE SUBSCRIBER TO
CLEAN THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE
THERE RESTRICTIONS YOU RECEIVE
FUNDS. FROM THIS PROGRAM TO
PRESERVE THESE BEDS ARE THE
RESTRICTIONS ON YOUR ABILITY TO
THEN SELL OUR- YOU KNOW
VISIBILITY WHICH- MAYBE THE
BUILDINGS WERE THOUGHT BECOMES
FOURTH WORSE A LOT OF MONEY OR
SOMETHING. SO HOW WE GONNA
BALANCE THAT OUT- IN TERMS OF-
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO PRESERVE.
BEDS FOR- FAMILY SO JUST
RECOGNIZING IT'S PART OF THE
STATE WHERE HOUSING VALUES ARE
PROPERTY VALUES ARE GOING UP
DESPERATE MORE ACTIVE
DESCRIPTION. AND AND THEN PEOPLE
ALSO- AND IN TERMS OF- PEOPLE
SUBSCRIBING FOR THESE FUNDS. AND
AND BEING ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
WERE ABLE TO PRESERVE THESE
FACILITIES- IN THE LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT THERE MAY BE
ALTERNATIVE USES THAT ARE LESS
HELPFUL IN THE SOCIAL SERVICE
SIDE BUT- ACTUALLY MAKE. THREE
GIVE GREATER RETURN FOR THE
OWNERS- SOAKING EUSTICE SPEAK TO
HOW THAT MIGHT BE ADDRESSED AND
WHETHER WE'RE GONNA SEE AN ISSUE
WITH- PEOPLE SUBSCRIBING TO THIS
PARTICULAR. PROGRAM PARTICULARLY
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. SO ON THE
CAPITALIST. PROJECT THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR A USE
RESTRICTION. SO THERE THERE'S A
THIRTY YEAR USE RESTRICTION FOR
ANY NEW FACILITY THAT'S
CONSTRUCTED AND A TWENTY YEAR
USE RESTRICTION FOR ANY CURRENT
FACILITY OPERATOR. LOOKING TO
EXPAND THEIR SERVICES SO THAT'S
FOR THE POPULATION MOVING
FORWARD. OKAY AND- YOU DON'T AND
AGAIN I DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE
USE RESTRICTION AFTER ALL WE'RE
INVESTING MONEY INTO IT BUT DO
YOU SEE THAT THERE WE MIGHT HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES A CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE STATE WHERE SOMEONE MAY
NOT BE WILLING TO SIGN UP FOR A
TWENTY YEAR. RESTRICTION GIVEN
THAT THE- THE SPEED AT WHICH-
VALUE PROPERTY VALUES MAY BE
CHANGING ARE RISING PARTICULAR
AND THOSE PARTICULAR REGIONS OF
STATE. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE TRACKING AND WORKING TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DRYING
IN- APPLICANTS AND HELPING THEM
TO FACILITATE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS SO THAT. THE GOALS OF
THE PROGRAM CAN BE ACHIEVED OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELL I HOPE THAT NOW
AGAIN I DON'T REALLY HAVE A
SOLUTION MYSELF BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MONITOR AND SEE
BECAUSE WHAT I REALLY HATE TO DO
IS WE ALLOCATE THIS BUDGET THIS
MONEY. YOU PUT THE MONEY OUT
THERE AND PEOPLE DON'T SIGN UP
FOR EIGHT AND- AND THEN WE FIND
OUT THAT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE AS
MANY FACILITIES AS WE HELP WE
DON'T HAVE THE FOURTH OUT THE
SEVEN THOUSAND BEDS THAT YOU'RE
PROJECTING BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T
SIGNING UP FOR ITSELF- SO
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN PROVIDE US
WITH UPDATES ON THAT AS THIS
ROLLS OUT SO THAT WE ARE WHERE
YOU KNOW WE MAY HAVE CERTAIN
PARTS OF STATE WORDS GOOD OTHER
PARTS THAT. DIDN'T SELL AND
DISTINTA WE'RE FIGHTING THESE
FUNDS IN A NON COMPETITIVE WAY
TO ALL COUNTIES THAT'S GREAT I
THINK EVERYONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT BUT I SAID WHAT IS THE
UP TAKEN THESE VARIOUS COUNTIES
ESPECIALLY GIVEN YOUR PARTICULAR
CIRCUMSTANCES. ALL RIGHT SO NOW
I APPRECIATE IT I THINK THIS IS
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
PROGRAM WE WANT TO BE SUPPORT
OF- BUT I ALSO WANT TO BE SURE
THAT- IT WE WERE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT IT AND. I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WORKING HARD ON THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I. A I THINK DIRECTOR. AND
ANNA AND- ALL THE- AB. ALL THE
THERE HAVE HAVE BEEN VERY-
RECEPTIVE TO THE IDEA OF NO
WRONG DOOR AND MAKING IT AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE TO APPLY. NOT JUST
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THAT FOR THE
COUNTIES AND AGENCIES AS WELL-
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW EVER THE-
FROM THE STATE LEVEL DOWN TO
THE- TO THE CITY AND DRIVING
COUNTY LEVEL EVERYBODY
STRUGGLING WITH THE WORK FORCE
ISSUE. AND SO- THE EASIER WE CAN
MAKE IT TO GET THAT MONEY OUT.
AND GUARD AGAINST FRAUD- IS A
YEOMAN'S TASK AND WE- WE
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
EMBRACING IT- AND CONTINUE TO
LIFT IT UP IN A LIGHT SO THAT WE
CAN ALL TAKE A LOOK AT IT. HOW
WILL CONTINUE ON THIS PROCESS
TOGETHER- SO I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THAT IS ALL FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS TODAY. I EIGHT
WILL NOW GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. YES I'M
HERE OKAY AND CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE
. AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE. SEVEN
IN OUR QUEUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL START WITH THE FIRST COLOR
IN COLORS AGAIN. I'M HERE TO
TELL YOU THE NUMBER AGAIN IT
WILL BE POSTED AND YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK IF YOU
DO NOT GET TO SAY WHATEVER ALL.
OF A- EVERYTHING YOU WANT TO SEE
THAT ONE MINUTE PLEASE. CONTACT
THE COMMITTEE AND WE WILL BE
GLAD TO HEAR FROM YOU- GO AHEAD
MODERATOR WITH THE FIRST CALLER. WE WILL START WITH NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMEN AND
MEMBERS THAT YOU'RE A CALL WITH
NURSE CALIFORNIA- COMMITTEE ON
EIGHT CALFRESH ONE GREAT
THINKING THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR EFFORT
COMBINED ALL OF THE LONG OVERDUE
CALPERS AGREEMENT BUT IN
PARTICULAR THE EXPANSION AND WE
DO OURS THE LEGISLATURE TO BUILD
FURTHER ON THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL BY EXPANDING ACCESS THE
CALIFORNIA ALL AGES. WORK ON THE
DISINTEGRATION THAT ON THE
TELEPHONE AFTER HE'S GONNA THINK
IT APARTMENT AND COUNTIES FOR
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THIS
AGREEMENT THAT DOES HELP
STREAMLINE THE APPLICATION
APPROVAL. PROCESS REQUIRED.
MAKING SURE THE PLANNING
UNDERWAY RESULTS IN A- PROFIT
THAT THE BILL. ALL CAL CRYING.
WHY THE LEVEL OF ACCESS SHOULD
THE ON IN THE A CLIENT WITH. WE
ALSO APPLY THE DEVELOP OF THE
BOOK BY CALPERS HAPPEN PROCESS.
THE BATTLE HE DR NEARLY YEAR.
DOLLARS HOW. BUT WE RECOMMEND
THE DEPARTMENT CONSIDER
INCREASING THAT NUMBER OF. THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE DEATH THE
ELDERLY APPLICATION PROJECT BY
ALLOWING HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN ALSO BE INCLUDED IN
THAT PROJECT AT. THE TIME. AND
FINALLY WE NEED TO PORT IS OPEN
FOR CAL WHO AND- INCREASE YEAH
SB YEAH THE L. I- A LINE THEM
WITH THE REPEAT FEDERAL INCREASE
AT. THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALL PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER
FIFTY. GO AHEAD PLEASE. MOVING
ON MODERATE. I WILL MOVE ON TO
NUMBER SIXTY ONE. HI SEAN
BAILEY'S PRASADA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
COMMENTING ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
ALLOCATION OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME PER THE HOUSE-
PROGRAM EATING FOOD BANKS TO
PURCHASE CALIFORNIA PRODUCED
FOOD. AND WE REQUESTED AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY MILLION AND
FUNDS TO MITIGATE THE STILL
RECORD BREAKING DEMAND. WHICH IS
SPIKING AGAIN DUE TO THE HIGHEST
INFLATION IN FORTY YEARS HE
BANKS ARE STILL REPORTING HAVING
NEW CLIENTS SHOULD NEVER BEFORE. UTILIZED EIGHT. NEXT WE ASK TO
INCREASE AMONG AMOUNT OR THE S.
AND B. G. AND PROGRAM STRETCHING
. WITH THE CALFRESH INCREASE IN
BENEFITS IN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AFTER A RE EVALUATION
OF THE THRIFTY PLAN WHICH
DETERMINES HOW FRESH AND
FINANCE. I THINK WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
FEEDBACK FOR IMMIGRANTS FIFTY
FIVE AND OVER WE URGE YOU TO
BUILD ON THIS ALLOCATION BY
EXPANDING. THE FACT YOU
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NAY SEVEN
NUMBER SIX. CLICK OUR. FIFTY SIX
LIGA. HI MY NAME IS MENTIONED IN
THE NINETEEN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE COLLISION- I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THAT SHE THAT
CONSTRUCTION- I THANK THE
GOVERNOR ONE CONVENIENCE BUDGET-
WE URGE YOU TO TELL ON THE
ALLOCATION- AND WE WANT TO. BE
SPENT TO ALL AGES- AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE INCREASING THE
MONTHLY AMOUNTS FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL. NUTRITION
PATTERSON TRANSIT. ADDITIONAL-
ARBITRATION PROGRAMS THAT HELP
AFTER TIMES CONSTRUCTION FOOD.
PARITY WITH THEM I DON'T THINK
AND TAKE NOT TO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE DID YOU READ ABOUT OF
THE COULD. MORE ACTION MEASURE
REPORTING INTEREST THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR. GO AHEAD
COLOR THANK YOU MATTER TURNED
OUT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KATHY SUNDERLAND
MAJOLICA COUNTY WATER ACTORS
ASSOCIATION REGARDING ITEM PICKS
CAL WORK WE URGE YOU TO REJECT
THE NEARLY 10% CUT COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY THIS CALIFORNIA
COUNTY DISTRICT FUNDING TO
ELIGIBILITY OPERATION RESULTING
IN LESS FUNDING FOR NEEDED
EMPLOYMENT. SERVICES AND CASE
MANAGEMENT. I DIDN'T SEVEN AND
HEALTH YOU'RE SPEAKING MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THE TO THE NEW
BUDGET. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
RESUMING OUR WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
METHODOLOGY THAT THE COUNTY TO
RECEIVE NO CALL LIST SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE ONLY PARTIAL
FUNDING FOR CASE THAT INCREASES.
AND FEDERAL FUNDING FOR COFFEE
LEGISLATION SIGNED LAST YEAR
FUNDING IS NEEDED NOW THE HUNGRY
CALIFORNIANS YOU GET THE FOOD
BENEFITS TIMELY AND ACCURATELY
HI REGARDING THE CALPERS
TELEPHONIC REPORT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH PDFS
STAKEHOLDERS TO THAT COST OUT.
THESE IDEAS AS WELL AS IDENTIFY
WHICH PROPOSALS WILL WORK BEST
IN CHINESE ARE DIFFERENT SIZES
AND OPERATIONAL STRUCTURES.
BERMAN HE WAS HURTING I DON'T
MIND HOUSING WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND DOCTOR CAN OCCUR IN
THE HOUSING PROGRAMS THE.
HUNDREDS OPERATE. OCULIST FOR
EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS IS VERY.
INSTRUCTORS JOHNSON. THAT OUR
WORK IN EACH THOSE PARTS ARE AND
BEST TO THE-UNDER THE HIGH
NEEDS. WE IT'S MOST TO PROVIDE
CARE TO YOU NEED THOSE NEEDS THE
SENATE FUNDING CHANGE. YEAH OF
COURSE WE'RE HAPPY TALK FOR A
ABOUT THIS. OPPORTUNITY HANK
YOU KNOW DEPRIVE MILLIONS MANY
COMMENTS THE FORM ALLOW THEM
FOLLOWING UP CAN MEMBER. AND
STAFF OF APPROPRIATE YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TAX CALLER. NEXT
TO THEM THE NUMBERS. TO FIVE. GO
AHEAD CALLER. HELLO I GOT THANK
YOU SORRY ABOUT THAT HELLO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS THAT ON A CONFERENCE
PROGRAM MANAGER WITH THE SAN
DIEGO HUNGER COALITION AND I
LIVE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I'M
COUNTING ON ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
THEN YOU GO OVER COALITION HELPS
ROUGHLY TWENTY THOUSAND THANK
YOU A GOOD ACTORS TALK FIRST
EACH YEAR A PARTNERSHIP WITH
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT CALPERS
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
ORGANIZATION ALL UP THERE ARE
COUNTY WE KNOW THAT HUNGER IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED BY
OUR COMMUNITY AND EVEN MORE SO
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. AND
INDIGO COUNTY ONE IN THREE SAN
DIEGANS ARE EXPERIENCING
ENCRYPTION AND SECURITY- NO WAY
THING ABOUT THAT UNABLE TO
PROVIDE BEING BILL TODAY FOR
THEMSELVES OR THEIR FAMILIES AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT AS MANY AS 44%
OF SPANISH SPEAKING HOUSEHOLDS.
ARE STRUGGLING TO AFFORD. I WE
KNOW THAT AND IN OUR COUNTY NEED
TO YOU A GLOBAL ACCESS. TO FOOD
ASSISTANCE ALL VANITY A AND-
RESERVE THE GUY BUDGET. OF
HAPPIER SAMANTHA. REMEMBRANCE OF
THE FIVE IN OVER I MEAN URGE YOU
TO VOTE ON THIS ALLOCATION BY
EXPANDING THE BENEFITS. THE
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS VERY MUCH. THAT
IS. THANK YOU PLEASE. LINE SIXTY
SIX GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALEXANDER APOLOGISES IT WAS BY
COLLIDEDPROBLEM NUMBER THE
CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATION
THAT HAPPENS TRISH AND BENEFITS
FOR IMMIGRANTS FIFTY FIVE AND
OVER HOWEVER MANY MORE COULD BE
RESTRICTING PROVE THE PROGRAM TO
ACCURATELY REFLECT. THE ERRORS
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO DEVELOP
ALLOCATION BY EXPANDING FEEDBACK
BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
AGES REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS IT'S CRITICAL THAT YOU
BRING EQUITY TURNING CHRISTIAN
FIFTEEN THAT SHOULD. BE A MODEL
FOR THE REST OF THE NATION. WE
ALSO SUPPORT GOVERNOR'S. FOR THE
FOOD PROGRAM AND YOUR CARD IS
DID FIFTY TWO IN THE AND- TO TRY
OF RECORD BREAKING INCREASING
DEMAND FOR. FINALLY WE WERE IN
THE MONTHLY IN MY FOR THE
SACRAMENTO. BENEFIT ENTRY
INTRUSION BENEFIT PROGRAM SH
THAT HELP BUYERS. PURCHASE THE-
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LEVINE.
SEVENTY FOUR. MADAM CHAIR AND
FOUNDER PAN OF MY CURLS IN THE
WESTERN FOR A LONG POVERTY- I
WANTED TO COME IN A COUPLE OF
THE ISSUE TAT YOU DISCUSSED
TODAY FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
CONQUER AND- THE COMMENT BY
CUTTING HER HAND OVER HERE ABOUT
THE COMMITMENT TO INCREASING THE
POWERS GRANTED ABOVE THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL- WE HAVE TAKEN A
BIG STEP IN TOWERS IN RECENT
YEARS TO INCREASE THE GRANT BUT
THEY STILL. STANDS LEGAL OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
PARTICULARLY FOR THE TWO THIRDS
OF THE CASELOAD WHICH ONE PARENT
OR ANOTHER IS NOT ONLY HATE WILL
NEVER FORGET THE REDUCE GRANT
MANY MANY MANY CHILDREN ARE
LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY. IN OUR
STATE AND WE NEED TO UNDER.
SECONDLY ON CHAU SUPPORT WE SAID
TO GO FOR. TO PASS THROUGH ALL
CHILD SUPPORT. FORMALLY
ADMITTED- CASES FORMER POWER
CASES. BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PRINCIPLE SHOULD BE EXTENDED TO
THE CURRENT CASE OF ALSO. THE L.
E. L. E. O. POINTED OUT THESE
FAMILIES ARE- ALTHOUGH RPGAMER
AND THEY NEEDED TO SPEND- RIGHT
NOW. AND SO WE ORDERED THAT THEY
BE PROVISION BE EXTENDED TO THEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR. PINE SIXTY
EIGHT. AFTER JOHN COCHRAN OF THE
CHILD DIRECT ASSOCIATION IN
REFERENCE TO ISSUE FOR WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S.
TWELVE TWENTY POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND PROPOSALS A LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY
ADMINISTRATION HOWEVER ACCORDING
TO THE AGREED UPON LEVEL EFFORT
STUDY METHODOLOGY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WILL STILL BE THIRTY
LOCAL AGENCIES UNDER FUNDED TO
THE TUNE OF FOURTEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND. TO PERFORM THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENT OF THE
EXISTING CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY THE AGENDA DOES A
GREAT JOB OF DESCRIBING THE NEW.
RULE WE HAVE TO MEET LOCAL EVEN
PEOPLE NEED ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND EMPLOYMENT
EVEN COURT AND LAUDABLE PROGRAM
CHANGES A LOCAL AGENCY THE
MINISTER THIS IMPORTANT BANKING
AT PROGRAM THAT FOUND THAT THE
BENEFIT THE CHILD THE POOR ON
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN IN NEED.
WITH THE IMPACT ELECTION HAVE ON
PAIN PAYER BILL FOR FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW WE CAN FULLY
RESTORE LOCAL AGENCIES TO CREATE
A MORE EQUITABLE CHILD SUPPORT
THEM IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER. NINE
FIFTY TWO. ROBERT I WANT SECOND
HOMES COMMITTEE I WANT TO
DISCUSS HOW HOLD I'LL BE
HOMELESSNESS GROUPS WHY A LOT OF
PEOPLE OF HOMELESS HAD COME
STORE. PEOPLE CAN'T FIND UP TO
STAY DO YOU HAVE A HIGHLY CHOICE
BY. WE ALL HAVE A PROBLEM TO
HAVE A- ASIAN GET NEED A SERVICE
LAG- SERVICES BEING MADE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL NEXT PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY.
GOOD PLEASE JERRY SENATOR. MY
NAME IS OSCAR GOVERNMENT OF YOU
KNOW ABOUT WITH LOOKING UP FOR
HEALTH CALIFORNIA OR ELSE YOU
SEE WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALLOCATION OF USERS AND
BENEFITS FOR IMMIGRANTS FIFTY
FIVE AND OVER WE URGE YOU TO ADD
TO THIS ALLOCATION BY EXPANDING
KEEP UP BUT LETS YOU ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WHO FALL IS A
PERMANENT SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE LONG STANDING ISSUE OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WE MUST HAVE NO
EXCEPTIONS AND NO SOLUTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH RECALL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLINDS. ONE
BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS MARKED
GUERRERO LOS ANGELES BOARD.
UNDER ISSUE SIX WE URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE REDUCTION TO THE CUT
WORKING LOCATION TO THE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION AND
ADMINISTRATION DEPEND AUDIT-
THERE'S NUANCES THAT NEED TO BE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
APPRECIATE THAT- AND WE ALSO ARE
YOU TO APPROVE THE TWO HUNDRED
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
CALVET GRANT- BUT FOR THE SEVEN
POINT 1% INCREASE WE ALSO URGE
YOU TO APPROVE UNDER ITEM SEVEN.
B. CALPERS MINISTRATION BINDING
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGIATE
DISTANCE PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM AND THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC EDT EXTENSION THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE. THE
CALIFORNIA BUT IT COULD BE
AMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE ON THAT
BUT I'M GOING TO GO DOWN TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON A
COUPLE ITEMS WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
THE LOCAL TALK ABOUT EVEN TO THE
MONEY BECAUSE THE FULL FUNDING
OF THE LAST DAY OF OPEN DEBATE
AND A COMMON BACKGROUND I DO
HAVE HOPE TO CUT IN TAYLOR
COUNTY ELIGIBILITY OPERATION
STATE OUTRAGE AND THEN LASTLY.
OF ABILITY TO COMPROMISE WITH
THE QUESTIONERS COMMITTEE GOOGLE
BASICALLY ALL YOU HAVE TO BRIDGE
THE NEW BUDGET METHODOLOGY
ALLOWING I WAS ABOUT A MONTH AND
THAT WOULD BE TO CONNECT
FAMILIES. AND MARK. IF YOU DON'T
LIKE TO LOOK LIKE A BARGAIN
COULD MAKE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COURT. QUINE SIX SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT CHAIR AND
CAMPAÑA IS CAN YOU CHILD AN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE GOING
TO CENTER REGARDING THE ITEM I
WOULD ITEMS EIGHT PC SUPPORT THE
BUDGET OF. INTRUSION BETTER
TRAINING WILL TO AN OLD RECORDS
OF STATUS. WITH INVESTMENT IN
TANGLED TOWARD HARVARD FOR FOOD
FOR ALL OF. YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
BY REMOVING THAT COULD OF
EMIGRATE AS CREDIT. AS SOON AS
YOU COMMITTEE THE HIGH THE
HEALTH AND WELL OF MALE OF
HEALTH SHOULD. WE CALL ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR SECURE CONSTRUCTION IS
CONTROL CAL THAT EVER AGE. THE
INCLUDE INTERVENTIONAL THERE.
AND ADULTS OUR NEIGHBOR.
COLLEAGUES IN CAN MEMBERS. COULD
HELP YOUR MORE THAN JUST HER
BODY AND ALLOW TERM AND INTO
WILL FEEL HEALTH ECONOMY. AND
HELP YOU CAN AND OUR LOCAL
ACROSS THE STATE I NEVER GET TO
THAT THEY NEED TO CALIFORNIA CAN
BECOME MORE RESILIENT AND DRIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE A THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
NICOLE ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
DO NOT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CHILD
SUPPORT FUNDING AS WELL AS THE
FUNDING AUGMENTATION TO FULLY
FUND LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT IS
A CRITICAL ASPECT OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO FIGHT CHILD POVERTY.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD ALLOW
LTSA SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
PROVIDING FOOD SHELTER CLOTHING
AND OTHER BASIC CLOSING EXPENSES
OF CHILDREN. IN ON THE OF THE
CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE C. HAPPEN
EXPANSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
FIVE. HI THIS IS HANDING OVER
THE JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF LOS
ANGELES A MULTI SERVICE PROVIDER
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR
SERVICES AND OTHER CONTENT OF
THOUSAND LOS ANGELENOS EACH YEAR
I JUST WANT TO ASK OUR SUPPORT
FOR OUR PARTNERS COMMENTS FROM
WESTERN PANAMA POVERTY NURSE
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS. WILLIAM GRAHAM CALLING
CENTER AND THE REST OF ME WE
SHARE THEIR SUPPORT FOR. MORE
RESOURCES FOR OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHANGE
AND I AGREED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION OR SEEN YOU WAY-
INTO A REPRESENTS PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES THAT ARE PROVIDING
POWER TO ABOUT TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO THE CALIFORNIA
RETURNS PAYMENT AB PROGRAM. THE
WAY IS WRINKLED LED TO THE
SENATE FOR THE LEADERSHIP AND
SHOWN IN ESTABLISHING THE
PROGRAM IS VERY SUCCESSFUL IT'S
DISPERSED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN UTILITY RELIEF TO
DISAPPEAR YOUR CUSTOMERS THAT
NEEDED IT DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
IT'S AN EFFICIENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE PROGRAM IS A VERY
GOOD EXAMPLE OF GOVERNMENT AT
WORK I HAD TO HELP NEED
CALIFORNIANS- AND ON BEHALF OF
STEAM AWAY WEEK WE JUST REALLY
LIKE TO THANK DIRECTOR SCRIBNER
AND ALL THAT EXTREMELY CAPABLE
STAFF YES HE- FOR BEING SUCH A
GOOD PARTNER IN THE PROGRAM.
THAT WHILE IT'S. GEN THERE IS AN
ABOUT ANOTHER HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION LAUGHTER JUST FROM THE
ORIGINAL TIME PERIOD AND SINCE
JAN FIFTEEN YOU BACK ANOTHER
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CAREER
AGES SO THE BOTTOM LINE WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE GOOD WORK OF
THE SENATE AND SEE IF THEY CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. ON THIS ISSUE GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ENSURES HERE WHERE THERE
ARE FIFTEEN STILL LEFT IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER NINETY FIVE.
JOHN ROBERTS CERVANTES LESS FILE
ALREADY WHEN THE COMMONS OR KALI
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ARE ALSO. OUR. SEARCH ENGINE
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR PLEASE.
NEXT IS A. NINE GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE EGGMAN CENTER PAN I'M JEFF
MARSTON REPRESENTING FEEDING SAN
DIEGO COMMENTING ON ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN I WISH TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS EXACTLY
CHRISTIAN BENEFITS IMMIGRANTS
FIFTY FIVE AND OVER AS WE
BELIEVE EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO NUTRITION BENEFITS WE
ARE HERE TO BUILD ON THIS
ALLEGATION BY SPENDING C. PAP C.
PAP BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL AGES REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE DR GRANT QUESTIONS
EARLIER TODAY ABOUT THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE. COULD CAUSE A
PERMANENT SOLUTION WHICH
ADDRESSES A LONG STANDING ISSUE
OF FOOD INSECURITY DEMOCRATS
MANAGERS MEETING SAN DIEGO'S IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE OF WHAT MEDICAID
HUNGER AND POVERTY ENSURING OUR
STATION TRISTIAN SYSTEMS DO NOT
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS ON BEHALF OF
HEATING SAN DIEGO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NO TO. WELL WELL FOR ALL
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MY NAME IS SEAN YOUNG AND I WORK
FOR THE FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT GATHERED THE STRUCTURE
OF OFFICE I'M CALLING A COMMON
FORMED BY I'LL BE COMMENDED
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSALS AMBROSIA
CALIFORNIA CHILD SUPPORT THE
TEMPERATURE THAT LOW INCOME
PARENTS CHILD SUPPORT AND GO
WHERE THEY SHOULD THE CHILDREN
AND NOT BE INTERCEPTED. BY THE
GOVERNMENT WHAT IS DEFINITELY
ONE OF THE- THEM. AND THE
GOVERNOR TO GO FOR A- THE JOB
OVER TO ENSURE THAT ONE HOW
PERCENT ALL PARENTS CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS. REGION
CHILDREN AND NOT BE INTERCEPTED
BY THE GOVERNMENT INCLUDING
FAMILIES CURRENTLY RECEIVING
ASSISTANCE RECALL WORK. AND I
CAL ASSEMBLY PUT THESE ARE
FAMILIES IN POVERTY THEY NEED
THOSE CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS
MORE THAN THE GOVERNMENT DOES WE
SHOULD NOT BE INTERCEPTING THEM.
WHAT ARE OFFICE PILOTED A
HUNDRED ARE 1100% PASS THROUGH
OF ALL CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS
THAT IS CO. DOCUMENTED BENEFITS
ACCORDING TO ANA AND AN
EVALUATION OF THE PILOT BY THE
URBAN INSTITUTE. APPARENTLY
BARGER AND MORE CONSISTENT
PAYMENTS. ALL THEIR PAYMENTS ARE
GOING TO THEIR CHILDREN'S
CHILDREN MOTHERS AND FATHERS
REPORTED INCREASED WELL BEING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR.
CALL NEXT CONTROLLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO SEVENTY FIVE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JULIA CURRENT WITH THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK AND I
WAS IN GLENDALE CALIFORNIA. I'M
ALSO CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER SEVEN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATION OF
SEATS THAT NUTRITION BENEFITS.
IN SIXTY FIVE AND OVER WE ALSO
ARGUE TO BUILD UPON THIS
ALLOCATION BY EXPANDING FEEDBACK
AND JUST CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
AGES REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. WE BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO NUTRITION
BENEFITS REGARDLESS OF THEIR AGE
OR INTEGRATION STATUS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS. TO NINETY
SIX. AND MY NAME IS ANKIT IT'S
AND I'M THAT POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD
BANK SERVING SAN FRANCISCO AND
MARIN COUNTIES AND ON BEHALF OF
THE FIFTY THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS
WHO RELY ON OUR FREE FOOD
SERVICE EVERY SINGLE WEEK TO
FEED THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I SHERMAN PART OF A
PRIORITIES ARE COVERED TODAY
FIRST OUR BUDGET IS IN OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
ALLOCATION. OF FIFTY MILLION ONE
TIME. GRAHAM DIED TO EIGHT. DAYS
PRETTY TALK. PRODUCES AND ABOUT
ACOSTA. IF YOU TO MILLION. AND
THE- A RECORD BREAKING IN THE-
WE ARE SEEING TWENTY THOUSAND
MORE. EVERY WEEKEND. THE END OF
NEXT THEN YOU JUST GOING AWAY. I
DON'T SEVEN ARCHITECTURES ARE
THE ONLY SOURCE OF FOOD UNDER.
NEIGHBORS MANY TIMES OR
EXCLUSION FROM OTHER STATES
PROGRAMS THAT WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATIONS HE
GOTTEN FISHING BENEFITS. FOR
IMMIGRANTS EIGHTY FIVE AN OLDER.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO DAHLE
AND FOUNDATIONS I THANK YOU THAT
BENEFITS CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
AGES REGARDING IMMIGRATION
STATUS THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR
PLEASE NEXT TO BE NUMBERED
SEVEN. SH GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS THE ONE THAT I'VE DONE WITH A
CALIFORNIA IN THE COMPOSITE
CENTER AND I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALLOCATION AND KEY PAD NUTRITION
BENEFITS FOR IMMIGRANTS AS
DEFINED IN OVER A WEEK- YOU TO
BUILD ON THE DELEGATION BY BENNY
HE HAD BEEN A CALIFORNIANS. OF
ALL AGES REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS WE BELIEVE
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
J. CAN BENEFIT REGARDLESS OF
THEIR AGE OR IMMIGRATION STATUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
NUMBER. ONE HUNDRED. THANK YOU
ALL I'M FRANK CAMARILLO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HUNGER
ACTION LOS ANGELES REGARDING
ITEM SEVEN WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S SEAT AT
EXPANSION AND HAS BEEN CALFRESH
ELIGIBILITY EVEN FURTHER TO ALL
IMMIGRANTS OF ALL AGES IN
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT MORE AND MORE OF
OUR CALPERS DOLLARS ARE STAYING
IN THE STATE AND ARE SUPPORTING
LOCAL CALIFORNIA FARMERS DUE TO
THE INCREASING SUCCESS OF
PROGRAMS SUCH AS MARKET MATCHING
OTHER HEALTHY FOOD INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS IN THAT SAME VEIN HELP
INVOLVED LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND
CALIFORNIA FARMERS WE ALSO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CALHOUN. FINALLY PLEASE SUPPORT
THE MONTHLY INCREASES FOR F. AND
B. AND HE CAN DO TO HELP OUR
DISABLED AND SENIOR AND I WAS
THINKING THANK YOU THANKS AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS. SEVENTY
SIX. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- BECKY SILVA
WITH A CALIFORNIA PHYSICIAN AT
THE BANK I WAS REALLY GRATEFUL
TO HAVE PDFS FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE WORK OVER THE LAST
YEAR TO HELP INSURE CALFRESH ACT
UP IN THAT ARE REALLY BIG
INCREASE IN CASELOAD AGREE HEARD
EARLIER AND ALSO FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE GRANULE
PANDEMIC YOU GET HE PROGRAM AND
WORKING HARD TO ENSURE THAT IT
MANY BECAUSE OF POSSIBLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE COULD RECEIVE IT. I'M
HERE AT THE ISN'T PART OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSALS OUTLINED
IN ISSUESSEVEN EIGHT AND IN
PARTICULAR WE CAN CALL THE
COUNTY WORK ALL WELFARE
DEPARTMENT THAT ARE PROVIDING
CRITICAL ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SERVICES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
CAN YOU SUPPORT THEIR REQUEST
FOR ADEQUATE COUNTY FUNDING TO
ADMINISTER THE CALPERS PROGRAM
ESPECIALLY IF THE AMOUNT FOR THE
PROGRAM CONTINUES TO INCREASE.
AND WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL TO SEE
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
DEVELOPING A SIMPLIFIED CAL
FRESH. APPLICATION FOR OLDER
ADULTS. I AS WE TRAIN AWAY FROM
COAL THAT REALLY EXACT ORDERS
AND PROGRAM. WE REALLY THE LIVE
. TO MAKE SURE DO SO WITH A
STATE OUT OF. THAT PREVENTS
SHOCKS THE PEOPLE. AND I THINK
YOU KNOW PROGRAMS PEOPLE STILL
REAL. ON PREVENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR MUCH THANK
COLOR PLEASE. NEXT WE GO TO
NUMBER FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JEREMY STATING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES REPRESENTING OPEN
GATE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
I'M GOING TO TAKE ON TWO ISSUES.
ON THE LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES ITEM ISSUE FOR WE
APPRECIATE THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS YOUR WORK IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET ON TO
BRING LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES- UP TO PAR WITH CAPABLE
BUT WE ARE ALSO JOINING THE
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES IN REQUESTING
AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. ONLY MEET THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY DESCRIBED IN THE
HEARING AND TO HELP ME THE NEW
FEDERAL FINAL RULE LASTLY THE
FUNDING OF COURSE INDIAN CREEK
COURT FAMILIES AND HELPS REDUCE
POVERTY. I DON'T THINK FROM THE
CALFRESH ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING
LOCAL MINISTRATION FUNDING WE
APPRECIATE THAT APARTMENT-
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO-
DEVELOPING A METHODOLOGY
HOWEVER- WE JOINED THE WGA AND
AT THE ARE YOU REQUESTING NOT
ONLY AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY MILLION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
STATION BUT THE SPEED UP THE
PROCESS THANK. YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NO WILL BE A SEVEN.
EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING AND THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME TWENTY AND THEN
AND THE AGRICULTURE POLICY
MANAGER FOR A NONPROFIT THINK
TANK BIRTH E. THREE Q. EIGHTEEN
PREFERRED TO CREATE MORE LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT TODAY
THIRD PATHWAY FIRST IT IS
IMPORTANT MAKE IT EASIER TO
ACCESS HEALTH FRESH AND I THINK
THE PORTABLE FINE. CALFRESH
APPLICATIONS FOR OLDER ADULTS.
THANK YOU WE CAN EXPAND THE
TAKING THAT REFORM. THE REPORT
THE- OF FEEDBACK. AND FINALLY WE
NEED MAY CALPERS BENEFITS. ONE
YOU DO THAT IT'S A DIFFERENT.
SACRAMENTO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA FRUIT VEGETABLE EACH
INTEGRATION PILOT TO INCREASE
THE PURCHASING POWER OF LOW
INCOME. CALIFORNIANS BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO
CALPERS FOR CONTENT. WITH OF
COURSE DISCUSSING THE EXPANSION
OF THE PILOT COMMITTEE AT A
LATER DATE. THANK YOU AGAIN AND
HAVE A GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT IS NUMBER ONE- FOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BETTY GAMBIT
TO CHEAT- SPECIAL CHRONICLING
THEIR CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE- I
LIVE IN FRESNO AND WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATION
OF FEEDBACK UNDERTAKEN BENEFITS
FOR IMMIGRANTS FIFTY FIVE AND
OLDER WE URGE YOU TO BILL ON
THIS ALLOCATION BY EXPANDING THE
THAT BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA. ALL
AGES REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THANK YO VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING US TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIX COLOR PLEASE. THANK IS. ONE OH TWO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR BUT I THINK IF YOU KNOW
WHAT HE CAN PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF AND ASSEMBLY PARTNERSHIP
ONE OF THE EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS OPERATING IN CALVERT
COUNTY THANK THE GREATLY
APPRECIATE APARTMENT PARTNERSHIP
AND ROLLING OUT THE CAL WORKS
UNDER THE NAME PROGRAM GIVEN THE
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
INSULIN RETREAT CHU DIFFERENT
STATE PROGRAMS GOING TO WORK IN
THE LEGISLATURE DEMONSTRATION IF
YOU'RE TRULY GET TO A NO WRONG
DOOR MODEL OF SERVICE DELIVERY
FOR ALL EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING PROGRAM DECLINED IN ANY
COUNTY IN WHICH THEY OPERATE. WE
ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
BUDGETED FUNDING GETTING TO
COUNTY SAN ROLE IN THE FAMILY
COMMITTEE AND RECEIPT OF OUR
LETTER AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO ENSURE THE
GOLD UNDER THE NAME FROM IT TO
HELP LOW INCOME FAMILIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS. EIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MANY
ARE GREAT AND THE POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH NURSE CALIFORNIA
WE ARE A CO SPONSOR OF THE FOOD
FOR ALL PROPOSAL AND CONVENE A
COALITION OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF FOOD
ASSISTANCE FOR ALL IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM
CALFRESH EITHER IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE ARE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE GOVERNOR'S BY
PROPOSED BUDGET ALLOCATION OF
SPEAK UP. EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS
TO IMMIGRANTS FIFTY FIVE IN OUR
PROGRAM WE ALSO URGE YOU TO
BUILD ON ITS ALLOCATION BY
EXPANDING FEEDBACK BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
. CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANTS. HIGH
LEVELS OF PRUDENT. AS A RESULT
OF RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES. I THINK EXCLUSION
WITHIN OUR STATE NUTRITIONAL
CONTENT. TO FOR ALL OF THE
PERMANENT SOLUTION THAT
ADDRESSES A LONG STANDING ISSUE
OF FOOD INSECURITY IN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. NOW THE TIME FOR A
STATE TO CHAMPION EQUITABLE
POLICY THAT DISMANTLE RACISM
VEHICLE THE EXCLUSION OF.
FIGHTING BASKING IN FEEDBACK
NUTRITION BENEFITS FOR
IMMIGRANTS OF ALL AGES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS. NINETY
ONE. A NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CRAIG
SCOTT I'M WITH RAINBOW BEGINNING
TO THE ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES
THE LGBTQ ASYLUM SEEKERS WE-
SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN THE
EXPANSION OF C. PAP WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A FULL OUR COVERAGE
AS MOST OF OUR CLIENTS ARE NOT
IN THAT AGE GROUP BUT THIS IS A
GREAT BEGINNING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A QUICK EXPANSION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO
NUMBER NINETY TWO. SERIKAT WITH
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON
ISSUES FOR WILL COUNTY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWENTY POINT
ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
HOWEVER WE AUTHORS A LEGISLATURE
MINISTRATION TO FULLY FIND OF A
CHILD OR AGENCIES WHICH REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION AND I'M PASTORING
PROGRAM PROBLEMATIC
REQUIREMENTS. IN ADDITION WITH
THE COURT FIFTEEN POINT SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION TWO LTSA
INSTRUMENTATION OF ANY FEDERAL
FINAL RULE REQUIREMENTS THE
GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AS NEEDED
TO CREATE A MORE EQUITABLE CHILD
SUPPORT I'M IMPROVE THE WELL
BEING OF. CHILDREN IN PAYMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX PLEASE. NEXT IS A ONE OH
FIVE. THANK YOU MANAGER
INCLUDING MEMBERS TO ME ALSO
WITH THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND
CHILD FOR COLLISION COMMITTEE
NOT ITEM. COALITION SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO VENT ALL
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS FOR
FORMALLY ACCEPTED FAMILY
DIRECTLY FAMILIES WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXTEND ALL THE
GOOD FAMILIES CURRENTLY ON HOW
IT WORKS BONTA MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN ARE OFTEN UNAWARE OF
HOW MUCH OTHERS ACTUALLY TAKE A
CHILD SUPPORT THE REPEAT A
LITTLE BIT OF THE PAYMENT THIS
CREATE CONFLICT AND DISTRACT
ADULT IS INTERCEPTED MONEY USED
TO FUND PUBLIC FOR THE PROGRAM'S
DRIVE KNOXVILLE PARENTS OFTEN
BLACK AND BROWN BAG. JEFF
IMMEDIATELY LEFT CONTACT WITH
CHILDREN ENGAGE WITH THEM AND
PROVIDE LESS FREQUENT IN CONCORD
BUT POLICY QUITE LITERALLY
PREVENT DATA FROM BEING DOWN
WITH AND HOW 2% OF CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS FOR FAMILIES CURRENTLY
IN PUBLIC AT THE JET TO FAMILY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE OH SIX. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ALL YOU ARE- BEHALF
OF OUR FIRM IN ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOAQUIN. ON THE TO CHILD SUPPORT
ISSUES ECHOING OTHER COUNTY
COMMENTS I JUST WANT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND OTHER MEMBERS-
FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS IS JUST VITAL
TO GETTING THE FUNDING
ESPECIALLY WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE
OH EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
EGGMAN SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS A
COMMON TORIA RESULT EXPERT ON
POVERTY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATION AND
FAST NUTRITION THEN. AND FIVE IN
A- HELLO WE BOTH EVERYONE SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO NUTRITION
BENEFITS REGARDLESS OF THEIR AGE
ARGUMENT GRAYSON YEAH. WE ASK
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
FROM PROPERTY SURE YOU PUT IT
INTO ALL CALIFORNIANS NO
EXCEPTIONS NO EXCLUSION. THANK
YOU AND GOOD NIGHT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE
ONE TWELVE. NUMBER ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HI HELLO
. YES YES WE'RE- HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE TRUTH YEAH CHILD OR
COALITION OF ALSO FOUNDER OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY DRIVE- WE
COMMEND THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
NEWTON PROPOSAL TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD SUPPORT
SYSTEM AND ENSURE THAT CHILD
SUPPORT DOLLARS GO WHERE NATION.
TO CHILDREN. HOWEVER REQUIRING
PARENTS TO HELP. FIRING PARENTS
FUND PUBLIC ASSIST FROM THEIR
CHILD PAYMENTS WHY DID EXISTING
. BY DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND COLOR AND ASPECTS THIS IS
WHY WE URGE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO CREEP UP A LITTLE
FURTHER. AND TO- TO MAKE THIS A
FULL PASSED THROUGH 1100% OF
CHILD SUPPORT DOLLARS SHOULD GO
TO THAT WE EXPERIENCE IN
GOVERNMENT. I THAT OCCUR UNDER A
LARGE AND CAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR- AND FOR THE PUBLIC
LISTING IN IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE YOU WANNA SAY FOR YOU TO
GET A CHANCE PLEASE MAKE SURE
YOU REACH OUT TO THE COMMITTEE-
FOR THAT FEEDBACK. AND I WILL
SAY ON MONDAY CALLED WITH SOME
IDEAS ON MARCH THIRD WE'LL BE
HEARING ALL THE BUDGET REQUEST
SO PLEASE GET PREPARED FOR MARCH
THIRD WILL BE THE HOLD OUR WHOLE
HEARING WILL BE. A HEARING
ISSUES THAT PEOPLE BRING
FORWARD- AND THAT THEN THERE'S
NO FOR THEIR BUSINESS CONCLUDES
OUR HEARING FOR TODAY WE THANK
EVERYBODY- AND ESPECIALLY WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY DIFFICULTIES WE
POWERED ON THROUGH SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THIS- COMMITTEE IS
DURING.